OF WILL BEGIN.
THE HIGHER ED COMMITTEE HEARING.
TODAY'S AGENDA HAS TWENTY THREE
ITEMS. FIVE ARE ON PROPOSED
CONSENT.
THEY ARE FILE ITEM THREE A. B..
TWO FIVE THREE FILE ITEM.
SIX AB FIVE FOURTEEN FILE ITEM.
TEN A. B. EIGHT OR NINE FILE
ITEM.
TWELVE AB EIGHT FIVE THREE AND
FILE ITEM.
FIFTEEN AB.
ONE THOUSAND ADDITIONALLY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER READY JONES
SAWYER HAS BEEN APPOINTED. TO
REPLACE ASSEMBLY MEMBER JOAQUIN
ARAMBULA FOR TODAY'S HEARING WE
ALSO WANT TO WELCOME ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JONES SAWYER.
WAS GOOD TO HAVE BACK ON THIS
COMMITTEE.
LASTLY PLEASE NOTE THAT OUR
GENERAL GUIDELINE FOR BILLS
HEARD IN THIS COMMITTEE IS TO
ALLOW TESTIMONY OF TWO WITNESSES
FOR SUPPORT.
AND TWO WITNESSES FOR OPPOSITION
TO SPEAK FOR TWO MINUTES EACH.
STAKEHOLDER GROUPS IN ENTITIES
THAT ARE NEITHER IN SUPPORT NO
OPPOSITION NOR IN OPPOSITION
WILL BE ALLOWED TO GIVE
TESTIMONY. FOR NO MORE THAN TWO
MINUTES WHEN I CALL FOR TWEETERS.
THE MEASURE HAS MORE THAN TWO
ENTITIES IN A TWEENER CATEGORY
ONLY TWO MINUTES WILL BE ALLOWED
TO THEM TO SPEAK FOR ONLY TWO OF
THEM WILL BE ALLOWED TO SPEAK
FOR TWO MINUTES EACH.
AND SINCE WE DON'T HAVE A QUORUM
YET.
WE WILL BEGIN AS A COMMITTEE.
AND AS CHAIR OF THE COMMITTEE.
TO INVOKE CHAIR PRIVILEGE TO
BEGIN.
WITH THE BILL THAT I'M
INTRODUCING -- I HAVE HERE
WITNESSES THAT NEED TO GET A ON
A FLIGHT BACK SO I'M GONNA HAND
OVER THE GAVEL. TO OUR VICE
CHAIR AND WE WILL BEGIN WITH
ITEM [inaudible]
I'D -- NO. TWENTY EIGHT OF
TWENTY THREE THANK YOU
[inaudible]
OKAY CHAIRPERSON.
SERENA BEGIN -- WITH THE ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY THREE AB
[inaudible]
SEVENTEEN FORTY SHE CONFESSES.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
WELL I GOT THE PROMOTION ON THE
VICE CHAIR.
YOU ARE HERE [inaudible]
NOW.
SO THE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS.
TODAY'S MY HONOR AND PRIVILEGE
TO PRESENT.
ASSEMBLY BILL.
SEVENTEEN FORTY THE INLAND
EMPIRE.
LIKE MUCH OF CENTRAL CALIFORNIA.
FACES A SERIES SHORT SHORTAGE OF
PHYSICIANS.
AND TRAILS BEHIND MOST OF
CALIFORNIA IN MANY OF OUR HEALTH
OUTCOMES.
SUCH AS DIABETES CORONARY HEART
DISEASE.
AND LACKS DIVERSITY IN THE
MEDICAL FIELD.
THE RICH THIS REGION OF
CALIFORNIA THAT I REPRESENT HAS
THE LOWEST SUPPLY OF VISIONS
POSITIONS.
PER CAPITA THAN ANY OTHER REGION
OF THE STATE.
ACCORDING TO THE CALIFORNIA
HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION.
IN PRIMARY CARE CARE SPECIALIST
ALONE.
MANY CALIFORNIA COUNTIES HAVE
FAR FEWER THAN SIXTY TO EIGHTY
PRIMARY CARE PHYSICIANS PER ONE
THOUSAND PEOPLE.
CONSIDERED SUFFICIENT TO MEET
THE MAN.
IN THE INLAND EMPIRE.
THERE ARE A MERE THIRTY FIVE
PRIMARY CARE PHYSICIANS PER ONE
THOUSAND PEOPLE.
STUDIES SHOW THAT THE GREATEST
INDICATORS OF WHERE PHYSICIANS
PRACTICE IS WHERE THEY GROW UP.
ADD OR COMPLETE THEIR MEDICAL
TRAINING.
THUS A MEDICAL SCHOOL WITH
ASSOCIATED RESIDENCY TRAINING
PROGRAMS IS THE MOST EFFECTIVE
MEANS OF ADDRESSING THE REGION'S
DOCTOR SHORTAGE.
THE MISSION OF THE UC RIVERSIDE
SCHOOL OF MEDICINE.
IS TO IMPROVE THE HEALTH.
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA AND TO
SERVE THE INLAND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
BY TRAINING A DIVERSE WORK FORCE
OF PHYSICIANS.
AND BY DEVELOPING IN A VERY
INNOVATIVE RESEARCH AND HEALTH
CARE DELIVERY PROGRAMS.
pAND ROLLED AND IT'S A KNACK
INAUGURAL CLASS.
OF AUGUST.
TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN AND WILL
GRADUATE ITS THIRD CLASS IN MAY
OF THIS YEAR.
THE CURRENT FACILITY.
AND COMMITMENT OF STATE
RESOURCES DOES NOT PROVIDE FOR
ADEQUATE STAFFING.
TEACHING FACULTY OR STUDENT
STUDY.
TEACHING AND ADMINISTRATIVE
SPACE.
EXPANSION OF THE UC OUR SCHOOL
OF MEDICINE FACILITY.
IS URGENTLY REQUIRED IN ORDER TO
ACCOMMODATE THE PLANNED GROWTH.
OF UP TO FIVE HUNDRED PHYSICIANS
IN TRAINING.
THEIR BY INCREASING THE SUPPLY
OF PHYSICIANS AND UNDERSERVED
AREAS OF THE STATE.
AND THE STATE'S ANNUAL FUNDING
APPROPRIATION.
MUST BE INCREASED IN ORDER TO
SUPPORT THE CURRENT AND FUTURE.
YOU SEE ARE SCHOOL OF MEDICINE
OPERATION.
HERE WITH ME TODAY ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY BILL.
SEVENTEEN FORTY IS THE DEAN OF
THE UC OUR SCHOOL OF MEDICINE
DOCTOR DEBORAH DEEDS.
AND FRANCISCO FOUR DYESS OF THE
CLASS OF TWO THOUSAND SCHOOL OF
MEDICINE AT UC ARE.
AND A WILL HAVE DOCTOR DIS.
OF BEGIN.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN WELCOME.
CHAIRMAN MEDINA AND MEMBERS OF
THE ASSEMBLY HIGHER EDUCATION
COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR ATTENTION TO
THE HEALTHCARE WORKFORCE NEEDS
OF CALIFORNIA.
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
RIVERSIDE IS SUPPORTIVE OF THE
CHAIRS BILL A. B..
SEVENTEEN FORTY THIS BILL WILL
ALLOW THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL RIVERSIDE
SCHOOL OF MEDICINE. TO REALIZE
ITS MISSION OF EXPANDING AND
DIVERSIFYING THE PHYSICIAN
WORKFORCE AT INLAND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
ARE THE INLAND EMPIRE.
WHILE WE ARE A YOUNG MEDICAL
SCHOOL.
I AM PLEASED TO REPORT.
THAT WE HAVE ALREADY MADE A DOWN
PAYMENT ON THIS MISSION.
ALL STUDENTS A RACIALLY AND
ETHNICALLY DIVERSE.
COME FROM DISADVANTAGED
BACKGROUNDS.
AND INCLUDE MANY STUDENTS WHO
ARE THE FIRST IN THEIR FAMILIES
TO COMPLETE A BACHELORS DEGREE.
LIKE I'LL STUDENTS FRANCISCO FAR
YES.
ALL STUDENTS IN BODY.
THE COMMUNITY OF FUTURE
POSITIONS THAT WE ARE TRAINING.
AND MORE THAN 80% ARE PURSUING
RESIDENCY TRAINING IN CALIFORNIA.
WITH MORE THAN TWO THIRDS
REMAINING IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
AND NEARLY A THIRD IN THE INLAND
EMPIRE -- INLAND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
YOU SEE ARE SCHOOL OF MEDICINE
IS UNDER FUNDED.
AS SUCH.
THE SCHOOL OF MEDICINE LACKS THE
RESOURCES TO FULLY MEET THE
NEEDS OF THE MEDICAL SCHOOL.
THE ASSOCIATION OF AMERICAN
MEDICAL COLLEGES.
ACES OUR MEDICAL SCHOOL IN THE
BOTTOM TWENTY FIRST PERCENT
HOUSE.
AMONG PUBLIC SCHOOLS IN TERMS OF
ESTIMATED STATE FUNDING.
DUE TO ALL UNDER FUNDED STATUS.
THE UC OUR MEDICAL SCHOOL IS HE
SENSUALLY.
AT SEVEN CAP THAT SEVENTY
INCOMING STUDENTS EACH YEAR.
MOST MEDICAL SCHOOLS AND ROLL
MORE THAN A HUNDRED STUDENTS
EACH YEAR.
THEREFORE IT IS ESSENTIAL.
WHERE YOU SEE OUR OF MEDICAL
SCHOOL TO GROW TO MEET THE
PHYSICIAN WORKFORCE NEEDS OF
CALIFORNIANS?
THE FUNDING NEEDS OUTLINED IN AB.
SEVENTEEN FORTY ALIGN WITH THE
RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE
CALIFORNIA FUTURE HELP WORKFORCE
COMMISSION.
THE COMMISSION AND PART CALLED
FOR INCREASED.
HERMAN AT OPERATING RESOURCES TO
EXPAND MEDICAL STUDENT
ENROLLMENT.
AT YOU SEE ARE SCHOOL OF
MEDICINE.
AND I CAPITAL INVESTMENT. TO AN
ABLE TO GROW.
WE ARE GRATIFIED BY THE
COMMISSION TO RECOGNITION.
OF HOW YOU SEE ARE SCHOOL OF
MEDICINE CAN CONTRIBUTE TO
SOLVING THE HEALTH CARE
WORKFORCE SHORTAGE.
IN THE STATE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
OF AB.
SEVENTEEN FORTY I AM PLEASED TO
ANSWER YOUR QUESTION
[inaudible]
NEXT WITNESS.
THANK YOU DEAN DAYS AND THANK
YOU TO YOU AS WELL -- HONORABLE
CHAIR SIMILAR RADINA AND THE
REST OF THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE -- MY NAME IS
FRANCISCO FORTY S. AND I AM
CURRENTLY A FOURTH YEAR MEDICAL
STUDENT AT THE UC OUR SCHOOL OF
MEDICINE.
I'M OFTEN ASKED THE QUESTION.
WHY DID I CHOOSE TO PURSUE
MEDICINE? FOR MY PASSION DESIRE
TO PURSUE A MEDICAL DEGREE STEMS
BACK. TO ONE PHYSICIAN.
TYPICALLY THIS WAS OUR PRIMARY
CARE DOCTOR.
WHO FOR SO MANY YEARS DISPLAYED
A LEVEL OF COMPASSION WHEN
TREATING MY MOTHER?
YOU HAVE TO LIVE WITH A VERY
CHRONIC AND DEBILITATING
CONDITION [inaudible]
AND THIS CONDITION OFTEN LEFT
HER FEELING VERY HOPELESS AND
AND DESOLATE AT TIMES.
HOWEVER WITNESSING MY
PHYSICIAN'S ABILITY TO SPEAK OUR
NATIVE LANGUAGE.
UNDERSTAND MY MOTHER'S
FORTUNATELY.
AND SEEING HIM RESTORE HOPE
WHERE THERE WAS ONCE NONE.
LEFT IN ON IMMEASURABLE IMPACT
ON MY LIFE.
AND FROM THAT POINT MOVING
FORWARD AND YOU WHAT TYPE OF
PHYSICIAN I WANTED TO BE.
THE KIND OF DOCTOR WHO WAS BOTH
CULTURALLY COMPETENT AND
COMPASSIONATE.
AND WHO NOT ONLY RELIED ON
MEDICINE TO BRING HEALING BUT
COULD ALSO USE A GENTLE WORD AND
THAT KIND TOUCH IS PART OF HIS
ARSENAL.
I CAN DECLARE WITH GREAT PRIDE
THAT YOU SEE ARE IN PART OF A
DIVERSE.
GROUP OF PEOPLE WHO ARE ALL
STRIVING TO IMPROVE THE HEALTH
OF OUR NEIGHBORING COMMUNITIES.
BUT DO NOT TAKE MY WORD FOR IT
THE NUMBERS SPEAK FOR THEMSELVES.
40% OF MY COHORT ARE UNDER
REPRESENTED IN MEDICINE. 564% OF
OUR CLASSES COMPRISE THE FUTURE
WOMEN DOCTORS.
AND 40% OF MY COLLEAGUES HEALTH
FROM EITHER EDUCATIONALLY AND OR
SOCIAL ECONOMICALLY
DISADVANTAGED BACKGROUNDS.
AND I BELIEVE THAT THE DIVERSE
WORKFORCE IS ESSENTIAL TO
MEETING THE VERY HEALTHCARE
NEEDS.
OF THE INLAND REGION IN
CALIFORNIA AT LARGE.
CURRENTLY I AM PURSUING A
RESIDENCY IN GENERAL INTERNAL
MEDICINE TO BUILD MEANINGFUL AND
LASTING RELATIONSHIPS WITH MY
PATIENTS.
IN MY COMMUNITY AS WELL.
AS I DISCOVER THROUGHOUT MY FOUR
YEARS OF HIGH CALIBER MEDICAL
EDUCATION AT UC RIVERSIDE.
THIS IS TRULY THE ESSENCE OF MY
CHOI IN MEDICINE.
MORE IMPORTANTLY I WANT AND I'M
MORE THAN READY TO TO SERVE IN
THE INLAND SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
REGION.
WHICH IS AND WILL FOREVER REMAIN
MY HOPE.
SO THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SHARE MY EXPERIENCE AND I
URGE THE COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN FORTY TO
HELP US CONTINUE TO BUILD THE
NEXT GENERATION OF PHYSICIANS.
AND EXPAND ACCESS TO QUALITY
CARE IN OUR REGION.
THANK YOU SHARON DR.
ANY OTHER.
SUPPORTING DOCK -- SUPPORTING
MEMBERS OF TO SMELL.
FROM THE AUDIENCE.
OKAY IF NOT THEN NOT ANY
[inaudible]
OPPOSITION WITNESS [inaudible]
THE AUDIENCE [inaudible]
NO TESTIMONY.
IF THAT'S THE CASE THEN OUR TURN
TO ALL MEMBERS OF FOR QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS.
LET ME BEGIN -- MYSELF FAR I AM
FROM ORANGE COUNTY -- IDEA.
HAVE -- BUNCH OF A DOCTOR'S IN
MY FAMILY INCLUDING MY SISTER
AND MY SON.
AND THEN I KNOW A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THE MEDICAL FIELD AND HAVE
A SEVERAL -- IDEAS IN MY HEAD.
BUT THE OVERALL I'VE BEEN.
HEARING ABOUT THE USE YOU ARE SO
MEDICAL SCHOOL CONNECTION WAY
BEFORE YOUR OF MEDICAL SCHOOL
BEGAN.
YOU HAD A COLLABORATION EIGHT
YEAR PROGRAM WITH THE USE --
UCLA.
ALSO THAT WAS -- I THOUGHT THE
DUST A GOOD BEGINNING AND THEN I
ENVISIONED A SOME DAY IT WOULD
HAVE FOR YOU INDEPENDENT A
MEDICAL SCHOOL.
AND ANOMALOUS I HEAR TWO
THOUSAND THIRTEEN YOU BEGAN.
AND THE THE IT THIS YEAR YOU'LL
BE GRADUATING US TO GRADUATE.
CONGRATULATIONS I THINK THAT
THAT WAS STOCKS ARE A BIT THE
THE DELAYED.
RELATED UP PROGRAM AND THE FOR
THAT REGION IN THE LAND.
EMPIRE -- SORELY NEEDED -- BUT
GOOD THE EDGE MEDICAL EDUCATION
PROGRAM AND DO YOU SEE OUR WAS A
PERFECT OUR LOCATION.
SO I AM -- FOR SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL.
AND ON I I KNOW ANY PROGRAM --
REQUIRES A FACILITIES SO YOU ARE
ASKING -- FOR FUNDS SELF WITH OF
MEDICAL FACILITY AND THEN ALSO
FOR THE PROGRAM SS BASIS THOUGH.
FUNCTION FOR ANY PROGRAMS -- SO
I THINK.
I HAVEN'T BEEN TO YOUR MEDICAL
FACILITY BUT AS A BEGINNING
MEDICAL SCHOOL WERE I'M SURE YOU
CAN -- A BILL NECESSARY SPACE UP
BEFORE YOU CAN EVEN CONTEMPLATE
ANY.
EXPANDING -- STUDENTS UP AND IS
OUR HERO SO SEVENTY IS.
BUT MEETING OUR STUDENTS NOT TO
ME THAT IS SO.
NOT VERY COST EFFECTIVE WHAT IT
WILL TAKE A FACILITIES IT'LL
TAKE A FACULTY MEMBERS SO.
FAR EVERYTHING EITHER YOU TRAIN.
ONE ONE HUNDRED AND ONCE YOU
HAVE THAT THE SCHOOL ALREADY
ESTABLISHED ALL WHY NOT WE
EXPAND.
AS SO MANY -- STUDENTS AS
POSSIBLE.
NOT ONLY TO MEET THE MEDICAL
DOCTOR SHORTAGES IN INLAND
EMPIRE BUT THE I DO NOT THE FACT
THAT -- THROUGHOUT THE THE STATE
IN PARTICULARLY IN A RURAL AREA
SO.
WE WE EXPERIENCE A SHORTAGE OF
DOCTORS -- SO ALTHOUGH AT THAT
AREAS US AT SEPARATE ISSUE.
BUT NOT TODAY YOU ARE EXPANDING
THE FACILITY AND THE PROGRAM SO
WHICH WILL TAKE OF RESOURCES TO
AND THAT THIS IS A VERY LOGICAL
STEP BOX.
SO YOUNG MEDICAL SCHOOL THAT THE
WE HAVE TO HAVE A AND THE XIN TO
EXPAND THE PROGRAM.
EVEN NOT JUST ALL IN ALL FOR
YOURSELF ABOUT IS A NOT COST
EFFECTIVE UP TO HAVE A THAT KIND
OF A LIMITED NUMBER FOR STUDENTS --
SO THEREFORE.
I MEAN FULLER A SUPPORTER OF
DATA AND THAT.
I CONGRATULATE AND SOMEDAY I
WOULD LIKE TO HAVE A VISIT THE
YOUR YOUR MEDICAL CAMPUS WELL
THANK YOU.
AND ALL OF THE ARE INVITED
ANYTIME THANK YOU THANK WITHIN
ANY THE MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO ASK
ANY QUESTION.
I WOULD MOVE THE BILL BUT I
DON'T THINK WE HAVE A QUORUM YET
DO WE ONLY HAD ONE IS AB.
SO I I AND WE ARE COMING WE HAVE
A WARRANT WE HAVE A FAR LESS
THAN THIS IS THE ESTABLISHED.
MEDINA PRESENT.
CHOI HERE JONES SAWYER HERE
BLOOM [inaudible]
GABRIEL.
IRWIN.
KILEY LEVINE [inaudible]
LOW [inaudible]
PATTERSON SANTIAGO WEBER.
OKAY OUR SECOND THE MOTION NANA
THE MOTION WAS A MADE THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER -- ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE MEMBERS.
AND MISTER CHAIR IF I IF I COULD
CLOSE -- IF THE COLLEAGUES WHO
ARE IN THE COMMITTEE WHO WERE
WITH US -- SEVEN YEARS AGO.
OF MAY REMEMBER THAT THIS WAS
THE FIRST BILL THAT I INTRODUCED
IN THE ASSEMBLY -- TO ESTABLISH
THE UC OUR SCHOOL OF MEDICINE.
AND WE WE DID ON THE CHEAP.
WE DID WITH FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY -- BUT CLANCY
SCHOOL.
WHO'S NOW BE DR -- FOR RYU'S.
IT IS BUT JUST ONE EXAMPLE OF
THE GREAT.
RESULTS OF THAT INVESTMENT SEVEN
YEARS AGO.
AND A FRANCISCO IS VERY
REPRESENTATIVE.
OF THE STUDENTS COMING OUT OF
THE UC OUR SCHOOL OF MEDICINE.
AND I HAVE TO TELL YOU THAT I
COULDN'T BE.
ANY PROUDER OF THAT FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT THAT
WE MADE -- IS SEVEN YEARS AGO.
AND THAT TO BE ABLE TO DUPLICATE.
AS THE VICE CHAIR IS SAID. TO A
LARGER EXTENT A WITH THE TWENTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLAR.
EXTRA INVESTMENT ANNUALLY AND
EIGHTY FIVE MILLIONS TO SCHOOL
BUILD A BUILDING FOR THE UC OUR
SCHOOL OF MEDICINE.
WE WILL BE ABLE TO SEE MANY MORE
DOCTORS OF THE CALIBER.
OF FRANCISCO SO WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU A LOT.
OF HELLO.
OKAY OKAY WE GET A MOTION YEAH
WE HAVE A MOTION ON BY DR GRANT
BRENDA'S SECONDED BY ME.
COOL.
OKAY THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE.
MEDINA AYE MEDINA AYE CHOI AYE
CHOI AYE JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER I BLOOM.
BLOOM I GABRIEL [inaudible]
IRWIN KILEY LEVINE.
LEVINE I LOW.
LEVEL I PATTERSON SANTIAGO WEBER
[inaudible]
WEBER I'D.
GET BASS IS A SEVEN ZERO ON
RESTORATIONS THANK YOU VERY AND
ARE OUT.
ONLY BE TO OPEN FULL IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS [inaudible]
AND J. O..
WHY YOU ARE SITTING DOWN THERE
ABOUT THE REST OF THE?
A GEM INDIANA.
DO YOU HAVE ANY OTHER WILL BE
ERRORS SO ABOVE THE OR BONUS
POINTS AND TALENT -- YOU'LL COME
BACK.
YEAH YEAH OKAY.
THANK YOU KATHY.
OKAY OUR OUR CALL UPON US TO
MEMBER GRAY OUT ON NOT A. B. IS
SIX IN ALL.
SIX ELIMINATE MIKE GAMBLING
TAXES IF YOU WANT ALL MY ALBUM.
THE THE RIGHT IS A LOT FOR ME.
THANK YOU MISTER MEMBERS.
AB SIXTY NO SIX IS A FOLLOW A
BILL THIS COMMITTEE.
YOU SAW IT LAST YEAR CREATED A
FIND WITHIN.
THE STATE TREASURY TO SERVE AS
AN ENDOWMENT FOR THE CREATION OF
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL SCHOOL IN THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY.
NOT UNLIKE THE AREA THAT THE
CHAIRMAN REPRESENTS THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY IS NOW UNDER
SERVED COMMUNITY WHEN IT COMES.
TO MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS AND
INFRASTRUCTURE.
THIS BILL ENJOYS THE SUPPORT THE
METAL CREATED YOUR FIRST OF
CALIFORNIA OFFICE THE PRESIDENT.
IT PROPOSES TO FUND THE MEDICAL
SCHOOL DOWN AT THROUGH THE
ELIMINATION OF THE NET GAMBLING
LOST TAX DEDUCTION I'D LIKE TO
MOVE THE BILL.
BUT I RESPECTFULLY ASK DRIVE OUT.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE -- SEEING NONE WE
HAD A MOTION.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE YOU RUN
A FINE COMMITTEE AND THANK YOU
ARE FOR YOUR SUPPORT HERE TODAY.
SO WE HAD A MOTION BY MISTER
LEVINE SECOND BY MISTER LOW.
OF MADAM SECRETARY READ PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
REVENUE AND TAXATION COMMITTEE.
MEDINA AYE MEDINA AYE CHOI.
CHOI I JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER I BLOOM.
BLOOM I GABRIEL.
IRWIN KILEY LEVINE LEVINE I LOW.
LOW I PATTERSON SANTIAGO WEBER
[inaudible]
WEBER AYE. SEVEN ZERO YOUR BILL
IS OUT WILL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU MISTER
THANK YOU -- NEXT WILL GO TO
FILE ITEM.
FOR AB THREE OH TWO MR BERMAN IF
HE'S HERE.
NO NOT HERE.
OKAY.
RIGHT THEN WE WILL GO.
ALL RIGHT.
NONE OF THIS.
WE'LL GO TO THE AUTHOR WHO I DO
SEE HERE.
WE'LL GO TO FILE ITEM EIGHTEEN
MR GLORY [inaudible]
WELCOME [inaudible]
MR GLORIA.
SOMETIMES YOU GET LUCKY WITH
CHAIRMAN DON'T OUT WOULD HAVE
BEEN VERY GOOD.
THANK YOU SIR.
THANK YOU EVERYONE -- THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN FOR LOBBY
PRESENT AB ELEVEN FIFTY TODAY IN
MOST LARGE CITIES COMMUNITY
COLLEGE BOARD MEMBERS ARE
REQUIRED TO YOU TO PAY.
A FEE A FILING FEE A PRETTY
SIGNATURES FROM THE COMMUNITY
THAT THEY'RE SEEKING TO
REPRESENT IN FACT ALL OF MY
COLLEAGUES HERE ON THIS DIES
TODAY YOU HAD TO PAY A FILING
FEE.
OUR GATHER UP TO THREE THOUSAND
SIGNATURES NOT ONLY DEMONSTRATE
OUR COMMITMENT TO THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SERVE -- BUT ALSO
THE SUPPORT THAT WE HAD FROM OUR
DISTRICTS AND THE CITY OF
COMMITTEE BECAUSE DISTRICT BOARD
AS WELL AS THE GROSS MONTHLY
MARKET COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT BOARD.
THE SIMPLE DEMOCRATIC
REQUIREMENTS DO NOT EXIST AB
ELEVEN FIFTY ADDRESSES THIS BY
REQUIRING CANDIDATES FOR THE
GOVERNING BOARDS OF BOTH OF
THESE COMMITTEE BECAUSE
DISTRICTS TO COLLECT AT LEAST
ONE HUNDRED SIGNATURES OF VOTERS.
IN THEIR TRUSTY AREA TO IN
SUPPORT OF THE CANDIDACY IN
ORDER TO QUALIFY FOR THE BALLOT.
COLLECTING SIGNATURES IS A
COMMON SENSE IN DEMOCRATIC WAY
TO DEMONSTRATE COMMUNITY SUPPORT
ENSURE THE CANDID SEEKING PUBLIC
OFFICE HAVE SUPPORT IN THEIR
DISTRICTS THAT THEY'RE SEEKING
TO REPRESENT.
WITH ME THIS AFTERNOON OR TWO
WITNESSES A BRIAN HOT WITH THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS FEDERATION
AND JIM MILLER ON BEHALF OF THE
A. F. T. LOCAL NINETEEN THIRTY
ONE I'D LIKE TO MOVE THE BILL.
THIS CHAIR MEMBER BRIAN HOW WITH
THE CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS WERE PROP SPONSORS OF
THIS LEGISLATION.
BOB I KNOW YOU HAVE A BUSY
HEARING TODAY SO I'M GOING TO
YIELD MY TIME TO OUR EXPERT
WITNESS TESTIMONY.
JIM MAILER NOT SUCH AN EXPERT --
PRESIDENT OF AMERICAN FEDERATION
OF TEACHERS GO LOCAL -- NINETEEN
THIRTY ONE AT THE AUTHORED
POINTED OUT VERY ELOQUENTLY AT
THE BILL'S PRETTY SIMPLE AND
PRETTY STRAIGHT FORWARD IT JUST
MAKES IT A LITTLE BIT MORE
DEMOCRATIC FOR PEOPLE THAT WANT
TO RUN FOR A SEAT ON ONE OF THE
COLLEGE BOARDS -- THE K. TWELVE
DISTRICTS AND THE UNION SENATE
GO UNIFIED THAT WE CAME OUT OF
SO HAS THE HUNDRED SIGNATURE
REQUIREMENT FOR SOME REASON WHEN
WE LEFT THEM WE LOST THAT SO.
BASICALLY JUST PUTTING THAT BACK
IN PLACE TO MIRROR WHAT THE
UNIFIED DISTRICT AS AN HUNDRED
SIGNATURES ISN'T SUCH A HIGH BAR
BUT IT DOES DEMONSTRATE AT LEAST
A SMALL.
AMOUNT OF THAT COMMITMENT FOR
PEOPLE THAT WANT TO RUN FOR THE
SEATS.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS MARK
MCDONALD ON BEHALF OF THE SAN
DIEGO COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT
IN SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
ANY TWEETERS.
AS A NUN ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU CHAIR AWESOME AND ONE
OF GLORIA -- WILL BE SUPPORTING --
MOST LIKELY BUT I HAVE A CURIOUS --
QUESTION I I KNOW THIS IS A
COMMON PRACTICE ABOUT THE
REQUIRING HUNDRED SIGNATURES SO
WHEN NOT REQUIRING.
WHAT DIFFERENCES HAVE DOES A
MAKE UP I NóI -- THEY
EXPERIENCE A CANDIDATE THE
COLLECTING THE SIGNATURES IS
ADJUSTABLE.
PAIN IN ALL BUT THAT DOESN'T
DETER -- FROM THAT SERIOUS A
CANDIDATE TO COLLECT THEM BUT
WHAT THE ANY ON SIRIUS PEOPLE
BECAUSE OF WHAT THIS --
REQUIREMENT -- THE THE NEVER
FILED OUT WHAT WHAT IS A STACK
THE PURPOSE OF REQUIRING THIS A
SIGNATURE SAID NOW SO.
IN ALL MY QUESTION.
THIS IS TO SHOW THAT THAT --
POTENTIAL CANDIDATE ACTUALLY
HAVE SUPPORT SUPPORT IN THE AREA
TO LOOKING TO REPRESENT -- IT'S
NOT AND DO BURDEN WE HAVE TO
SUPPLY MANY MORE THOUSANDS IF WE
WANTED SEEK.
THE LEGISLATIVE SEATS -- BUT IT
IS A SENSE OF MAKING SURE THAT
THESE ARE NOT FOLKS -- TO TO
SORT OF JUMP IN -- TO RACE BUT
THEY HAVE SOME DEMONSTRATED
ABILITY TO TELL AT LEAST A
HUNDRED THEIR CONSTITUENTS
CONVINCE A HUNDRED THEIR
CONSTITUENTS TO PUT THEIR NAME
ON A PETITION.
SAYING THAT THEY ARE WORTHY
PUBLIC OFFICE AND THEY COULD
HAVE SOME POTENTIAL SUPPORT --
IF THEY RICHARD IF THEY CHOSE TO
RUN.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE [inaudible]
SEEING NONE -- I I I WOULD WANT
TO ADD THAT.
HAVING BEEN A COMMUNITY COLLEGE
CHRISTY MYSELF I THINK THAT ONE
HUNDRED SIGNATURES IS A VERY
GOOD IDEA.
I'VE SEEN IN MY OWN DISTRICT --
OF TRYING TO REMEMBER YOU KNOW
PEOPLE WITH FLASHY NAMES AT
NAMES THAT.
MAYBE YOU RECOGNIZE TO THE
PUBLIC BUT IT'S NOT THEM -- RUN
AND SOMETIMES WHEN.
AND SO -- HUNDRED SIGNATURES I
THINK WOULD KIND OF STOP THOSE
KIND OF THINGS FROM HAPPENING.
AND WOULD BE A GOOD SHOW OF
MINIMAL SUPPORT SO I SUPPORT
YOUR BILL.
SO WE HAD A MOTION BY MISTER
LEVINE A SECOND BY MISTER LOWE
AND MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
ELECTIONS AND REDISTRICTING
COMMITTEE.
MEDINA HI MEDINA I CHOI.
CHOI I JONES SAWYER [inaudible]
BLOOM.
BLOOM I GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I IRWIN -- WHEN I KILEY?
LEVINE.
LEVINE I LOW.
LOW I PATTERSON SANTIAGO WEBER
[inaudible]
WEBER I EIGHT ZERO BILL IS OUT
WE'LL KEEP IT OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS BIGGEST GERMAN THANK YOU.
GOING NOW BACK -- TO SIGN IN
ORDER MISTER BERMAN -- FILE ITEM
[inaudible]
FOR WELCOME.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
COLLEAGUES.
HOUSING AND FOOD AND SECURITY
AMONG COLLEGE STUDENTS ALSO
KNOWN AS BASIC NEEDS AND
SECURITY.
IS FINALLY GETTING THE ATTENTION
IT DESERVES.
STUDENTS OF COLOR FIRST
GENERATION COLLEGE STUDENTS
FINANCIAL AID RECIPIENTS AND
FORMER FOSTER YOUTH ARE AT MUCH
HIGHER RISK OF EXPERIENCING
BASIC NEEDS AND SECURITY.
THE MOST EXTREME FORM OF HOUSING
AND SECURITY IS HOMELESSNESS
THEN AT IT HAS A DIRECT IMPACT
ON THE STUDENT'S ACADEMIC
SUCCESS.
A RECENT REPORT RELEASED BY THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE IN THE HOPE
CENTER FOR COLLEGE COMMUNITY AND
JUSTICE.
WHICH SURVEYED NEARLY FORTY
THOUSAND STUDENTS AT FIFTY SEVEN
COMMUNITY COLLEGES FOUND THAT
19% OF RESPONDENTS EXPERIENCED
HOMELESSNESS IN THE PRIOR YEAR.
IF YOU EXTRAPOLATE THAT TO
CALIFORNIA'S COMMUNITY COLLEGE
POPULATION OF TWO POINT ONE
MILLION STUDENTS.
THIS MEANS THAT BARELY LESS THAN
FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND STUDENTS
STATEWIDE HAVE EXPERIENCE
HOMELESSNESS IN THE LAST YEAR.
THIS NUMBER IS NOT ONLY SHOCKING
AN ALARMING AND TRAGIC BUT IT'S
A CALL TO ACTION.
THIS IS WHY I INTRODUCED AB
THREE OH TWO WHICH WOULD REQUIRE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO GRANT
OVERNIGHT ACCESS TO THE PARKING
FACILITIES FOR HOMELESS STUDENTS
TO SLEEP IN THEIR VEHICLES.
EXISTING LAW ALREADY REQUIRES
COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO GRANT
HOMELESS STUDENTS ACCESS TO
CAMPUS SHOWER FACILITIES.
THIS BILL IS THE NEXT LOGICAL
STEP IN HELPING OUR HOMELESS
STUDENTS.
UNDER AB THREE OR TWO EACH
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT WILL
BE PROVIDED BROAD FLEXIBILITY TO
DEVELOPING AN IMPLEMENTATION
PLAN THAT MEETS THE LOCAL NEEDS
AND CIRCUMSTANCES.
AB THREE OH TWO ALSO IMPORTANTLY
SPECIFIES THAT IT IS THE INTENT
OF THE LEGISLATURE THAT HOMELESS
STUDENTS TO USE THE OVERNIGHT
PARKING FACILITIES THE CONNECTED
TO AVAILABLE STATE.
COUNTY COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT AND COMMUNITY BASED
HOUSING FOOD AND FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE RESOURCES.
THE GOAL ISN'T TO TO HAVE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS OR
REALLY ANYBODY SLEEP IN THEIR
VEHICLES.
WE SHOULD BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
HOUSING FOR RESIDENTS AT EVERY
INCOME LEVEL. FOR FAR AWAY FROM
THAT GOAL IN CALIFORNIA TODAY.
THE REALITY IS THAT STUDENTS ARE
SLEEPING IN THEIR VEHICLES RIGHT
NOW.
AND WHEN WE DON'T PROVIDE A SAFE
PLACE FOR THEM TO SLEEP WE FORCE
THEM INTO THE SHADOWS IN A DARK
ALLEYS AND INDUSTRIAL PARKS
WHERE THE WHERE THEY ARE MOST
VULNERABLE.
MAKE NO MISTAKE AB THREE OR TWO
IS NOT A SOLUTION TO THE
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS.
BUILDING MORE HOUSING IS.
BUT THAT WILL TAKE YEARS AND IN
THE MEANTIME THERE ARE HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS RIGHT NOW
[inaudible]
TONIGHT.
AND WE SHOULD DO EVERYTHING WE
CAN TO MAKE THEIR SITUATION A
LITTLE BIT BETTER.
THIS IS WHAT AB THREE OH TWO
DOES.
IT MEETS THEIR MEDIA NEEDS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
AND WITH ME TO TESTIFY -- ARE
MATTHEW BUT IS STUDENT AT
FOOTHILL COLLEGE ANTHONY WHITE
THE SECOND A STUDENT AT PALOMAR
COLLEGE AND TO HEAR A HYATT
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
HOMELESS YOUTH PROJECT.
AND THEY WILL MAKE SURE TO STAY
WITHIN THE FOUR MINUTES YES SIR
THANK YOU.
NOT THE ONE IS ALL AGAIN A MATH
DEVOTO I'M A THIRD YEAR FOOTHILL
COLLEGE STUDENT I SPENT ABOUT
TWO YEARS.
HOMELESS PRIMARILY SLEEPING MY
CAR WILL COUCHSURFING TRYING TO
FIND A STABLE PLACE TO LIVE.
DURING THAT TIME I WAS NOT ONLY
A FULL TIME STUDENT BUT I WORK
FULL TIME.
WITH SOME SOME WEEKS LOOKING
LIKE FOURTEEN ARE SCHOOL DAYS.
THIRTEEN ARE WORK DAYS -- I
WASN'T WELCOME TO SLEEP ON
CAMPUS THERE NEAR THE RESOURCES
THAT COMMUNITY COLLEGES PROVIDE
LIKE SHOWERS.
THAT I NEEDED TO USE EVERY
MORNING BEFORE WORK OR SCHOOL.
AND WAS FORCED TO GO OFF CAMPUS
IN THE COMMUNITY NEARBY WHERE IT
WAS ILLEGAL TO PARK OVERNIGHT.
I CHORUS TICKETED AND VANDALIZED --
AND BECAUSE OF THAT ENDED UP
PARKING FURTHER AND FURTHER AWAY
FROM CAMPUS TO TRY AND FIND A
SAFE PLACE TO PARK.
WHICH CUT INTO THE VERY LIMITED
TIME THAT I HAVE FOR THINGS SUCH
AS SLEEP AND TAKING CARE OF
MYSELF ON TOP OF WORKING.
AND BEING A STUDENT.
THERE THERE PLENTY OF STUDENTS
THAT ARE IN NEED OF THIS
ASSEMBLY BILL.
AND MANY OF THE STUDENTS THAT
ARE HOMELESS OR TRYING TO TEN
AND EDUCATION TO ESCAPE FROM
POVERTY AND HOMELESSNESS SO
ANYTHING THAT WE CAN DO TO HELP
THEM.
ESPECIALLY NOW.
SUCH AS THIS BILL IS.
MUCH NEEDED.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MATHIS.
HELLO MY NAME'S ANTHONY WHITE --
I'M TWENTY YEARS OLD I'M A
MARINE CORPS VETERAN STUDENT A
FATHER A HUSBAND.
I'M ALSO FORMALLY HOMELESS I
SAID ABOUT EIGHT MONTHS LIVING
IN MY TRUCK -- POST MARINE CORPS --
UNFORTUNATELY I DISSENT I'M A
FULL TIME FATHER -- BUT I HAD TO
SEND MY SON OUT OF STATE TO LIVE
WITH HIS MOTHER IS A SINCE CAME
APPARENT THAT MICE LIVING
SITUATION WASN'T GONNA BE.
STABLE ENOUGH FOR HIM.
SO -- EIGHT MONTHS WENT BY I WAS
GOING TO SCHOOL WHILE WORKING
FULL TIME JOURNALIST MYSELF UP
OUT OF THE SITUATION TO BE WILL
HAVE MY SON BACK WITH ME. TO A
MAKE SURE MY FAMILIES BACK
TOGETHER AND WE'RE GONNA -- TO
BETTER FOR OURSELVES AND
FORTUNATELY IT WAS NOT A LOT
ACCESS OR AT LEAST -- IT WAS AN
ADVERTISER YOU KNOW MADE
AVAILABLE ACCESS TO RESOURCES
THAT COULD HELP ME GET OUT OF
THE SITUATION A LOT SOONER.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES YOU KNOW A
LOT OF FOOD PANTRIES ARE IN
PLACE A LOT OF?
YOU KNOW GOOD EFFORTS ARE MADE
BUT HOMELESSNESS IS ONE OF THOSE
ISSUES THAT HASN'T BEEN
ADDRESSED AS MUCH AS IT SHOULD
BE.
AND THE RECENT HOPE LAB STUDY
THAT CAME OUT IN MARCH YOU KNOW
GIVES THE SPECIFIC DATA THAT
SHOWS ABOUT 20% OF STUDENTS.
HAS ASSEMBLYMAN BERMAN MENTION
ARE FACING HOMELESSNESS THAT'S
NOT HOUSING SECURE HOMES ON THE
STREET WERE LIVING IN THEIR CAR
HOMELESS WITH NO SICK ROOF OVER
THEIR HEAD.
I WAS ONE OF THAT 20%.
OF THAT OUR CITY OF THAT 19% 20%
OF STUDENTS SO ABOUT EIGHT
EIGHTY THOUSAND STUDENTS ARE
SLEEPING IN THE CARS RIGHT NOW.
YOU DIVIDE THAT ACROSS ALL THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
ALL HUNDRED FOURTEEN OF THEM
WHAT SEVEN HUNDRED STUDENTS AT
EACH COLLEGE CAMPUS HER RIGHT
NOW LIVING IN THEIR CARS.
ARE NOT ABLE TO HAVE A SAFE
PLACE TO SLEEP AT NIGHT OF THE
BIGGEST CHALLENGE FOR ME WAS
WHERE MY GONNA SLEEP.
ON PARK IN FRONT OF LOWS BECAUSE
THEIR WIFI REACHES ALL THE WAY
OUT IN THE PARKING LOT A PARKING
BEHIND INDUSTRIAL CENTERS
BECAUSE THEIR PRIVATE I'M NOT
GONNA BE DISTURBED.
I IF I LOST MY VEHICLE AS MATT
MENTIONED YOU KNOW IT'S CRIMINAL
AND A LOT OF PLACES TO BE LIVING
IN YOUR CAR AND HAD I LOST MY
VEHICLE WITH A LOSS MEANS
TRANSPORTATION. TO WORK TO
SCHOOL WHICH ULTIMATELY HAD
WITHDRAWAL FROM SCHOOL JUST
BECAUSE I COULDN'T KEEP THE
CHALLENGE OUT.
OF TRYING.
TO BE SUCCESSFUL IN MY CLASSES
AND THEN YOU KNOW FROM SIX TO
NINE PM GOING TO NIGHT SCHOOL
AND LEAVING AND HAVING TO FIGURE
OUT WHERE MY GONNA GO AT NIGHT
WHERE MY GOING TO BE SAFE FOR MY
NOT GONNA BE HARASSED WOMEN NOT
GONNA COST TROUBLE.
YOU KNOW AND I FEEL THAT AB
THREE OH TWO HAD BEEN IN PLACE
OF THE TIME.
I WOULD'VE BEEN ABLE -- TO GET
SUPPORT SOONER -- THANK PLEASE A
BETTER ACCESS TO RESOURCES THAT
MOST STUDENTS DON'T -- YOU KNOW
I WAS ABLE TO LEAN ON THOSE
RESOURCES -- YOU KNOW AFTER THAT
EIGHT MONTH PERIOD TO GET MYSELF
OUT OF THAT SITUATION BUT I CAN
IMAGINE IF I WASN'T A VETERAN I
MIGHT STILL BE IN THAT SITUATION
I AM NOW THANKFULLY THAT WAS
FOUR YEARS AGO I HAD MY SON A
WITH ME FULL TIME.
WITH A ROOF OVER OUR HEADS I'M
BACK IN SCHOOL PALOMAR WITH
STERN GOVERNMENT NOTE -- AND YOU
KNOW IT'S ONE OF THOSE STORIES
THAT YOU LOOK BACK ON YOU SAY
THAT WOULD HAPPEN TO ME OR YOU
KNOW YOU DON'T THINK IT'S
RELATABLE BUT THEN IT HAPPENS TO
YOU HAPPENS TO OUR BROTHERS AND
SISTERS OUR SONS AND DAUGHTERS.
THAT'S WHY I URGE YOU YOU KNOW --
TO PLEASE SUPPORT AB THREE OH
TWO NOT JUST FOR POLITICS IS NOT
JUST ETHICALLY RESPONSIBLE
PLEASE FISCALLY RESPONSIBLE WITH
THE CALIFORNIA COMMITTEE BECAUSE
FUNDING FORMULA BASED ON SUCCESS
OF STUDENTS NOW SHE WAS ARE
GONNA BE SUCCESSFUL IF THEY'RE
HUNGRY FOR HOMELESS.
SO I URGE YOU TO PLEASE SUPPORT
EIGHTY THREE OH TWO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
IF I COULD SAY TO THE LAST
WITNESS IF YOU COULD LIMITED TO
AFTERNOON TERRY MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MANY MISSION HER HIGH
AND I'M THE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA HOMELESS YOUTH
PROJECT.
ON THIS BILLS IMPORTANT STEP
TOWARD PROVIDING SAFE SPACE FOR
STUDENTS USING A HARM REDUCTION
PHILOSOPHY WHICH IS A BEST
PRACTICE IN THE FIELD OF YOUTH
HOMELESSNESS.
WE HAVE NUMBERS OF STUDENT
HOMELESSNESS AS HIGH AS WE DO WE
SHOULD HAVE A BIAS TOWARD ACTION.
IT IS ALSO AN OPPORTUNITY
CONNECT THESE STUDENTS TO THE
COLLEGE HOMELESS LEASE ON ON
CAMPUS SO THEY CAN MORE
EFFECTIVELY BE REFERRED TO
HOUSING AND OTHER SUPPORT OF
SERVICES.
A NEW STATE REPORT FOUND THAT
THE RATE THAT LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS ARE PROVING LOW
INCOME HOUSING.
MOST COUNTIES ACROSS CALIFORNIA
WON'T REACH THEIR OWN HOUSING
GOALS FOR DECADES.
IT'S ALSO TRUE THAT MOST CITIES
ACROSS THE STATE IT IS ILLEGAL
TO SLEEP IN A PARKED VEHICLE
OVERNIGHT BUT WE KNOW THAT MANY
STUDENTS ARE PUT IN THAT
POSITION.
WE DON'T WANT STUDENTS TO BE
CRIMINALIZED FOR THEIR LACK OF
HOUSING ESPECIALLY WILL TRYING
TO ATTEND COLLEGE FOR THESE
REASONS WE APPLAUD SUMMER BERMAN
THE TENSIONS TO BETTER SERVICE
DIDN'T COMMUNITY HAPPEN ANSWER
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT IF
THEY COME UP TO THE MICROPHONE
AND GIVE THEIR NAME AND THE
GROUP THEY REPRESENT.
AB SANCHEZ REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION VERY PORTION OF THE
OF THE AMENDMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN
TAKEN LOOKING FORWARD TO
CONTINUING CONVERSATIONS WITH.
REGARDING APPROPRIATE AND
ADEQUATE SECURITY OVERNIGHT
THANK YOU IN STRONG SUPPORT.
I USUALLY YOUNG BUT THE STUDENT
CENTER FOR CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AND WE'RE STRONG
SUPPORT.
MY NAME IS SUKI HUMAN I'M A
TRANSGENDER STUDENT FROM PALOMAR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE IN SAN DIEGO
COUNTY AND I'M HERE TO VOICE MY
SUPPORT FOR ASSEMBLY BILL THREE
OH TWO THANK YOU.
HI I'M ELIZABETH CORTES ID TEN
PALOMAR COLLEGE YOU SAID YOU
COUNTY AND I SUPPORT AB.
THREE OH TWO MY NAME IS OUT
THERE GREEN I AM A HOMELESS
STUDENT AT PALOMAR COLLEGE IN
SAN MARCOS AND I SUPPORT A
RETAIL JOB.
I NAME IS BREANNA DEAL STUDENTS
SENATOR AT PALMER COLLEGE IS A
FORMER FOSTER YOUTH I SUPPORT
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS STEPHANIE
HERNANDEZ AND I'M A CURRENT
STUDENT I'M PALMER COLLEGE AND I
AM ALSO A WHOLE LIST.
STUDENT TRYING TO SUCCEED THANK
YOU AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL
[inaudible]
STONE.
OKAY.
HELLO MY NAME'S YOUNG HE'S
JOHNSON I'M THE REGIONAL AFFAIRS
DIRECTOR REGION THREE FOR THE
STUDENTS IN A FOR CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES WHICH IS THE
BAY AREA.
AND WE HIGHLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
TO HELP ALL OF THE STUDENTS
THERE.
THANK YOU.
HELLO I'M HEATHER JOHNSON FROM
SERENA'S COLLEGE AND I AM THE
ROOT SYSTEM REACHING THE SYSTEM
AFFAIRS DIRECTOR FOR REGION --
EIGHT FOR SERENA'S COLLEGES WELL
AS THE OTHER COLLEGES IN MY
REGION -- AND LOS ANGELES COUNTY.
AND I AM HERE TO SUPPORT AB
THREE OH TWO THANK YOU.
HELLO I'M KAREN CAPP BIRTH
WEIGHT AND I AM THE CLERK FOR
THE ASSOCIATED STUDENTS.
OF MERCED COLLEGE IN THE CENTRAL
SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY.
I'M HERE TO VOICE MY SUPPORT FOR
A BI THREE ATTEMPTS.
HELLO MY NAME IS EVA MENDEZ I'M
THE IN OUR CLUB COUNCIL CHAIR AT
APPLE VALLEY COLLEGE AND DOUBLE
THE COLLEGE OVERWHELMINGLY
SUPPORTS AB THREAT TO THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON LUIS BRONTE WITH
CALIFORNIA BE -- CALIFORNIA BE
REPRESENTS THOUSANDS OF HIM IS
ACROSS THE STATE WHO ARE TO MAKE
CALIFORNIA AND A PLACE FOR
EVERYONE MORE AFFORDABLE STATE --
WE'RE HERE TO VOICE OUR STRONG
SUPPORT THANK RAN.
FOR REBEKAH GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
AB FAB -- I'M DIVISIONAL AFFAIRS
DIRECTOR FOR REGION FOUR WHICH
COVERS THE SILICON VALLEY AND
PARTS OF ALAMEDA COUNTY AS WELL.
OUR REGION OVER MELANIE SUPPORTS --
AB PURITY THANK YOU.
MICHELLE HI STUDENTS SENATOR AT
SEATTLE COLLEGE LOCATED IN
CUPERTINO IN THE SILICON VALLEY
WHERE HOUSING AND SECURITY IS A
HUGE CRISIS AND THE AND THE
COLLEGE STRONGLY SUPPORTS AB
THREE OH TWO THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS A ROBINSON
STUDENT AT FOOTHILL COLLEGE IN
FRONT OF MATTHEW VOTERS AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT AB THREE OR TWO
MY NAME IS MARK TELL FLOYD I'M A
CO COUNSEL PRESENT AT MAYOR
COLLEGE.
AND ASM SEE MAYOR CALL SUPPORT.
HI AM BERNARD MCFADDEN FROM
COPPER MOUNTAIN COLLEGE IN THE
HIGH DESERT REGION NINE I AM
WITH THIS IS TRIPLE C. ON THE
VICE PRESIDENT COMMUNICATIONS
AND I SUPPORT AB.
THREE OH TWO HI THANK YOU FOR
HAVING US MY NAME IS HALEY NORTH
I AM A SENATOR PALOMAR COLLEGE
ON A NORTHERN SAN DIEGO.
AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT.
THREE OH TWO STEPHANIE GOLDMAN
WITH THE FACULTY ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES WE
APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENTS NOISE
FOR THIS BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS PUSH
ON THE UC STUDENT ASSOCIATION
WE'RE HAPPY TO STAND IN
SOLIDARITY WITH OUR FRIENDS AND
THE COMPANY COLLEGES AS WE SAT
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
KRISTIN POWER THE ALLIANCE FOR
CHILDREN'S RIGHTS IN SUPPORT.
MY NAME IS JORDAN BAGLEY I'M A
TRANSGENDER STUDENT FROM PALOMAR
COLLEGE AND WE CAME FROM NORTH
SAN DIEGO COUNTY TO LET YOU KNOW
THAT WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU. FOR ME AT THE
THING THE NEXT GEN CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT.
MARIO GUERRERO ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT.
HI AM ALLEN MARVIN FROM PALOMAR
COLLEGE ALL THE WAY FROM SAN
DIEGO AND WE ALL SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
SENATOR CALLISTER INTERESTING
PHILOSOPHY AS COMMITTEE BECAUSE
DISTRICT IN STRONG SUPPORT.
CAN REALLY ROSENBERG WITH
SERVICE EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL
UNION IN LIGHT OF THE WORK THAT
THE AUTHORS TAKEN WITH US YES CA
IN OUR COLLEAGUES TO CONTINUE
THE CONVERSATIONS WE LIKE.
TO ASK OUR STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
ARE YOU MISTER MEMBERS TONY RICE
ABOUT THE LOS ANGELES AREA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE A VERY
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HELLO I MEMBER BANCROFT AND
STUDENT TRUSTEE FOR PALMER
COLLEGE AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
COME SIT AT THE TABLE.
ACTUALLY NOT OPPOSITION JUST A
TWEENER FAITH LANE FOR JUST ON
BEHALF OF AT THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF JOINT POWERS
AUTHORITY IS WE SINCERELY
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S GOOD
INTENTIONS TO SERVICE.
PORTABLE STUDENT POPULATIONS AND
WE APPRECIATE THE TIME THAT YOU
AND YOUR STAFF IN WORKING FOR US
WITHIN SAFETY SECURITY AND
ONGOING LIABILITY CONCERNS WE
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
CONTINUE THAT CONVERSATION AS
THIS BILL MOVES FORWARD.
THANK YOU.
OTHER TWEETERS.
BRIAN MACKLIN AT THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA WE
ARE ALSO BETWEEN HERE WE ARE WE
ARE APPRECIATIVE THE MOMENTS ARE
TAKEN BUT THIS IS STILL A
SIGNIFICANT MANDATE FOR
INSTITUTIONS TO IMPLEMENT.
AND WE ALSO FEEL THAT THIS IS
NOT ADDRESS THE UNDERLYING
PROBLEM OF OF WHAT IS HAPPENING
TO OUR HOME ASSIDUOUS WHICH IS A
SYSTEMATIC UNDERFUNDING.
OF OUR STATE FINANCIAL AID
SYSTEM PARTICULARLY WHEN IT
COMES TO COMMUNITY COLLEGES SO I
THINK YOUR TIME.
ALSO LEFT ON BEHALF OF THE COSTA
RANCHO SANTIAGO COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT SAM ALL ECHO MY
COLLEAGUE FROM THE LEAGUE WE
APPRECIATE THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ADDRESS TRYING TO ADDRESS THIS
ISSUE BUT STILL HAVE SOME
CONCERNED WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING THROUGH WITH HIM.
THANKS.
STILL SHE WAS TALKING WITH SANTA
MONICA COLLEGE A YOU RECEIVED
THE THE COLLEGES LETTER WERE
SUPPORTIVE AMENDED -- TO MOVE
THE AT MANDATE IN TO THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS -- STATEMENT
ABOUT THIS IS A TEMPORARY
SOLUTION WE ALSO LIKE TO SEE A
SUNSET DATE THE BILL GIVEN IT'S
A TEMPORARY.
DAVID NEVIN ON BEHALF OF THE LOS
RIOS COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT --
WE HOLD A SUPPORT OF AMENDED
BILL TO REMOVE THE MANDATE MAKE
THAT BILL PERMISSIVE THANK YOU.
A JUST AND SILICON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE AND WE DO
NOT HAVE AN OFFICIAL POSITION ON
THE BILL AT THIS TIME.
OF WE DO APPRECIATE BRING IN THE
ISSUE OF HOUSING INSECURITY
FORWARD WE APPRECIATE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BERMAN DOING SO.
AND WE'VE WE'VE HEARD THE THE
CONCERNS OF OUR DISTRICTS AND
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK ON IT
GOING FORWARD THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM --
TO THE COMMITTEE [inaudible]
MR WITH.
THANK YOU AND THANK YOU TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER -- BERG BERMAN
AND WE'VE HEARD A LOT OF AND
STUDENTS HERE AND AND I BUT I
CONTINUE TO HAVE A LOT OF THE
CONCERNS THAT THE WINNERS HAD --
THIS IS.
A REPEAT AGAIN THIS IS A
TEMPORARY SOLUTION AND WE HAVE
TO FIND A BETTER WAY. TO HELP
THESE STUDENTS THE NUMBER OF
STUDENTS THAT ARE HOMELESS IS --
THAT WITH THAT WE'VE SEEN IN THE
LATEST STATE IS ABSOLUTELY
APPALLING -- I AM NOT GOING --
TO I I HOPE TO VOTE FOR THIS
BILL ON THE FLOOR AND I'M NOT
GOING TO SUPPORT RIGHT NOW AND I
WANT -- TO LAY OUT SOME OF MY
CONCERNS AFTER I HAVE TALKED.
TO PEOPLE IN MY DISTRICT AND AND
I THINK A LOT OF THEM WERE
BROUGHT UP ALREADY.
FIRST ONE IS FUNDING WE WANT TO
ABSOLUTELY MAKE SURE THAT THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES ARE
REIMBURSED -- FOR THIS COST --
THEY ARE READY -- DEALING WITH A
LOT OF FUNDING GAPS AND WE DON'T
WANT TO TAKE ANYTHING AWAY FROM
OTHER PROGRAMS -- SECURITY WAS
MENTIONED ALSO -- I DON'T THINK
THAT THAT WAS THE AMENDMENTS
THAT YOU TOOK I DON'T THINK THAT
WE'VE THAT DEALT WITH GET WITH
SECURITY -- THEM.
I'D LIKE TO ALSO SEE -- SUNSET.
AND AN EVALUATION OF THE PROGRAM.
AND AND YOU KNOW MAKE SURE TO
DEAL WITH THE LIABILITY ISSUES
SO THAT THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES
STONE AND UP HOLDING THE BAG ON
THIS BUT I THINK THIS IS.
GOV THIS IS IT'S WE HAVE SUCH A
HUGE PROBLEM HERE IN CALIFORNIA
AND I THINK THIS IS A CREATIVE
WAY TO DEAL WITH THAT.
I JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
IT'S COMPLETELY WELL THOUGHT OUT
THAT WE DON'T.
IMPACTS.
THE THE COLLEGES AND THAT WE
DON'T IMPACT NEIGHBORHOODS AND
THAT WE DON'T END UP WITH
STUDENTS IN A WORSE SITUATION
THAN THEY WOULD BE OTHERWISE SO
AGAIN -- WANT TO CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH YOU ON THIS AND AND
HOPE TO SUPPORT YOU ON THE FLOOR
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER WHEN
AND AND APPRECIATE THE
CONVERSATIONS WE'VE HAD -- IN
OVER THE LAST COUPLE OF DAYS AND
AND I'M SURE AND THE PUSH IT YOU
PROVIDING YOUR CONCERNS YEAH YOU
KNOW TO ME AHEAD OF TIME AND
WILL KEEP ON WORKING TOGETHER
THAT TO WORK THROUGH.
SOME OF THE CONCERNS THAT YOU
REST [inaudible]
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM.
THANK YOU AND THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BERMAN -- FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL I THINK IT ADDRESSES A
VERY -- IMPORTANT ISSUE THAT WE
HAVEN'T.
SPENT ENOUGH TIME -- THINKING
THROUGH -- I SHARE A LOT OF THE
CONCERNS OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER --
WHEN -- I'M GONNA REACH A
DIFFERENT RESULT HERE TODAY AND
RESERVE -- MY THINKING ON THE
BILL UNTIL -- IT COMES TO THE
FLOOR -- A SEWER -- TAKING A
SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT APPROACH BUT
I THINK THAT MY CONCERNS ARE
VERY MUCH REFLECTED IN THE
LETTER THAT YOU RECEIVED.
FROM SANTA MONICA COLLEGE RIGHT
I DO BELIEVE THAT -- WE SHOULD
START THIS PROGRAM AS A
PERMISSIVE PROGRAM NOT AS A
MANDATE -- I THINK THAT THERE
ARE SOME -- OTHER CONCERNS THAT
ARE IN IN THE LETTER BUT
STARTING SOMETHING IS A AS A
PILOT WITH A SUNSET SO THAT WE
CAN LOOK BACK SEE HOW IT'S
WORKING TO ME SEEMS SO.
REALLY IMPORTANT HERE.
THIS IS SOMETHING OF A YEAR --
YOU'RE KIND OF ASKING TOOK UP
PUT A SQUARE PEG IN A ROUND HOLE --
THIS IS NOT THE HOUSING STUDENTS
IS NOT A CORE FUNCTION OF OF OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES I THINK IT
SHOULD BE FRANKLY I THINK THAT
COMMUNITY COLLEGES SHOULD BE.
PROVIDING HOUSING -- BUT I HAVE
TO SAY -- THIS ALSO ISN'T REALLY
HOUSING -- WERE PROVIDING -- UP
A PLACE TO PARK A VEHICLE OF I
GET VERY UNEASY.
WITH PROGRAMS LIKE THIS -- AND
THE REASON I GET UNEASY IS
BECAUSE A AN AUTOMOBILE -- IS A
SUB STANDARD PLACE TO LIVE --
AND WHEN GOVERNMENT -- STEPS IN
AND SAYS IT'S OKAY -- UNDER
THESE CIRCUMSTANCES AND WILL
PROVIDE A PLACE -- BECAUSE THE
CRISIS IS SO BAD -- WE BEGIN TO
NORMALIZE THAT AND I THINK IT
JUST HAS -- IN IN MY EXPERIENCE
IN WORKING ON THIS ISSUE LIKE
YOU FOR A LONG TIME FOR ME IT'S
WELL IN EXCESS OF THIRTY YEARS
NOW A LITTLE LONGER THAN I HAVE --
IT GET -- TO I I I I'VE JUST
I'VE I'VE BEEN DISTRESSED TO
FIND THE HOMELESSNESS HAS GOTTEN
WORSE AND WORSE AND WORSE -- AS
WE'VE ALLOWED -- THROUGH CONSENT
DECREES AND OTHER MEANS --
PEOPLE TO SET UP TENTS AND LIVE
ON SIDEWALKS -- I BELIEVE WE'VE
NORMALIZE THAT BEHAVIOR AND
WE'VE BECOME MORE INURED TO IT
AND TO AND THAT'S NOT GOOD NOW I
SEE THE OTHER SIDE OF THE ISSUE --
TOO WHICH IS THAT WE HAVE A
GROWING HOMELESS POPULATION AND
EVEN THOUGH WE'RE HOUSING MORE
PEOPLE THAN WE EVER HAVE BEFORE
LARGELY BECAUSE OF THE HOUSING
CRISIS IN BECAUSE OF RISING
SUBSTANCE ABUSE FIRST FOR THE
WITH SOME A VERY VERY DANGEROUS
CHEMICALS -- AND AND BECAUSE OF
INCREASING MENTAL ILLNESS WE SEE
THE POPULATION NOT BEING EVEN TO
ABLE TO KEEP UP WITH OUR STRIDES
IN PROVIDING HOUSING SO THERE
THERE'S THERE'S DEFINITELY
MULTIPLE SITES TO THIS BUT I I
WANT TO MAKE SURE AND TALK ABOUT
THAT A NEEDS THAT I HAVE BECAUSE
WE SHOULD.
NEVER -- THINK ABOUT A PROGRAM
LIKE THIS AS PROVIDING OF ANY
KIND OF A LONG TERM SOLUTION
WHICH IS ONE OF THE REASONS THAT
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO HAVE A
SUNSET WE START SOMETHING LIKE
THIS -- AND IT'S GOING TO TAKE
ON A LIFE OF ITS OWN.
AT LEAST I THINK THAT THAT
POTENTIAL IS THERE THE OTHER
THING THAT I THINK IS MISSING --
THAT I'D LIKE YOU TO CONSIDER --
IS IF WE'RE GOING TO HAVE A
PROGRAM LIKE THIS THEN -- THERE
NEEDS TO BE -- ACCESS -- TO AGE
APPROPRIATE -- SERVICES -- ON AN
ONGOING BASIS.
I'M THAT DOESN'T SEEM TO BE
PRESENT IN THE BILL RIGHT NOW.
ALI CAN LET ME KNOW WHICH
SERVICES ARE YOU REFERRING WELL
AGE APPROPRIATE -- FOR A
TRANSITION H. YOUTH SO -- OKAY
YOU KNOW WHAT SPECIFIC SERVICES
THOSE WOULD BE -- THAT
WRAPAROUND SERVICES ARE
TYPICALLY PROVIDING WHATEVER
SERVICE A PARTICULAR INDIVIDUAL
NEEDS BUT AT AN AGE APPROPRIATE
LEVEL SO IT MIGHT BE SUBSTANCE
ABUSE COUNSELING IT MIGHT BE --
HELP WITH THE PSYCHOLOGICAL
PROBLEMS -- IT MIGHT BE -- HELP
TO FIND LONG TERM HOUSING IT
SHOULD BE HELP TO FIND LONG TERM
HOUSING THE THINGS LIKE THAT.
THANK THANK YOU VERY MUCH AS A
MEMBER BLOOM AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP ON HOUSING
ISSUES -- IN THE LEGISLATURE.
DO YOU YOU KNOW AS WELL AS
ANYBODY THAT WE HAVE A
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS -- IN
CALIFORNIA AND WE NEED DIFFERENT
SOLUTIONS TO ADDRESS THE NEEDS
OF DIFFERENT HOMELESS
POPULATIONS -- AND AND I THINK --
AND AN INFINITE NO AND AND CHAIR
YOU MIGHT KNOW A LOT ABOUT THE
DETAILS OF THE STUDY THAT WAS
DONE BUT I I I DON'T KNOW TO
WHAT EXTENT -- SUBSTANCE ABUSE
IS A PROBLEM.
WITH OUR HOMELESS COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS -- I THINK IT'S
MORE JUST THEY CAN'T AFFORD TO
FIND A PLACE TO LIVE YEAH -- AND
AND SO -- BUT BUT PART PART OF
THE BILL DOES SAY THAT IT'S
INTENT OF THE LEGISLATURE THAT
WE CONNECT PEOPLE WITH THE STATE
COUNTY COMMUNITY COLLEGE LEVEL
AND LOCAL.
SERVICES AVAILABLE LAW TAKE IT
TO HEART YOU KNOW YOUR COMMENT
ON ON A DIFFERENT AGE
APPROPRIATE -- SERVICES FOR FOR
YOUTH AND WILL MAKE SURE THAT
THAT THAT'S ADDRESSED AS WELL --
AND WELL -- I'D I'D I DON'T
THINK IT CAN BE SAID THAT
SUBSTANCE ABUSE -- GONNA ISN'T
SIGNIFICANT ISSUE AND I ALSO
WOULD WOULD POINT OUT -- THAT --
USED TO AGE TWENTY FIVE THAT IS
THE PERIOD OF TIME -- WHEN YOUNG
PEOPLE FREQUENTLY HAVE THEIR
FIRST PSYCHOLOGICAL BREAKING --
AND END UP IN CRISIS SO -- THOSE
KIND OF SERVICES ARE -- NOT --
MINOR THINGS IN MY OPINION THERE
CRITICAL ABSOLUTELY I TOTALLY
AGREE AND I DON'T KNOW IF.
THEY'RE OR ANTHONY IF EITHER YOU
YOU WANTED YEAH I'D LIKE TO
ADDRESS THAT -- SO ONE OF THE
THINGS I WOULD LIKE TO SAY JUST
IN GENERAL -- TO MISTER WHEN MR
BLOOM BUT WHEN WE RAISE SOME OF
THE ISSUES AS FAR AS THE SAFETY
YOU KNOW THE DRUG ABUSE ISSUES
THAT THAT COULD BE PRESENT IN
THE COMMUNITY.
I WANT TO POINT OUT THAT WERE
FOR THIS IS A STUDENT CENTRIC --
BILL WE LOOK AT THE STUDENT
POPULATION THEY'VE MADE THAT
INITIAL STEP TO TRY TO GET
THEMSELVES IN HIGHER EDUCATION
TO TRY TO GET THEMSELVES IN.
OUT OF THE SITUATION AND TO
BETTER THEIR LIVES.
FROM THE MOST PART AND YOU KNOW
I'VE INTERACTED WITH.
IT COUNTLESS STUDENTS WHO HAVE
BEEN IN THESE SITUATIONS.
AND I WOULD SAY THAT DRUG ABUSE.
I DON'T KNOW THAT IT IS AN ISSUE
AND I WOULD SAY YOU KNOW WHEN
YOU LOOK AT THE COLLEGE STUDENT
COMMUNITY YEAH I MEAN WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THOSE PEOPLE THAT ARE
MOST VULNERABLE.
MORE OFTEN THAN NOT IT IS THE
COST OF LIVING IT IS BEING ON
THEIR OWN FOR THE FIRST TIME
IT'S TRANSFERRING TO A SCHOOL
OUT OF STATE.
THAT LEADS THEM TO THE SITUATION
WHEN YOU LOOK AT IT THE GENERAL
HOMELESS POPULATION DRUG ABUSE
ALCOHOL ABUSE MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES THOSE MIGHT BE THE MORE
PREVALENT ISSUES WE TALK ABOUT
THE ENTIRE COMMUNITY WHEN YOU
TALK ABOUT THE STUDENT CENTRIC.
MOST OF THE STUDENTS THEY MIGHT
BE SUFFERING WITH MENTAL
INSTABILITY SOME CERTAIN ISSUES
BUT IT'S GONNA BE TO A FAR LESS
EXTENT.
AND WE CAN SAY THAT BECAUSE WHEN
YOU LOOK AT THE STUDENTS THEY'RE
GOING TO CLASSES IT'S INDICATIVE
I'M NOT GONNA SIGN UP FOR
CLASSES IF I'M YOU KNOW HAVING
ALL THESE MENTAL ISSUES I'M
PROBABLY NOT GONNA BE AS APT. TO
ROLL INTO COLLEGE I'M HAVING A
COULD BE AS APT TO YOU KNOW BE
IN THAT SITUATION WHERE I'M
TRYING TO BETTER MYSELF SO WE
LOOK AT THOSE SITUATIONS I WOULD
SAY.
MOST OF THEM ARE JUST POOR
CHOICES OR BEING OUT YOUNG AND
ON THEIR OWN FOR THE FIRST TIME --
BUT THE STATE'S NOT SAYING YOU
KNOW AS YOU SAID MR BLOOM IT'S
NOT SAYING THAT IT'S OKAY TO BE
HOMELESS I MEAN IT'S NOT
NORMALIZING I WOULD SAY IT'S DE
STIGMATIZING AND IF I WOULD HAVE
KNOWN.
THAT I COULD HAVE PARKED IN MY
COLLEGE CAMPUS OVERNIGHT.
I MEAN I I NEVER ONCE USED DRUGS --
YOU KNOW THE ENTIRE TIME I WAS
LIVING IN MY CAR I NEVER MET --
ONE NEVER MET SOMEBODY.
WHO IS IN A SIMILAR SITUATION WE
ENDED UP IN A SITUATION BECAUSE
OF DRUGS OR ALCOHOL OF TIMES?
THE PEOPLE USE THEM ONCE YOU'RE
IN THAT SITUATION TO NUMB THE
PAIN.
IT'S A PAINFUL SITUATION BEING
HOMELESS BE AFRAID AT NIGHT KNOW
THEM TO BE HARASSED I CAN
UNDERSTAND YOU KNOW WANTED TO BE
ABLE TO JUST GET A FEW HOURS OF
SLEEP SO I YOU KNOW I MAYBE A
DRINK WHAT ABOUT RIGHT TAKES
MEDICINE.
TRY TO GET YOU KNOW GET OUT OF
THAT THAT FEELING OF DESPERATION
THAT I HAVE BUT I WOULD SAY
THAT'S NOT THE LEADING CAUSE OF
THAT'S PROBABLY THAT'S MORE
OFTEN THAT THE FACTOR THAT
CONTRIBUTES TO BILLS PEOPLE
USING THOSE.
WERE ABUSING THE SUBSTANCES SO I
WOULD SAY THAT THE STATE'S NOT
REALLY SAYING THAT IT'S OKAY
YOUR FOR YOU.
YOU KNOW THIS IF THE ISSUE IS
GOING TO GO AWAY.
WHETHER WE PASS THIS BILL OR NOT
COSTUMES ARE GONNA BE HOMELESS
WE PASSED THE BILL QUESTIONS
WILL CONTINUE TO BE HOMELESS
WHAT THIS DOES IS IT PUTS
SUPPORT IN PLACE FOR THE
STUDENTS. TO WHO ARE STRUGGLING
WHO DON'T KNOW WHERE TO TURN TO
BE ABLE TO SAY HEY WE HAVE AN
ACCESS FOR YOU TO GET YOU OUT OF
THE SITUATION IT'S DEFINITELY
DON'T WANT TO BE A PERMANENT
SITUATION SOME PEOPLE ABUSE THAT
THOSE LIVING APART RENT FREE
IT'S CALIFORNIA IT'S EXPENSIVE.
I DEFINITELY UNDERSTAND THAT
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE STUDENTS
FOR THE MOST PART THEY JUST WANT
TO GET OUT OF THAT SITUATION.
IF WE DON'T PUT A PROGRAM IN
PLACE AND WHAT ARE WE OFFERING
STUDENTS.
YEAH IF I COULD HAVE A QUICK
RESPONSE -- TO YOU KNOW I THINK
THAT WORKING ON SIMULTANEOUSLY
ON LONGER TERM HOUSING
STRATEGIES WHILE EMPLOYING A
HARM REDUCTION STRATEGY -- IS
NOT A MUTUALLY EXCLUSIVE GOAL I
THINK WE CAN DO BOTH AT THE SAME
TIME SO IT'S NOT SORT OF EITHER
OR I DON'T THINK IT UNDERCUTS
EFFORTS TO PROVIDE LONGER TERM
HOUSING STRATEGIES.
AND AT THIS BILL DOESN'T ALLOW
STUDENTS TO SLEEP IN THEIR
CARSTENS ARE ALREADY SLEEPING IN
THEIR CARS IT ALLOWS AN OF A
SAFE PLACE TO PARK AND I KNOW
THAT JUST YOUR CONVERSATIONS
WITH BOTH OF THE STUDENTS HERE.
THEY TALKED ABOUT KIND OF
NEGATIVE RAMIFICATIONS FROM THE
COMMUNITY WHEN THEY DIDN'T HAVE
A SAFE PLACE TO PARK AND FROM
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
AND SO THAT MADE IT YOU KNOW ODD
A DIFFICULT SITUATION EVEN
HARDER IT SORT OF ADDING INSULT
TO INJURY WHEN NOT ONLY ARE THEY
IN A SITUATION THEY HAVE TO BE
SLEEPING THEIR CARBON THEY'RE
ALSO EXPERIENCING.
YOU KNOW THE KIND OF STIGMA AND
TO BE IS -- FROM THE COMMUNITY
ABOUT HAVING TO DO THAT SO I
THINK WHILE WE WORK ON LONG TERM
STRATEGIES.
RECOGNIZING THAT THIS IS A
CRISIS I MEAN THAT WE SHOULD
HAVE THAT BIAS TOWARD ACTION IN
RESPONDING I'M WITH REALLY THE
LOWEST PAYING FOR THAT WE CAN
POSSIBLY THINK OF AS IMMEDIATELY
AS POSSIBLE.
MR GAVE UP.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I JUST
WANT TO THANK MY COLLEAGUE FOR
REPORT THIS IMPORTANT MEASURE I
REALLY APPLAUD YOU THIS IS A
SUCH A CHALLENGE FACING OUR
STATE -- AND I WANTED TO SAY
THANK YOU ALSO APPLAUD THE THE
WITNESSES AS WELL FOR YOUR VERY
POWERFUL TESTIMONY.
I KNOW THAT IT'S ARE YOU CAN
IMAGINE IT'S NOT AN EASY THING
TO COME UP HERE AND TO TO SHARE
YOUR STORY IN SUCH A PUBLIC WAY
BUT I THINK IT'S REALLY POWERFUL
AND IT REALLY PUTS A FACE ON
WHAT I THINK IS A HUGE MORAL
CRISIS THAT WE'RE FACING.
IS THE STATE'S LARGEST ONE
APPLIED BOTH OF YOU FOR HAVING
THE COURAGE TO COME HERE AND TO
SHARE YOUR STORIES AND SO GLAD
TO HEAR THAT YOU'RE BACK WITH
YOUR FAMILY AND AND JUST
APPRECIATE.
YOUR WILLINGNESS TO TO TO BE
PART OF THIS CONVERSATION -- I
DO UNDERSTAND MY MY COLLEAGUES
THEIR CONCERNS THIS IS THIS IS
AN AS YOU'VE KNOWLEDGE BUT NOT A
LONG TERM SOLUTION.
RIGHT THIS IS UNCOMFORTABLE AND
IN PERFECT RESPONSE TO WHAT IS A
VERY VERY CHALLENGING.
PLEASED TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
TODAY I THINK THAT FOLKS HAVE
MADE SOME SUGGESTIONS ABOUT WAYS
THAT MIGHT BE IMPROVED I
APPRECIATE -- THE AUTHORS
WILLINGNESS TO CONSIDER THOSE I
WOULD SPECIFICALLY HIGHLIGHT --
ANYTHING WE CAN DO TO DO SOME
TYPE OF REPORT EVALUATION
ANALYSIS I THINK THAT SUPPORT
WITH ANY.
ANYTHING THAT WE DO IN PUBLIC
POLICY -- ESPECIALLY SOMETHING
LIKE THIS WHERE WE ARE -- MAYBE --
BREAKING A LITTLE BIT OF NEW
GROUND I THINK EVALUATION
ANALYSIS NUMBER TWO FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO HEAR IS THIS
WORKING IS THIS NOT WORKING ARE
THE WAYS THAT WE CAN IMPROVE
UPON IT -- WOULD BE WOULD BE AN
IMPORTANT THING SO AGAIN JUST
ONE APPLY THE AUTHOR WANT TO
APPLAUD THE WITNESSES FOR YOUR
VERY POWERFUL TESTIMONY AND I'LL
BE PLEASED TO SUPPORT THE BILL
TODAY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHOI.
I THANK THE CHAIR AND THE NORTH
SO I WANNA AT MY A US A QUOTE --
TO A. B..
THREE OH TWO AND ASSEMBLYMEMBER
OF BERMAN SAID -- A CONCERN ON
THIS -- HOME NESS OF STUDENTS.
AND THAT THIS IS THE REALITY.
IN THE LISTENING TO WITNESSES --
I MEAN THIS IS SO.
NOT A FIX AS A TEMPORARY ADDING
A LITTLE MORE CALM FOR THE WAY
TO PARK IN HUNDRED WHEN FORCED
MONTH DENTAL SO.
LOCAL ORDINANCES SO WOULD NOT
ALLOW.
YOU TO PARK IN THE CITY BUT I
AND THEN ALSO.
A SOME AREAS -- DANGERS SO THIS
IS A TEMPORARY -- SOLUTION BUT
WHEN WE PROVIDE THAT THAT KIND
OF A ADDRESS THAT THE ARE YOU
GOING TO AT THAT REQUIRED THE
FINANCIAL RESOURCES SO.
BUT THAT THE STATE CAN PROVIDE
THE FULL.
BECAUSE OF THIS ONE SYSTEM TO
REQUIRE HOLD CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
SO THAT MEANS US OF THE
MANDATING.
SO -- IS IT GONNA BE UNFUNDED
MANDATE THOUGH WHAT I CAN OUR
SUGGEST A CERTAIN DAUGHTERS SO
TO THAT THOUGH BECAUSE SO.
I'M PICTURING MYSELF FOR IT
FOLLOWS.
PROVIDED THAT IS SECURE PLACE
OUR APPRECIATE THE ONCE I SUBMIT
THEIR AND YOU KIND OF WHAT THE
REST ROOM AND THEN THE SHOWER.
AND AN ON CAMPUS OR THE
CAFETERIA VIDEO OR CLOSED I
DON'T KNOW.
SO HOW WE WANT TO ADDRESS THAT
THAT ADDITIONAL CONVENIENCE AT
THAT A OF THE NEEDED YEAH THANK
YOU DOCTOR CHOI AND THANK YOU
FOR YOUR SUPPORT NEEDS THE
IMPORTANT QUESTION AND IF.
IF IT'S REQUIRED IN THE BILL
THEN IT IS A STATE MANDATE AND
AND COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
CAN DISTRICTS WILL GET
REIMBURSED -- FOR THE EXPENSES
AS A PROCESS I GIVE YOU THE
WHOLE PAGE LONG ANSWER BUT ALL
DAHLE D. JUST KIND OF SKIP IT
AND SAY.
IT'S IF IT'S A STATE MANDATE
THEY GET REIMBURSED THERE'S A
PROCESS TO GO THROUGH TO GET
REIMBURSED -- AND AND YOU KNOW
THAT THAT IS AN IMPORTANT PART
OF THE BILL IT HASN'T WE HAVEN'T --
RECEIVED -- FINANCIAL ANALYSIS
YET THAT I HAVE BEEN IN THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE AND SO
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT DOLLAR
AMOUNT IS YET IT ALL HAPPENED
THE PROVISIONS COMMITTEE IF WE
MAKE IT THAT FAR -- BUT BUT IF
IT'S REQUIRED IN THE BILL THEN
IT'S A STATE MANDATE THAT THAT
WOULD BE REIMBURSED.
LIKE AT SOMETHING THAT IF I CAN --
WHEN WE LOOK AT SOME OF THE
COSTS OF THE INFRASTRUCTURE AND --
TO BE PUT IN PLACE TO SUPPORT
THIS.
SO I ACTUALLY -- WE'VE HAD
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE DIRECTOR
OF DREAMS FOR CHANGE WHICH IS --
OVERNIGHT PARKING PROGRAM IN THE
SAN DIEGO AREA THEY RUN OVER TO
OVERNIGHT PARKING PROGRAM
SUCCESSFULLY PROBABLY FIVE TO
SEVEN YEARS NOW -- I WILL NOT
WITHOUT A SINGLE INCIDENT THAT
CONCERNS US SAFETY RELIABILITY
FOR THE PEOPLE INVOLVED.
I'M FOR THE ENTIRE TIME THAT'S
DR THERESA SMITH WHO IS THE
DIRECTOR OF THAT PROGRAM SO
WE'VE HAD HER COME OUT -- AND
PRESENTED ARE -- STERN
GOVERNMENT -- MEETINGS -- AND SO
THE DATA THAT WE'VE GOTTEN FOR
HER AND AGAIN YOU KNOW SHE'S
BEEN RUN INTO THESE PROGRAMS FOR
SEVERAL YEARS.
IS THAT THE COSTS FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE NOW -- AS MISTER --
SOME NOT I'M GONNA STOP A LITTLE
BIT THE DISCUSSION ON THAT
BECAUSE I WILL REMIND THE
COMMITTEE THAT THAT WE ARE THE
POLICY COMMITTEE AND NOT THE AND
NOT THE BUDGET COMMITTEE OR THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE SO IF I
MAY JUST FOR EXPEDIENCY.
OF LET'S MOVE FORWARD THAT'S ALL
RIGHT.
THANK YOU OKAY AT BECAUSE MR
GABRIEL.
THAT IS QUESTION DOCTOR WEBER
AND THEN MISTER SUN -- I DO WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD YOU KNOW I DON'T.
I DON'T THINK ANY OF US WOULD
HAVE THOUGHT. SIX YEARS AGO NOW
WHEN WE STARTED THE CAMPUS
CLIMATE COMMITTEE THAT WE WOULD
BE IN A POSITION OF DEALING WITH
THESE KINDS OF ISSUES AS WELL AS
THE OTHER ISSUES.
BASED ON CAMPUSES -- BUT AS
CHAIR THAT COMMITTEE BECAME VERY
CLEAR THAT WE HAD NOT ONLY
ISSUES OF RACE AND GENDER BUT
ISSUES OF ECONOMIC ON OUR
CAMPUSES.
THAT HAD A THE ABILITY TO REALLY
CHANGE THE CULTURE OF CAMPUSES
AND MAKE THEM VERY DIFFERENT
PLACES AND WE HAD ENVISIONED.
BOB I'M VERY PROUD OF THE FACT
THAT SO MANY OF OUR CAMPUSES OF
TAKEN THE CHALLENGE OF TRYING TO
MEET THE NEEDS OF STUDENTS IN
TERMS OF ECONOMICS -- FOOD IN
SECURITY HOUSING AND SECURITY
YOU KNOW -- TAKING THE STIGMA
OUT OF THE SO CALLED COUCH
SURFING CULTURE AND WHICH WAS A
JOKE THAT IS A REALITY FOR SO
MANY STUDENTS AS THEIR THIS IS
NOT A PERFECT SOLUTION BUT WE
CAN IGNORE THE PROBLEM AND IF SO
WE WILL HAVE EVEN MORE PROBLEMS
THAN BEFORE -- WE SAW THAT IN
SAN DIEGO WHEN WE TRIED TO
IGNORE THE HOMELESS POPULATION
AND ENDED UP WITH THIS HELP.
EIGHT UP WE DIDN'T WANT TO
PROVIDE RESTROOMS IN WANT TO
PROVIDE WATER WE DIDN'T WANT TO
PROVIDE CERTAIN THINGS
INDIVIDUAL THINKING THAT THAT
WOULD HELP THAT WOULD JUST GO
AWAY THAT IF WE HAD.
RESTROOMS AND WATER IN THOSE
KINDS OF THINGS THAT SOMEONE OF
THAT WOULD ENCOURAGE
HOMELESSNESS AND KNOW WHAT IT
DID WAS MAKE PEOPLE DO WHAT THEY
HAD TO DO ALL OF THE CITY IN
FACT EVERYBODY IN HAD PEOPLE
DIED FROM HIP IT.
AND SO WE REALIZED AT LEAST WE
SHOULD HAVE THAT YOU CAN'T
IGNORE THE PROBLEMS YOU HAVE
PROGRESSIVELY FACE THEM THE BEST
WAY YOU CAN AND THEN WORK TO
MAKE SURE THOSE PROBLEMS DON'T
COME BACK.
WE HAVE A MAJOR PROBLEM
OBVIOUSLY KNOCKED ME TO CALL
JUST BECAUSE WE DON'T ADEQUATELY
FUND STUDENTS TO GO TO COMMUNITY
COLLEGE.
YOU KNOW IT'S NOT AS THOUGH THE
HOMELESS POPULATIONS WHICH
GREATER THERE THAN IT IS AT SEA
ISSUE AND YOU SEE BECAUSE THEY
GET LARGER GRANTS TO PAY FOR
HOUSING -- WE GIVE OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS JUST THE MONEY
FOR CLASSES AND BOOKS BUT WE
DON'T WE DON'T FUND HOUSING --
AND AND BECAUSE I SOME XIN IS
THAT THESE ARE.
A LITTLE BIT HIGHER THAN A HIGH
SCHOOL GROUP OF FOLKS AND THEY
STILL LIVING AT HOME WITH MOM
AND DAD AND THE WORLD HAS
CHANGED IN TERMS OF COMMUNITY
COLLEGES.
AND AS A RESULT WE HAVE MORE AND
MORE STUDENTS AND OUR COMMUNITY
IS A HIGHER PERCENTAGE THEN IT
THEN AT C. ISSUE AND YOU SEE WHO
ARE PRUDENT SECURE IN WHO ARE
HOMELESS -- AND AND IT GOES BACK
TO OUR OWN VISION OF WHAT WAS
SUPPOSED TO BE DOING SO.
I'M HOPING THAT IN THE PROCESS
OF THIS.
WHAT IS HAPPENING HERE IN AND
AND IT'S POINTED OUT SAN DIEGO
HAS THESE PLACES WHERE PEOPLE
PART BECAUSE?
WE DISCOVERED THAT THERE WERE
PEOPLE WITH A MOBILE HOME PARK
IN ALL OF OUR NEIGHBORHOODS.
YEAH YOU COME OUT IS A BIT MORE
HOMELESS BEEN SIGNIFICANT RE
DAYS BECAUSE THEY FIND THE CUL
DE SAC THAT'S EMPTY AND IF IT IS
ACTUALLY PEOPLE WHO WAS SLEEPING
THERE THERE THAT THEY'VE.
THEIR CAMPING THERE SO SAN DIEGO
HAD TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT AND
WE CREATED THESE PLACES IN SOME
CHURCHES HAVE PLACES WHERE
PEOPLE PART.
AND THEY PROVIDE SECURITY WE
HAVEN'T HAD AN INCIDENT IN SO
YOU CAN SOMETIMES SEE THAT AND
IT'S A STOP GAP MEASURE WHERE
YOU CAN AT LEAST PUT PEOPLE
TOGETHER AND TRY TO WORK WITH
THEM TO GET THE RESOURCES THEY
NEED. TO GET THEM OUT OF THAT
POSITION AND GET THEM BACK IN
THE HOUSING VERY FEW PEOPLE WANT
TO BE HOMELESS.
AND YOU KNOW VERY FEW THERE ARE
FEW WHO WHO WHO AS YOU PULL OUT
BUT MOST FOLKS DON'T WANT THAT
THEY WANT TO BE SECURE SO.
I THANK YOU FOR THIS I KNOW
YOU'RE GOING TO DRESS ALL THE
ISSUES THAT OUR CAMPUSES HAVE --
MAKING SURE THAT THERE'S SOME OF
SAFETY IN THOSE KINDS OF THINGS
BUT IF WE DON'T PASS THIS BILL.
THEY WILL STILL BE HOMELESS.
AND THEY WILL STILL BE TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO PARK THE CAR
AND WHAT THEY'RE GOING TO DO AT
LEAST AT SOME POINT THIS PUTS
THEM IN ONE PLACE SO WE CAN
BEGIN.
TO TARGET THEM AND GET THE
RESOURCES THEY NEED THERE BUT
ALSO THE RESOURCES ON CAMPUS SO
I THANK YOU -- FOR BRINGING THE
BILL FOR THANK YOU THANK YOU TO
WHOEVER [inaudible]
SANTIAGO.
YOU KNOW I KIND OF THINK -- MISS
WEBBER WAS LOOKING AT MY NOTES.
THOSE ARE THE EXACT SAME TWO
THINGS UP AND LEAVE.
BECAUSE I I HAVE THEM IN THE
AUTHOR I'VE TALKED IN THE PAST
RIGHT IF I WEAR MY PREVIOUS
COMMITTEE COLLEGE FOR PRESIDENT --
WAS THE PRESIDENT THE LARGEST
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT IN
CALIFORNIA -- LA CCD AND IF I
WERE MY POLICY ONE CAT AND THEN
THIS DOESN'T MAKE SENSE.
AND SIMPLY DOESN'T MAKE SENSE IN
A DOZEN PENCIL OUT.
BUT THEN IN THIS PARTICULAR
ISSUE I CURRENTLY WITH MY HEART --
IN IN IN AND I WILL ECHO SINCE
YOU'RE READING UP MY NOSE
ANYWAYS YEAH REPEAT NORTH.
BUT LET ME THAT.
I HAVE A CHALLENGE WITH THE BUT
IT'S IT'S MY HEART BUT I'M A LET
LEAD ON THIS PARTICULAR THIS
PARTICULAR VOTE BECAUSE NO ONE
WANTS. TO BE HOMELESS.
NO WAKES UP IN THE MORNING SAYS
I WANT TO BE HOMELESS.
I AT LEAST I HAVE MET SOMEBODY
WHO SAYS THAT YET.
AND MOST WE KNOW THAT HOW HOW
PASSIONATE ABOUT BUT I AM ABOUT
THAT ISSUE -- I REPRESENT THE
AREA SKID ROW WHERE THOUSANDS
AND THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE LIVES ON
THAT BUT I ALSO UNDERSTAND WHEN
BAD POLICY DECISIONS.
ARE AND WHERE AND WHEN -- URBAN
PLANNING IS A WELL THOUGHT OUT
IT CREATES THOSE KIND OF
SITUATIONS.
SOME CONSCIOUS OF THAT IN AND
WHEN I TAKE A LOOK AT THIS.
WHICH IS WHY I STARTED SAYING IT
WITH I'M WEARING MY POLICY ONE
CANNOT MORE INTO MY COMMITTEE
COLLEGE BOARD ATTIC CETERA.
I TAKE A LOOK AT THIS DECISION
AND I GET TO GO PRETTY BAD.
ABSOLUTELY PRETTY BAD
[inaudible]
ON AND THAT'S WHY I THERE'S A
CAUTIOUS SIDE INSIDE AND YOU
LOOK LIKE AYE AYE TRUSTING YOUR
COMMITMENTS TO ADDRESS SOME OF
THESE ISSUES BECAUSE OUR SERVICE --
AND I TRUST THAT YOU BEEN
RESPONSIBLE OF KEPT YOUR WORD
AND AND AND ARE REALLY
STRUGGLING TO TO ADDRESS SOME OF
THOSE ISSUES -- AND THERE ARE
SEVERAL RIGHT THERE'S A
LIABILITY ISSUE THERE'S OF
INSURANCE ISSUE -- HOW DO YOU
DETERMINE -- WHO'S A STUDENT AND
WHO'S NOT -- IN OUR AREA NOT
THAT THEY MAY BE COOKIE CUTTER
SOLUTIONS TO THEM THAT THAT THAT
FOLKS A MENTION TO ME.
AT THE END OF THE DAY IT DO YOU
FOR SOMEBODY TO SHOW --
IDENTIFICATION OR NOT IF THERE'S
OTHER PEOPLE IN THE CAR WOULD
YOU DO -- THAT THERE'S A NUMBER
OF THINGS MY HEART WILL LEAD TO
SAY THAT WE'VE GOT TO DO
SOMETHING -- AND AND STUDENTS
HAVE TO BE SAFE SOMEWHERE NOT
NECESSARILY HAPPY WITH THAT
BECAUSE OF THERE'S IT'S
PROBLEMATIC -- YOU WHERE THE
SHOWER -- YOU DID YOU KNOW WE'RE
NOT PRESSING COMMUNITY COLLEGES
TO ADDRESS AND REDEFINE
THEMSELVES TO WHAT THEY SHOULD
BE TODAY WHAT WHICH IS HELPING
WITH WORKFORCE HOUSING WITH IS
HELPING.
A WITH ROB BROWN SUPPORT
SERVICES WITH STUDENTS -- THE
SIMPLE THINGS LIKE HAVING A
STUDENT FILL OUT A FASSEL FORM --
COUNSELORS WRAPAROUND SUPPORT
SERVICES GETTING EVERYONE ON
THEIR FEET BUT SOMETHING LIKE
THIS CAN GO PRETTY BAD IF IT'S
NOT DONE.
CORRECTLY.
AND WHAT DO YOU DO LIKE IN OUR
CARE WE STE WE CONTRACTED WITH
THE SHARES -- FOR UP FOR PUBLIC
SAFETY REASONS -- EIGHT WOULD
YOU DO IF A STINT AS WANT TO
SHOW IDENTIFICATION TO SHARE IT
WOULD YOU DO IF THE SHERIFF --
WALKS AROUND IN HIS -- LOOKING
IN IN THE CARS I MEAN WHAT KIND
OF SAFE GUARDS TO PUT INTO PLACE --
AND THERE'S A LOT OF ANSWERED
UNANSWERED QUESTIONS WHICH I
BELIEVE THESE BECOME -- BECOMES
A PROBLEMATIC TO IMPLEMENT AS IT
IS.
BUT I LEAD WITH MY HEART
UNDERSTANDING IN KNOWING THAT
YOU'RE GONNA DO THE VERY BEST
POSSIBLE JOB.
I DO THIS BUT WE'LL RESERVE MY
RIGHT NONE THE LESS HI ON THE
FLORIDA VOTE HOT ONE BUT YOU
KNOW BUT THAT TAKES IT'S A HUGE
CHALLENGE.
I WOULDN'T WANT YOU TO YOU TO
FOR ME -- TO BECOME COMPLACENT
AND AND THINK THAT THIS IS GOING
TO BE SOLVED THE PROBLEM I THINK
WE'VE GOT A PUSH TO BE TO FIND
WHAT COMMUNITY COLLEGES DO HOW
SERVICES.
ARE HANDLED WHAT COUNSELOR
SHOULD DO -- WHETHER THEY BE TRY
AND WHETHER WE HELP IN ROLE
PEOPLE AND CAL WORKS -- MEDI CAL --
ECCENTRICS FEDERAL EITC PROGRAMS
OF ALL KINDS OF DIFFERENT THINGS
THAT WE HAVE TO DO WE HAVE TO
PUSH SIMILAR BUT EVEN STUDENT
HOUSING ALTHOUGH I UNDERSTAND
THE CHALLENGES WITH.
WITH TO YOUR PART TIME STUDENT
SUCCESS -- BUT I THINK LOOK AT I
THINK IT'S WORTH THE
CONVERSATION HAVE BECAUSE WE'VE
GOT TO ADDRESS -- THE HOMELESS
ISSUE IN CALIFORNIA WE'VE GOT TO
ALSO ADDRESS.
CHILDREN IN AND SMALL -- SINGLE
MOTHERS LIVING ON THE STREETS
AND AND STUDENTS LIVING IN THEIR
CARS.
HI AM AND FOR THE REASONS HOLD
ON MY HEART TO LEAD ON THIS.
ONE THEY USE ON THE BIRTH.
MR LIVING -- GET GREAT GREAT
BILL GREAT STARTING POINT WE'RE
SOLVING AN IMMEDIATE NEED WE DO
THE SAME THING WITH THE SHOWERS
A FEW YEARS AGO PEOPLE NEED TO
HAVE A WAY TO BE SUCCESSFUL WITH
THEIR DAY KNOWING WHERE THEY'RE
GOING TO SLEEP IS ANOTHER
IMPORTANT COMPONENT TO THAT --
DOESN'T GET THE JOB DONE AS WE
KNOW AND WE NEED TO FIGURE OUT A
WAY THAT THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES
AS THEIR IDENTIFYING WHO THOSE
STUDENTS ARE ARE ALSO ABLE TO
PUSH OUT -- MISS SANTIAGO
MENTION WRAPAROUND SERVICES IS
EVERYONE AVAILING THEMSELVES OF
THE FINANCIAL AID THAT MAY CAN
RECEIVE.
HOW CAN WE HELP YOU TO SOMETHING
BETTER THAN THIS HOMELESSNESS
ARE PRECARIOUSLY HOUSE STATE AND
YOUR FOR REGISTERING THOSE CARS
HOWEVER STUDENTS DO THAT?
THAT THAT IS ONE WAY TO CAPTURE
THEM IN A POSITIVE WAY TO SAY
ARE WE GIVING YOU ALL THE
SUPPORT THAT YOU ALREADY QUALIFY.
FOR THAT YOU JUST DIDN'T KNOW
THAT YOU WERE ABLE TO GET.
WE CAN GET THEM KIND OF WHAT'S
COMING WHAT SHOULD BE COMING
THEIR WAY IF THEY JUST KNEW HOW
TO DO IT -- SO PLEASED TO VOTE
FOR THIS TODAY AND AND THANKS
TAKE ON THIS HEART ISSUE.
THE BILL.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER LIVE
IN.
THANK YOU.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY.
LOADED MISTER LEVINE A SECOND BY.
MR GAVE.
TAKEN BY MR GABRIEL -- STIR
BERMAN WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I
JUST REALLY APPRECIATE THE THE
THOUGHT FULL DIALOGUE THAT THAT
WE'VE ALL HAD TODAY AND A LOT OF
THOSE SERIOUS CONCERNS THAT WERE
RAISED -- THAT WE ARE TAKING A
HARD THAT WE ARE LOOKING INTO
THAT WE WILL WORK TO TRY TO
ADDRESSES MANY OF THEM AS WE CAN
AND WORK WITH YOU ALL TO ADDRESS --
AS WE MOVE THIS BILL FORD SHOULD
MAKE IT OUT OF THE HIGHER
EDUCATION COMMITTEE TODAY AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU WELL I I ALSO WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD.
IT IS WE HAD THE HEARINGS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE -- WE WE
SAW THE STUDENTS LIKE WE DID
TODAY LINE UP TO TALK ABOUT THE
FOOD AND SECURITY AND AND NOT
HAVING A PLACE.
TO SPEND THE NIGHT -- SO I I I
THANK THE AUTHOR I'M ALSO AWARE
OF OUR OWN CHAIR OUR OWN PASTOR
OF THIS COMMITTEE WAS --
HOMELESS AND SLEPT IN HIS CAR
WHEN HE WAS A STUDENT AND SANTA
BARBARA CITY COLLEGE.
SO I REMEMBER -- STORIES THAT HE
SHARE ALSO WE WE SEE SIGNS YOU
KNOW NO PARKING OVERNIGHT.
IT'S NEAR SOME OF OUR CAMPUSES --
AND SO I YOU KNOW I I HAVE THANK
ALL THE MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE FOR THEIR DISCUSSION I
AGREE WITH MR BLOOM THIS IS NOT
A A FINAL.
A SOLUTION -- AND I SHARE MR
SANTIAGO'S CONCERNS AS A FORMER
COMMUNITY COLLEGE IT RAISES
ISSUES.
BUT THE THOUGHT COMES TO MIND
THE BETTER TO LIGHT THE CANDLE
THAN TO CURSE THE DARKNESS SO
IT'S IT'S A IT'S A STEP.
IT'S A STEP I THINK IT'S THE
RIGHT SET UP AND I'M I'M HAPPY --
TO SUPPORT THIS BILL.
SO YOU MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE MEDINA
AYE MEDINA AYE CHOI.
CHOI I JONES SAWYER BLOOM.
BLOOM I GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I IRWIN -- WHEN NOT
VOTING KILEY?
KILEY I LEVINE.
LEVINE I LOW.
LOW I PATTERSON.
PATTERSON NOT VOTING SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I WEBER.
WEBER I'D. NINE ZERO THE BILL IS
OUT WE WILL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OF MEDINA THANK YOU MISTER.
BERMAN.
NEXT SIGNED FILE ORDER FILE ITEM
OR I'M SORRY IN SIGN IN ORDER
FILE ITEM FOR NOTE.
FILE ITEM ONE MISTER IS THERE.
HE'S STILL HERE [inaudible]
NO.
NO THEN WILL CONTINUE IN IN --
SIGN IN ORDER FILE ITEM ELEVEN
MISTER REID REDUCE.
WELCOME MISTER RODRIGUEZ.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN BURST.
THANKS FOR OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT AB.
EIGHT FORTY THREE AB EIGHT FORTY
THREE REINSTATES FUNDING FOR THE
ASSUMPTION PROGRAM OF LOANS FOR
EDUCATION ALSO KNOWN AS APPLE I.
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE PROGRAM
CREATED TO HELP FUTURE IN
CURRENT EDUCATORS.
AND PUBLIC KATE.
TO K. THROUGH TWELVE SCHOOLS
WITH THE BURDEN OF STUDENT LOANS.
APPLE WAS CREATED IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY TWO BUT WAS DE FUNDED IN
TWENTY TWELVE DUE TO BUDGET
CONSTRAINTS.
SECOND.
THE STATE EXPERIENCING A SEVERE
TEACHER SHORTAGE AND HAS
RESTORED THE TO ISSUE AN
EMERGENCY STOP TEACHING PERMITS
AS A RESPONSE.
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN CALIFORNIA
ISSUED OVER TWELVE THOUSAND
EMERGENCY INTERN CREDENTIALS
PERMITS AND WAIVERS.
TEACHERS WILL BE ABLE TO RECEIVE
UP TO NINETEEN THOUSAND THIS
WILL INCENTIVIZE STUDENTS TO
ENTER THE TEACHING FIELD AND
HELP ADDRESS THE TEACHER
SHORTAGE WE HAVE GOING ON ACROSS
CALIFORNIA.
WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY IS ME
YOU KEEP.
AMONG THE NOT A ON BEHALF OF THE
CULT CO SPONSOR CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION SHE IS
CURRENTLY SERVES AS THE
PRESIDENT OF THE STUDENT
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION.
ON ORGANIZATION OF STUDENTS AND
THEIR UNDERGRADUATE AND GRADUATE
LEVEL COURSEWORK.
WHO ASPIRE TO BECOME EDUCATORS
THANK YOU?
LET ME LET ME JUST A TO HELP BUT
EXPEDIA I. SPEEDY EIGHT EXCUSE
ME.
ROSS IS TO REMIND THE WITNESSES
THAT THIS ENJOYS SUPPORT SUPPORT.
CODE FOR THE GET GOOD AFTERNOON --
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS I AM I
NEED TO SPEAK COMMANDS NATO
REPRESENTING FIFTEEN HUNDRED
TALENTED INDIVIDUALS ACROSS
FIFTY PLUS COLLEGE CAMPUSES
PREPARING TO BECOME EDUCATORS
LOOKING FORWARD TO JOINING
CALIFORNIA'S TEACHER WORK FORCE --
WE COME FROM EVERY CORNER OF
CALIFORNIA AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO SERVING THE DIVERSE STUDENTS
OF CALIFORNIA ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
A PRO CO SPONSOR OF THE SPELL --
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER RODRIGUEZ WE
URGE YOUR AYE VOTE ON THIS BILL
TO INVEST IN TALENTED
INDIVIDUALS LIKE MY FELLOW
STUDENTS HE TEAM MEMBERS THE
APPLE PROGRAM PROVIDES
MEANINGFUL FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE.
TO FUTURE EDUCATORS PURSUE A
CAREER IN PUBLIC EDUCATION
WHETHER INDIVIDUALS COME FROM A
LONG LINE OF EDUCATORS SUCH AS
MYSELF OR ARE YOU KNOW FIRST
GENERATION COLLEGE STUDENTS MID
CAREER CHANGERS THIS PROGRAM
PROVIDE.
ENCOURAGES TALENTED STUDENTS
BECOME EDGE EDUCATORS BY EASING
DEBT BURDEN AFTER BECOMING
CREDENTIAL TEACHER KEY SHORTAGE
AREAS.
THE STATE'S INVESTMENT
YESTERDAY'S APPLE PROGRAM
TEACHER CANDIDATES YOU'LL THE
TEACHER CORPS -- A CURRENT
TEACHER WORK FORCE NOT ONLY
GRATEFUL FOR THE FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE THAT THEY RECEIVED.
BUT ALSO HAD A INDIVIDUALS ARE
DEEPLY PASSIONATE DEVOTED TO THE
TO THE PROFESSION.
BY RESTORING THE APPLE PROGRAM
THIS WILL BRING RENEWED HOPE AND
INVESTED FOR INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
NEEDED TO WITH THE AT THE
GROWING TEACHER WORKFORCE.
AS PART OF THEIR TEACHER
PREPARATION PROGRAMS TEACHER
CANDIDATES BUT THIRTY BETWEEN
HEAVY COURSEWORK ANTI STUDENT
TEACHING WOMEN IN NO TIME TO
CREATE A SOURCE OF INCOME. FOR
THEIR LIVES KNOWING THEIR
AVENUES FOR DEBT RELIEF.
SUCH AS THE APPLE PROGRAM AFTER
BECOME A CREDENTIAL TEACHER WILL
BRING US RENEWED HOPE.
US INVESTMENT IN EDUCATOR
WORKFORCE WITH APPLE PROGRAMS DO
NOT ASSUMPTIONS PROVED
BENEFICIAL NOT ONLY TO
CREDENTIALED TEACHERS.
WHO TEACH MATH SCIENCE SPECIAL
EDUCATION BILINGUAL EDUCATION OR
CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION HIGH
NEED DISTRICTS BUT ALSO FOR
STUDENTS THAT THEY SERVE?
ULTIMATELY ENTERING THE TEACHER
WORK FOR SHOULD NOT BE A DEATH
SENTENCE.
AB EIGHT FORTY THREE RESTORES
THE UPPER PROGRAM FOR FUTURE
EDUCATORS LIKE MY STUDENTS HE
TEAM MEMBERS WHO ARE GOING ABOVE
AND BEYOND THE CHALLENGES OF
COLLEGE STUDENTS FACE TODAY IN
ORDER TO ADVANCE VALUES WE HOLD
DEAR TO US SUCH AS COMMUNITY
SERVICE.
TEACHER QUALITY AND DIVERSITY CJ
THANKS THE AUTHOR FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP ON THE SPELL AND FOR
THE REASONS GIVEN RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF RON RAP ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS AND A PRO A PROUD CO
SPONSOR OF THIS LEGISLATION AND
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF
YOU GIVE YOUR NAME IN THE GROUP
YOU REPRESENT.
SERRA LESS ON BEHALF TEACH PLUS
IN SUPPORT.
RIGHT -- MASSARO WITH PUBLIC
ADVOCATES IN SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
ANY TWEETERS.
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE.
SEE NONE.
IF THE AUTHOR WOULD LIKE TO
CLOSE.
R. SPEC RUSHED RIGHT ABOUT THANK
YOU.
I JUST WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD AS A
FORMER TEACHER OF THIRTY FOUR
YEARS YOU KNOW I REMEMBER WHAT
MY INCOME WAS WHEN I STARTED
TEACHING.
AND BEING ABLE TO REPAY STUDENT
LOANS WOULD HAVE BEEN A GOOD
THANKS SO.
VERY MUCH APPLY THE OTHER FOR
BRINGING FORWARD.
DO WE HAVE WE HAD A MOTION BY
MISTER LOW A SECOND BY
[inaudible]
DOCTOR WEBER [inaudible]
MADAM SECRETARY.
CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE MEDINA
AYE MEDINA AYE CHOI.
CHOICE I JONES SAWYER HI JONES
SAWYER AYE BLOOM [inaudible]
GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I IRWIN -- WHEN I KILEY?
LEVINE.
LEVINE I LOW.
LOW I PATTERSON.
PATTERSON I'D SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I'D WEBER [inaudible]
WEBER HI. TEN ZERO THE BILL IS
OUT WE WILL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS [inaudible]
RIGHT.
GOING BACK TO SIGN IN.
ORDER ITEM NUMBER.
ONE MR AS OUR AND AGAIN I WILL
REMIND EVERYONE THAT IT ENJOYS
SUPPORT SUPPORT.
BUT THE BILL.
WELL GOOD AFTERNOON.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
COLLEAGUES.
I JUST WANT TO BRIEFLY TOUCH ON
A FEW POINTS AND AND ALLOW MOST
OF THE TIME -- FOR FOR THE
WONDERFUL -- SPONSORS AND
SUPPORTERS THAT THAT ARE HERE
WITH ME RESEARCH HAS
CONSISTENTLY SHOWN THE
CORRELATION BETWEEN HIGH SCHOOL
DROPOUT RATES AND POVERTY.
ACCORDING TO STUDIES OF A
NUMEROUS STUDIES ROUGHLY FIVE
INTENT HIGH SCHOOL DROPOUTS.
WERE LIVING IN POVERTY 48%
COMPARED TO LESS THAN ONE IN TEN
COLLEGE GRADUATES ONLY AT EIGHT
POINT 6%.
SECOND THERE IS GROWING
RECOGNITION THAT THE COST OF
HIGHER EDUCATION AND BURDEN OF
STUDENT THAT OR SERIOUS BARRIERS
TO ECONOMIC MOBILITY.
THIS IS WHERE CHILDREN SAVINGS
ACCOUNT FALLS INTO PLAYING A
MAJOR ROLE AB FIFTEEN WOULD
CREATE A STATEWIDE CHILDREN
SAVINGS PROGRAM -- TO BY TESTING
THE SCHOLARS SURE INVESTMENT
BOARD TO OPERATE A MASTER FIVE
TWENTY NINE ACCOUNT OWNED BY THE
STATE.
THE CHILD WILL AUTOMATICALLY BE
ENROLLED IN THE MASTER ACCOUNT
AT BIRTH AND RECEIVE AN INITIAL
C. DEPOSIT -- AND THE PROGRAM
WILL ALLOW PRIVATE PHILANTHROPY
TO CONTRIBUTE TO THE FUND AND
ENCOURAGE ADDITIONAL INCENTIVES
FOR LOW INCOME FAMILIES -- THREE
POINTS THAT I'D LIKE TO MAKE IS
AB FIFTEEN WILL ULTIMATELY JUMP
START COLLEGE SAVINGS FOR
ROUGHLY.
OF FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
CHILDREN.
BORN EACH YEAR IN CALIFORNIA TO
CREATE A GIVE CHILDREN A REAL
WORLD TOOL TO PRACTICE FINANCIAL
LEADERS LITERACY.
AND THREE ENABLE STUDENTS TO
RAISE THEIR OWN EDUCATIONAL
EXPECTATIONS WITH ME I'M VERY
PROUD TO HAVE NOW YOU KNOW HOW
BAD YOUNG FROM GLENDALE UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT.
AS WELL AS SABRINA HIM FROM THE
CALIFORNIA ASSET BUILDING
COALITION -- AS WELL AS WELL AS
BEING JOINED BY THE STAFF FROM
THE US.
STATE TREASURER'S OFFICE.
AND WE'LL KEEP YOU TO FOUR
MINUTES YOU DON'T HAVE TO USE
ALL THE TIME.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH CHAIRPERSON
MEDINA AND COMMITTEE -- ON
HIGHER EDUCATION FOR HAVING ME
HERE TODAY MY NAME IS SABRINA
HAM I'M THE MANAGING DIRECTOR
FOR THE CALIFORNIA ASSET
BUILDING COALITION -- CBC
REPRESENTS OVER TO THE TWO
HUNDRED ORGANIZATIONS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA AND WE WORK TO
SUPPORT POLICIES AND PROGRAMS TO
HELP LOW TO MODERATE INCOME
FAMILIES BECOME MORE FIND
FINANCIALLY SECURE.
AND A CHEAP ECONOMIC MOBILITY WE
ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
FIFTEEN WHICH WOULD CREATE A
UNIVERSAL CHILDREN SAVINGS%
ACCOUNT FOR EVERY CHILD AT BIRTH.
IN CALIFORNIA UNDER THE STATE'S
BY TWENTY NINE SCHOLARSHIP
PROGRAM RESEARCH SHOWS THAT A
CHILD WITH ANY AMOUNT OF MONEY
FOR STATE FOR COLLEGE IS THREE
TIMES MORE LIKELY TO ATTEND
COLLEGE AND FOUR TIMES MORE
LIKELY TO GRADUATE.
CHILDREN SAVINGS ACCOUNT
CONTINUE TO DEMONSTRATE
OVERWHELMING.
THE POSITIVE IMPACT ON CHILDREN
AND THEIR FAMILIES WE ARE
THRILLED TO HAVE SO MANY LOCAL
BASED PROGRAMS ACROSS THE STATE.
HOWEVER THEY ARE NOT AVAILABLE
TO ALL CHILDREN.
WE ARE IN NEED OF A UNIVERSAL
PROGRAM TO REACH THE CHILDREN
WHO DO NOT RESIDE IN THE AREAS
WERE LOCAL SAID SAVINGS.
ACCOUNTS ARE OFFERED WE FIRMLY
BELIEVE THAT ALL STUDENTS SHOULD
HAVE ACCESS TO A SAVINGS ACCOUNT
PROGRAM.
AND THE UNIVERSAL PROGRAM THAT
AB FIFTEEN PUTS FORTH WOULD
ENSURE THAT ALL CHILDREN START
WITH THE SMALL AMOUNT OF SEED
MONEY IN A FIVE TWENTY NINE
ACCOUNT.
MORE FAMILIES WILL HAVE COLLEGE
GOING CULTURE AND EXPECTATION
FOR THEIR CHILD.
AN INCREASE CULTURE FOR
AFFORDABILITY FOR LOW INCOME
FAMILIES.
IF WE DO NOT ACT NOW
CALIFORNIANS WILL FALL BEHIND IN
OUR BASEMENT IN CHILDREN.
THERE ARE STATEWIDE PROGRAMS IN
ABOUT FIVE OTHER STATES SEVERAL
OTHER STATE LEGISLATORS ARE
CONTAINED ARE CONSIDERING
SIMILAR LEGISLATION IN AB
FIFTEEN THIS YEAR INCLUDING
ILLINOIS MASSACHUSETTS NEW YORK
AND WASHINGTON.
THE TIME IS NOW FOR CAP FOR THE
STATE TO INVEST IN EVERY CHILD
IN CALIFORNIA AND THE FUTURE OF
OUR STATE.
I'M I THINK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
NEWSSTAND FOR HIS CONTINUED
COMMITMENT AND LEADERSHIP ON
THIS AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
COMMITTEE FOR YOUR AYE ABOUT
THANK YOU -- HELLO I'M NINE
ARENA HOW BAD YOUNG AND I'M A
BOARD OF EDUCATION MEMBER AND ON
THE UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT AND
ALSO A FACULTY MEMBER AT CAL
STATE LA IN THE SCHOOL OF SOCIAL
WORK.
CHILDREN SAVINGS ACCOUNT CSA'S
ARE A POWERFUL TOOL TO CHANGE
THE TRAJECTORY OF KIDS LIVES
UNIVERSAL CSA'S GIVE FINANCIAL
ASSETS TO ALL KIDS BUT IT'S THE
KIDS WITH THE GREATEST NEEDS WHO
SHOW THE GREATEST GAINS.
BENEFITS OF SAVINGS ACCOUNTS ARE
REALLY WELL RESEARCH AND
DEMONSTRATED AT THIS POINT
THERE'S NO QUESTION ABOUT IT
CSA'S FROM BIRTH HAVE SHOWN TO
IMPROVE CHILDREN'S.
NOT ONLY WHAT WAS MENTIONED
BEFORE BUT ALSO THEIR SOCIAL AND
EMOTIONAL DEVELOPMENT.
WHICH IS DIRECTLY LINKED TO
LATER ACADEMIC ACHIEVEMENT CSA'S
A CREATE A COLLEGE GOING MIND
SET WHICH IS CRUCIAL FOR COLLEGE
ATTENDANCE.
AS AN EXAMPLE JUST LAST YEAR.
IT GLENDALE UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT WE ENROLLED AT
ROOSEVELT MIDDLE SCHOOL STUDENTS
AND A PILOT FIVE TWENTY NINE
ACCOUNT.
AND WE QUICKLY NOTICED JUSTIN
THE MERE. ONE HUNDRED CASES THAT
WE ENROLLED -- THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THE STUDENTS WHO HAD THE
SEAT DOLLARS AND THE STUDENTS
WHO DID NOT HAVE THE THREE
DOLLARS THOSE WITH THE ACCOUNTS
WERE MORE INQUISITIVE.
ENTHUSIASTIC AND SERIOUSLY
ENGAGED WHEN THREE MONTHS LATER
WE DID AN ACTIVE WE DID
ACTIVITIES AROUND CAREER AND
COLLEGE PATHWAYS PLANNING.
CSA'S REYES PARENTS EXPECTATIONS
OF THEIR CHILDREN.
AND A BOOSTED THEIR OWN MENTAL
HEALTH PARENTS MENTAL HEALTH
WHICH IS IMPORTANT BECAUSE
THAT'S LINKED TO PARENTS
ENGAGING WITH THEIR STUDENTS
WITH THEIR CHILDREN.
AND THUS BEING ENGAGE WITH THEIR
EDUCATION.
SO THAT'S OUR REDEVELOPMENT TREE
WE HAD PARENTS TELL US THAT THEY
WOULD HAVE NEVER CONSIDERED JUST
THINKING ABOUT COLLEGE AND
SAVINGS HAD WE HAD NOT OPENED
THESE ACCOUNTS FOR THEM LAST
YEAR.
AND FINALLY CSA'S INCREASE
PARENTS THE LIKELIHOOD OF SAVING
THEIR OWN MONEY FOR THEIR KIDS
FUTURE.
THE FACT IS THAT CHILDREN FORM
IDEAS ABOUT THEIR FUTURE VERY
VERY EARLY IN THEIR LIVES.
A FORM IDEAS ABOUT THEIR
CAPACITIES THERE POSSIBILITIES
AND THEIR COLLEGE AND THEIR
CAREER OPPORTUNITIES.
POVERTY CONTINUES TO BE
CORRELATED WITH MANY KINDS OF
CHALLENGES STRESSORS ABUSE
NEGLECT AND LACK OF OPPORTUNITY
AND IT IS NOT AN OVERSTATEMENT
TO SAY THAT GETTING ONE YOUTH.
TO COLLEGE OR ON THE CORRECT
CAREER PATH GOES A LONG WAY
TOWARD LIFTING THAT WHOLE FAMILY.
OUT OF POVERTY IN ONE GENERATION
WITH THE STATE WIDE INTERVENTION
THOUGH A STATE WIDE WHICH IS
WHAT IS NEEDED LIKE AB EIGHT ONE
FIVE WE CAN TRULY MOVE TOWARD
GETTING OUR MOST VULNERABLE KIDS.
HEAD START AND REALLY ELEVATING
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES INTO A
BRIGHTER FUTURE AND A STATEWIDE
MEASURE.
THANK YOU THINK AND OTHER
WITNESSES HAVE YOU IT PLEASE
STATE YOUR NAME AND THE
ORGANIZATION YOU REPRESENT GOOD
AFTERNOON POSH ON THE UC SOON
ASSOCIATION WE'RE IN SUPPORT.
EIGHTY ONE REPRESENTING AMERICAN
ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS AND
SUPPORT.
ALSO WORKS WITH THE CITY OF
OAKLAND WE HAVE A SUPPORT OF
AMEND POSITION WE APPRECIATE ALL
THE AUTHORS WORK ON THIS.
BRIAN HOW THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS WE HAVE
HIS POSITION ON IT THANK YOU.
REBEKAH GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
ANGELA WILLIAMS CALIFORNIA'S
LIKE ALFA WORK IN SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ANY TWEETERS ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
MISTER NAZARIAN IF YOU'D LIKE TO
CLOSE.
I HAVE SOME QUESTIONS
[inaudible]
THANK CHAIR.
FIND THE THAT THIS IS SUPPORT
SUPPORT.
YEAH I I YEAH I DO SUPPORT DOT.
I LIKE THAT -- BECAUSE I HAVE
ALSO SIMILAR -- IT NOT NOT BY
SIMILAR BUT THEY'RE RELATED THIS
US GONNA SHARE -- FIVE TWENTY
NINE I THINK THE BILL NUMBERS OF
FOUR FOUR FOUR TO HAVE A TAX --
A DEDUCTION ABILITY -- FOR
PARENTS TO IN IN IN THE INVESTOR
AND YET AND YET THE PERSON BUT
THIS ONE IS SOME MANDATED.
THE ASIAN OFF -- SCHOLARS SHARE
ON THE FIVE TWENTY NINE AND THE
STATE THAT AT THE IS A LACK OF
SOCIAL SECURITY AUTOMATICALLY --
YOU ARE MANDATING REQUIRING FOR
OUT BUT I DO SEE THAT THE
ABILITY TO OPT OUT.
BUT THE THE SENATE ESSENTIALLY --
YOU ARE.
EXPECTING EVERYBODY -- TO IS SET
UP BOB -- FIVE TWENTY NINE PLAN
AND THE TWENTY FIVE DOLLARS SO
THE INITIAL -- INVESTMENT THE BY
THE STATE.
BUT MY QUESTION IS -- ANY ANY
SCHOLARSHIP FUND IS SO GOOD THEN --
NOT HAVING ANYTHING THIS IS AN
CORD TO MATT AS WE HEAR FROM
THAT WITNESSES SO.
BUT I WONDER HOW YOU ARE NOT
TECHNICALLY.
HANDLE.
IF I HAVE MY OWN CHARS OF FIVE
TWENTY NINE PLAN ALREADY -- AND
DO I A HOW DO I USED ON ONE PLAN
WHAT CAN I SET UP A FIVE TWENTY
NINE MULTIPLE PLANS A DUST ONE
WALL.
MORE THAN ONE THE C. DEPOSIT THE
IS NOT GONNA BE ALLOWED THE BUT
THE THAT THAT SOUNDS LIKE A YOUR
ALLOWING MORE THAN.
ONE FIVE TWENTY NINE PLAN SO
THAT'S THE AREA I'M NOT CLEAR
ABOUT IF YOU CAN EXPECT A VERY
BRIEFLY MISTER CHAIR IF I CAN.
OF ALL AND I'LL KEEP IT BRIEF
AND I'M HAPPY TO TALK ABOUT THIS
AT LENGTH LATER IF YOU'D LIKE AS
WELL UP.
CONGRATULATIONS IF IF YOU DO
HAVE A FIVE TWENTY NINE PLAN FOR
YOUR CHILD YOU ARE THE LUCKY
WINNER OF BEING PART OF 3% OF
CALIFORNIANS THAT ACTUALLY HAVE
A PLAN FOR THEIR CHILD.
THIS IS THE PROBLEM THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO ADDRESS -- THIS IS A
VERY VALUABLE TOOL AND IT'S A
TOOL THAT CAN HELP UTILIZED THE
MARKET GROWTH. TO HELP ENHANCE
YOUR CHILD'S OPPORTUNITY.
TO BE BETTER EDUCATED FOR FOR
FOR HAVE A CAREER BUILDING
OPPORTUNITIES BUT UNFORTUNATELY
MANY PEOPLE ARE NOT UTILIZING IT
SAID THIS BILL.
IS JUST TO KIND OF JUMP START
THAT OPPORTUNITY MAKE THAT HAVE
THE STATE MAKE THE INITIAL
INVESTMENT.
OF MAYBE THERE WOULD BE A LOCAL
MATCHING PROGRAM BECAUSE MANY
CITIES AND JURISDICTIONS IN
CALIFORNIA ARE NOW LOOKING AT
DOING THIS AS EVIDENCED BY WHAT
OF A SCHOOL BOARD MEMBER NOT
THAT YOUNG WAS TALKING ABOUT.
OF MOTIVATE PARENTS TO BECOME
MORE ENGAGED AND INVEST.
AND THEN LAST BUT NOT LEAST
ALLOW PHILANTHROPIC
ORGANIZATIONS AND CHARITABLE
ORGANIZATIONS TO LOOK AND MAKE
THEIR OWN ASSESSMENT SINCE THIS
IS A UNIVERSAL PROGRAM.
MAKE THEIR ASSESSMENT OF WHICH
CHILD GIVEN THE DEMOGRAPHICS AND
NEEDS THEY'D WANT TO INVEST MORE
IN -- SO I THINK ALL AROUND IT'S
A BENEFIT AND IT ALLOWS FOR MORE
INDIVIDUALS TO PARTICIPATE.
IN THE IN A PROGRAM THAT
UNFORTUNATELY TOO FEW HAVE BEEN
TAKING ADVANTAGE OF OR BEING
INVOLVED IN.
SO WILL THIS BE ARE MOVING FOR
THE PLANET -- IF IT PASSES --
THEN MOVING FORWARD DIED LAST
SAY UP FOR NEXT YEAR ALONE ANY
ANY TYPE.
OF BEING BORN ARE FROM NEXT YEAR
WOULD BE AUTOMATICALLY.
A REGISTERED TO AND THAT THAT
WILL GIVE.
RUNS -- TO INVEST MORE AND THEN
IS THE SEED MONEY TWENTY FIVE
DOLLARS A WOULD GROW BUT TWENTY
FIVE THOMAS ITSELF IS NOT GOING
TO BE.
SUFFICIENT AT ALL NO MATTER HOW
MUCH IT ROLES -- IS SUFFERING WE
MORE BUT IT IS SUCH AN
ENCOURAGEMENT SO IT IS -- TO TO
ENCOURAGE PARENTS SO SO THAT'S
WHY I AM IN SUPPORT OF THAT BUT
THE HOW WE GONNA -- EXISTING
ONCE OF PARENTS ARE.
RIGHT NOW DO WE HAVE THIS ONE SO.
WITH THE P. -- SSS UP RIGHT THE
ONLY MOVING FOR DONE.
NEW BORN CHILDREN ARE.
WILL BE MANDATE.
YES IT WITH THE AUTHOR'S CONSENT --
I WOULD ASK IF IF THE YOU COULD.
MAYBE -- CONNECT WITH THE VICE
CHAIR AND COME TO HAVE A
DISCUSSION.
OUTSIDE OF COMMITTEE MEETING
OKAY THANK WITH THE BRIEF
ANSWERS YES.
YES.
OR SO AS WE HAVE A MOTION.
BY MISTER LOWE A SECOND BY
DOCTOR WEBER -- MADAM SECRETARY
AT PLEASE IF I MAY CLOSE I WOULD
JUST ALLOW THE STATE TREASURER'S
OFFICE TO TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
A ME.
TO A STATE THAT.
SENTENCE.
HELLO MY AND AND AND AND TO BE
CLEAR TO BE CLEAR TO EVERYONE
HERE IN THE AUDIENCE AND ON THE
COMMITTEE.
I I SAID AT THE OUTSET THAT WE
WERE. TWO WITNESSES TWO MINUTES.
OR FOUR MINUTES ANYWAY YOU
WANTED TO DIVIDE IT AND YOU WERE
AT FOUR MINUTES.
BUT WE WHAT WE WANT TO HEAR FROM
THE SECRETARY ONE JUST IDENTIFY
AND SAFE.
BLAKE JOHNSON HER BEHALF OF
TEACHERS OFFICE WE HAVE MAKE
TAKING PHONE POSITION BEFORE
WORKING CLOSELY WITH ALL HIS
OFFICE IN AFFORDING TEAM
DISCUSSIONS.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
YEAH.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE MEDINA
AYE AYE MEDINA AYE.
CHOI.
CHOI I JONES SAWYER.
DON'T YOUR JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER II.
BLOOM [inaudible]
I GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I WHEN -- WHEN I KILEY?
LEVINE LEVINE I LOW LOW I
PATTERSON.
PATTERSON I SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE WEBER [inaudible]
WEBER I THANK YOU ELEVEN ZERO
YOUR BILL IS OUT WE WILL LEAVE
IT OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM.
TWENTY TWO MS RUBIO [inaudible]
AND WE'LL GO AHEAD AND DO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR WHILE WE HAVE
EVERYONE HERE.
MOVE BY MR LEVINE.
SECOND BY MISTER CHOI.
I'M SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
MEDINA HI MEDINA I CHOI.
CHOI I JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER I'D BLOOM BLOOM I
GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I IRWIN -- WHEN I'D
KILEY LEVINE LEVINE I LOW LOW I
PATTERSON?
PATTERSON I SANTIAGO SANTIAGO
AYE WEBER.
WEBER I ELEVEN ZERO THE CONSENT
ITEM IS APPROVED WE'LL LEAVE IT
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
THIS RUBIO IF YOU'D LIKE.
TO BEGIN THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS -- AND I WANT TO THANK
ASSEMBLY WOMAN COREY ANDREAS FOR
JOINING ME AS AUTHORS OF THIS
IMPORTANT LEGISLATION AND TOLD
ALL THE ADVOCATES FOR CONTINUING
TO FIGHT FRONT ON DOCUMENTED
STUDENTS.
AB SIXTEEN FORTY FIVE IS A BILL
THAT WILL DESIGNATE A DREAM
RESOURCE LIAISON I CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES.
SINCE THE IMPLEMENTATION OF AB
FIVE FORTY THE CALIFORNIA DREAM
ACT AND OTHER MEANINGFUL PIECES
OF LEGISLATION ACCESS AND
AFFORDABILITY TO HIGHER
EDUCATION IS NOW ATTAINABLE FOR
ARE UNDOCUMENTED STUDENT
POPULATION.
IT IS ESTIMATED THAT EACH YEAR
APPROXIMATELY SIXTY FIVE
THOUSAND UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS
GRADUATE FROM HIGH SCHOOL AND
WHILE CALIFORNIA HAS TAKEN THE
LEAD TO ENACT LEGISLATION TO
PROVIDE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
UNDOCUMENTED YOUTH.
WE ONLY SEE 20% OF THE STUDENTS
ATTENDING COLLEGE.
WE MUST AND CAN DO MORE TO HELP
STUDENTS AND THEIR FAMILIES
NAVIGATE THE HIGHER EDUCATION
SYSTEM.
WHERE WE ARE IN DIRE AND
TURBULENT TIMES AS THERE IS NO
END IN SIGHT FOR THE FEDERAL
ADMINISTRATIONS CONSTANT THREAT
TO DR?
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS CENTERS
AND STAFF PLAY A CRITICAL ROLE
AT OUR COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITY
CAMPUSES AS IMMIGRATION POLICIES
RAPIDLY SHIFT AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL.
ESTABLISHING A PERMANENT AND
INSTITUTIONALIZED DREAM RESOURCE
LIAISON I ON CALIFORNIA COLLEGES
AND UNIVERSITIES WE WILL PROVIDE
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS WITH
ADEQUATE EDUCATIONAL SUPPORT.
GUIDANCE OF STATE FUNDED LIKE
JUST LEGAL SERVICES AND ON A
CAMPUS PROTECTION POLICIES.
A DREAM RESOURCE LIAISON WOULD
SATISFY THE CENTER -- COMPONENT
TO WEAR DARK WHERE STUDENTS CAN
EXPRESS EXPERIENCES AND GATHER
ENSURE INVALUABLE INFORMATION
THAT IS ESSENTIAL IN THE
OUTCOMES OF STUDENT SUCCESS.
ARE DREAMERS HAVE MADE
CALIFORNIA BETTER WITH THEIR
COUNTLESS AND RICH RELENTLESS
ADVOCACY EFFORTS THE STUDENTS
LIKE ME CAME TO THE U. KNIGHTED
STATES FOR A BETTER OPPORTUNITY.
AND IT IS OUR DUTY TO CREATE
POLICIES THAT WILL LEAD THEM TO
A SUCCESSFUL FUTURE AND A BETTER
QUALITY OF LIFE.
HERE WITH ME TODAY I HAVE --
COPIER GARCIA A YOUTH ORGANIZER
TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY ON BEHALF
OF THE COALITION FOR HUMANE
IMMIGRATION IMMIGRANT RIGHTS.
WE ALSO HAVE DIANNE NOT A
STUDENT AT SACRAMENTO CITY
COLLEGE THAT WOULD LIKE TO SHARE
HER STORY WITH YOU.
AND LAST BUT NOT LEAST --
CHRISTOPHER SANCHEZ POLICY
ADVOCATE FOR CHIRLA. TO ADD TO
ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
AND AND I JUST WANT TO REMIND
THE WITNESSES WHAT I JUST
FINISHED SAYING THAT IT'S FOUR
MINUTES.
ANYWAY YOU WANT.
TO DIVIDE THE FOUR MINUTE.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS GOT
THE THAT SEE A AND I AM TO YOUTH
ORGANIZER WITH WEISS UP THE HIGH
SCHOOL COMPONENT -- CHEER Là BY
WEISS A PROGRAM WE WORK WITH
OVER ELEVEN HIGH SCHOOLS IN LA
COUNTY WITH THE MAJORITY OF THE
STUDENTS BEING UNDOCUMENTED.
WE PROVIDE IS YOU'D WITH
INFORMATION AND RESOURCES TO GO
TO COLLEGE REGARDLESS OF THEIR
LEGAL STATUS TODAY THE REALITY
IS THAT EVERY DAY WE NEED MORE
AND MORE YOU ACQUIRE BECOMING
LESS THAN COURAGE TO GOAL OR
STAY IN COLLEGE.
BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE THE
GUIDANCE OR SUPPORT OF SOMEONE
WHO IS TRAINED SPECIFICALLY ON
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS ISSUES.
HAVING A DREAMILY A SON A
COMMUNITY COLLEGES OR FOUR YEAR
UNIVERSITIES WHO CAN PROVIDE
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS WITH THE
RESOURCES THAT THEY NEED CAN
MAKE A DIFFERENCE -- WHETHER
THEY STUDENTS DROP OUT A
GRADUATE COLLEGE I KNOW THIS
FIRST HAND BECAUSE I WAS ONCE IN
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS.
MY FAMILY AND I MIGRATED TO THE
US WHEN I WAS ELEVEN YEARS OLD
WE ARRIVE IN LA WHERE I ATTEND
THE ABRAHAM LINCOLN HIGH SCHOOL.
IN MY SENIOR YEAR I HAD TO FACE
THE HARSH REALITY WHEN MY
COLLEGE COUNSELOR TOLD ME THAT
THERE WASN'T ANY HELP FOR ME.
FEELING HOPELESS I DECIDED TO
ATTEND.
A COMMUNITY COLLEGE IN COMMUNITY
COLLEGE I HAD TO FIGURE
EVERYTHING OUT BY MYSELF BECAUSE
THE COUNSELORS DIDN'T KNOW HOW
TO HOLD ME.
DOING RESEARCH ON MY OWN AND
NAVIGATING THE COLLEGE SYSTEMS
ON MY OWN I WAS ABLE TO WE SEE
MY BACHELORS DEGREE WITHIN FIVE
YEARS.
THERE WAS NO BACK UP IN THE
POLITICAL CLASS I MAIN AND
SUPPORT FOR UNDOCUMENTED
STUDENTS WAS MUCH DIFFERENT WHEN
I WAS ATTENDING SCHOOL.
TODAY MY STUDENTS FACE SIMILAR
CHALLENGES AS A DATE THEY THEY
DON'T HAVE DOCTOR AND THEY HAVE
TO BUILD UP THE KOREJE EVERYDAY
TO APPROACH A NEW STAFF. TO
RELIEVE THEIR STATUS AS AB FIVE
FORTY NOT KNOWING HOW THE PERSON
IS GOING TO REACT. FOR THESE
REASONS I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
OF AB SIXTEEN FORTY FIVE THANK
YOU.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE MY
NAME IS DIANA MY OPPONENTS ARE
SHE HER HER IS THE NAME OF THE
DOCUMENTS STUDENTS ARE COMING
CITY COLLEGE.
OUR TO OUR GRADE SCHOOL I
NURTURED THE IDEA THAT I WAS ONE
DAY GOING TO GROW UP AND BECOME
A PROFESSIONAL SOME SORT -- BUT
THE PROBLEM LETTER THE FACT THAT
I HAD ABSOLUTELY NO IDEA WHAT I
WANTED TO BE AND MUCH LESS OF
HOW I WAS GOING TO GET THERE.
NOW THIS IS PROBABLY ONE OF THE
MOST RELATABLE DILEMMAS EVER BUT
IT'S HONESTLY A LOT MORE
DIFFICULT TO FIGURE OUT WHEN
YOU'RE DOCUMENTED FROM LOW
INCOME.
YOU'RE THE FIRST THING YOU FROM
IT'S A COMPLETE JERK A GRADE
SCHOOL EDUCATION AND THE STATE
AND THEN GO TO COLLEGE.
I WAS LUCKY BECAUSE I HAD A TEAM
THE BEST THING ABOUT COLLEGE HAS
BEEN MEETING PEOPLE WHO
STRUGGLED LIKE ME.
BUT HAVE TAUGHT ME TO OVERCOME
THE OBSTACLES.
I WAS VERY LUCKY TO HAVE
GUIDANCE ON CAMPUS BY PHIL
JIMERSON ALLIES WHO ARE ALSO
VERY MUCH SO PROFESSIONALS --
BEING ABLE TO GO TO SCHOOL
KNOWING I HAVE A DECIMATED YOUR
ADVOCATE ON CAMPUS HAS MADE ME
FEEL WELCOME.
THROUGH THEM I HAVE INVOLVED
MYSELF ON AND OFF CAMPUS I HAVE
BEEN PART OF SEVERAL
ORGANIZATIONS THAT HELP ME
DEVELOP POSITIVE GOAL SETTING
MENTALITY AND TELL ME HOW TO
CREATE A SAFE SPACE FOR OTHERS.
BY CREATED ONE FOR ME.
I'D LEARN TO TAKE CARE OF MY
MENTAL HEALTH AND I NEVER
THOUGHT HOW MUCH OF AN IMPACT
THAT WOULD ACTUALLY MAKE.
A THROUGH MY CAMPUS ADVOCATES I
RECEIVE MANY RESOURCES THAT ARE
EXCLUSIVELY FOR STUDENTS LIKE ME
WHETHER IT'S SCHOLARSHIP
OPPORTUNITY THAT GOVERNOR
WORKSHOPS POLITICAL UPDATES OR
SIMPLY SOMEONE TO RELATE.
TO THIS IS WHY I AM HERE TODAY I
URGE YOU TO TAKE ACTION IN
SUPPORT AB SIXTEEN FORTY FIVE
LET'S MAKE IT'S THAT OUR SCHOOLS
PRO -- DO PROVIDE US WITH THE
TOOLS TO REACH OUR GOALS BECAUSE
EVERYONE TO SEARCH OUT SOMEONE
IN THE CORNER WHO OFFICE IN THAT
CITY SPACE.
ACROSS THE NATION WE HAVE
DREAMERS THAT SIMPLY WANT TO
SUCCEED AND CONTRIBUTE TO MAKE
THIS COUNTRY A BETTER PLACE I AM
FORTUNATE TO BE FROM CALIFORNIA
ONE OF THE MOST PROGRESSIVE
ENDEAVOR STATES.
WE HAVE BECOME THE STATE THAT
SETS THE EXAMPLE FOR THE REST SO
LET'S KEEP DOING THAT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I'M GOING TO ASK --
THAT OTHERS JUST GIVE THEIR NAME
THE ORGANIZATION THEIR CRAFT
MISS CHAIR MEMBERS BECAUSE FOR
SIGNS OF THE TRUTH OF THE
COALITION FOR HUMANE IMMIGRANT
RIGHTS IN AUGUST ALSO A PRISONER
YOUTH ORGANIZATION THE
CONFERENCE ROOM RIGHT NETWORK.
PRADA SPONSOR THIS LEGISLATION
HERE TO ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
BRIAN REAVIS ON BEHALF OF THE
EDUCATION TRUST WESTON SUPPORT.
CHAIR MEDINA AND MEMBERS J.
GRAHAM THERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY
AS WELL AS THE CALIFORNIA
UNDOCUMENTED HIGHER EDUCATION
COALITION AND SEVERAL OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS SUPPORTING THIS
LEGISLATION AND THIS CHANGE BUT
NOT LISTED IN THE ANALYSIS.
STEPHANIE GOLDEN WITH THE
FACULTY ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES IN
SUPPORT.
ANDREY RIVERA WHAT THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER IN SUPPORT.
REBEKAH GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
CAME IN CAMP WITH WEIGHT VICE
LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS LISTEN
SENATE FOR CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES IN SUPPORT.
HI YOU'VE YOU MENDOZA WITH
DOUBLE VALLEY COLLEGE IN SUPPORT.
JIMMY JOHNSON REGION OFFICE
DIRECTOR OF REGION THREE FOR THE
SIGNIFICANT SENATE FOR
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES IN
SUPPORT.
PHOEBE FELL ON BEHALF OF REGION
FOR AS REGIONAL AFFAIRS DIRECTOR --
UNDERNEATH THE CALIFORNIA CAN
COLLEGES FOR SUPPORT.
MICHELLE HALL REPRESENTING DE
ANZA COLLEGE STRONGLY SUPPORT.
BUT MISTER CHAIRMAN MANNY VS OF
REPRESENTS SOUNDS A EVERGREEN
COMMUNICATOR SISTER VERY MUCH IN
SUPPORT AND HOPEFULLY OTHER
THIRD TIME'S A CHARM.
A GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
ANYTHING ELSE OTHER CENTRAL
VALLEY ORGANIZER FOR CHIRLA HERE
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU -- I
RISOTTO FROM UC DAVIS IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
I AM TO TWO FROM BY SALIENT
STRONG SUPPORT.
WHICH HE'D LE AND IT'S IT WILL
TO DO ON THIS.
THANK YOU.
HELLO EVERYONE MY NAME DRAWS
WONDER BECAUSE MINE I'M HERE --
WHICH CAROLINE HERE AND SUPPORT.
DONNA STERN A CENTRAL VALLEY
ORGANIZER WITH THE COALITION FOR
HUMANE IMMIGRANT RIGHTS AND
STRONG SUPPORT.
IT IS A LOPEZ FROM PORTABLE
CALIFORNIA IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY
ON WITH CHIRLA COLLISION
FRIEDMAN WE'RE IMMIGRANT RIGHTS
INDIAN SUPPORT.
CATHERINE MISSUS ISRAEL'S I'M
FROM LOS ANGELES IN THE BACK
CURRENT AREAS AND TO BE SOCIAL
WORKERS PARK IS PART OF THIS
BILL.
ON HELLO MY NAME IS WRONG RC ON
I'M WITH -- ON WAS CHIRLA FROM
LICENSE BUT I'LL AND I'M ALL FOR
YOUR SUPPORT.
RIGHT NOW WITH THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS WE
SUPPORTED SIMILAR BILLS IN THE
PAST WERE STRUCK SUPPORT THANK.
MARIO GUERRERO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
OF ALSO SUPPORTED SIMILAR
EFFORTS IN IN THE PAST -- WE
HAVE A RECORD SUPPORT HOPE TO
SUPPORT THE BILL AS IT MOVES
FORWARD.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
ANY TWEETERS.
SEEING NONE.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE [inaudible]
SEEING NONE [inaudible]
IF.
IF YOU'D LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU FOR LISTENING TO THEIR
STORIES IT'S REALLY CRITICAL --
FOR FOR US TO DO SOMETHING TO
HELP THE THIS SIZE STUDENT
POPULATION AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE WITH THE BILL.
CHECK.
THE BY MISTER LOWE SECOND BY
MISTER JONES SAWYER.
I THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD -- MUCH NEEDED --
AND AM I CORRECT IN IN THAT THIS
IS A PRIORITY BILL FOR THE THAN
A CLOCK IN THE CLOCK IS YES IT
IS.
SO WE HAD OF THE MOTION BY.
MISTER LOS SECOND BY AND MISTER
JONES SAWYER THAT I'M SECRETARY
OF YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE MEDINA.
MEDINA I CHOI.
CHOI NOT VOTING JONES SAWYER HI
JONES SAWYER AYE BLOOM.
BLOOM I GABRIEL.
APRIL I IRWIN -- WHEN I KILEY?
LEVINE LEVINE I LOW.
LOW I PATTERSON SANTIAGO
[inaudible]
WEBER [inaudible]
UBER II. EIGHT ZERO THAT BILL IS
OUT WE WILL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM [inaudible]
TWENTY ONE MISTER REAVIS
[inaudible]
WHAT?
WELCOME MISTER REAVIS MISTER
CHAIRMAN THIS BILL ALSO ENJOYS
SUPPORT SUPPORT.
IT'S GREAT TO BE HERE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN.
I COLLEAGUES SUBCOMMITTEE STAFF
THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK -- ON
THE ANALYSIS.
AND I'M HERE THIS AFTERNOON TO
VISIT AB SIXTEEN TWENTY THREE A
WHICH IS LEGISLATION SEEKING TO
ESTABLISH THE GOLDEN.
STATE TEACHER GRANT PROGRAM --
IN THE OBVIOUSLY SHOULD BE NO
SURPRISE TO ANY MEMBER OF THIS
COMMITTEE.
OR IN THIS LEGISLATURE THAT THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT ARE HAVING A
VERY DIFFICULT TIME RECRUITING
AND RETAINING.
QUALIFIED CREDENTIALED TEACHERS.
AND THE PROBLEM ONLY SEEMS TO BE
GETTING WORSE -- IN OUR SCHOOLS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
A RECENT COMPREHENSIVE SURVEY OF
TWO HUNDRED ELEVEN SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
CALIFORNIA REVEALED THAT NEARLY
THREE QUARTERS.
OF THE SCHOOLS COULD NOT FIND OF
THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS COULD NOT
FIND ENOUGH QUALIFIED TEACHERS
TO FILL THE CLASSROOMS.
IN FACT THE SUPPLY OF NEW
TEACHERS IS CURRENTLY HOVERING
AT A TWELVE YEAR LOW.
AB.
TWELVE SIXTY THREE I'M SORRY.
AB SIXTEEN TWENTY THREE CREATE A
SERVICE SCHOLARSHIP PROGRAM --
BY PROVIDING A ONE TIME GRANT OF
TWENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS TO
STUDENTS AND TEACHER PREPARATION
PROGRAMS.
IN EXCHANGE FOR THEIR COMMITMENT
TO TEACH FOR FOUR YEARS IN A
HIGH NEED SUBJECT AREA --
ACCORDING TO THIS BILL AND BASED
ON THE DATA -- THE HIGH NEED
SUBJECT AREAS INCLUDE SPECIAL
EDUCATION LAST DAM WHICH IS
SCIENCE TECHNOLOGY ENGINEERING
AND MATH.
AND BILINGUAL EDUCATION -- AND
SO CLEARLY MORE NEEDS TO BE DONE
TO END THAT CALIFORNIA'S TEACHER
SHORTAGE.
BUT YOU KNOW AB TWELVE OR
SIXTEEN TWENTY THREE A WON'T
ENTIRELY SOLVE OUR STATES.
THE SHORTAGE PROBLEM -- BUT WILL
GO A LONG WAY TO HELP CREATE THE
INCENTIVES NEEDED TO INCREASE
THE PIPELINE OF QUALIFIED
TEACHERS.
IN THESE SUBJECT SHORTAGE AREAS --
AND SO WITH THAT THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR.
AND MY COLLEAGUES ON THIS
COMMITTEE AND I'M JOINED HERE BY
SOME OF OUR BILL SPONSORS AND
ONE OF THEM LAST NAME IS REVERSE
AND I'VE NEVER.
BEEN A BEEN IN A PLACE TO AYE I
DON'T KNOW ANY OTHER BE THIS IS
MY ENTIRE LIFE AND NOW I SERVE
WITH ONE OF THE LEGISLATURE THIS
ONE HERE WITH ME AT THE HERE ARE
ON THE TABLE.
OR AT THIS TABLE INSTALL ALLOW
THEM TO INTRODUCE THEMSELVES.
THANK YOU MISTER THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
BRIAN REAVIS ON BEHALF OF THE
EDUCATION TRUST WEST COAST
SPONSORS OF THE MEASURE.
OF MISTER REAVIS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
REAVIS HIT ALL THE HIGH POINTS
OUT JUST REITERATE -- THIS IS AN
EQUITY ISSUE LOW INCOME STUDENTS
AND STUDENTS OF COLOR.
ARE EXPERIENCING THE WORST
AFFECTS THE TEACHER SHORTAGE IN
OUR ENGLISH LEARNERS ARE HAVING
TO FOREGO THE BENEFITS OF A WELL
IMPLEMENTED BILINGUAL PROGRAM.
WE SEE THIS IS ADDRESSING THOSE
THAT THOSE NEEDS IN THOSE
PROBLEMS AND URGE YOUR AYE VOTE.
GOOD AFTERNOON RIGHT ALMOST TARA
PUBLIC ADVOCATES NEW CO SPONSORS
OF THE MEASURE IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
HELLO SERRA LOW AS WITH EACH
PLUS IN SUPPORT.
HI MEMBERS NOT A REVISED BRIAN
HA WITH PRETTY FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS WERE AS STRONG SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON -- KEVIN TOMER
WITH THE COMPTON UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN STRONG SUPPORT AS
WELL THANK YOU.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
ANY TWEENER.
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE.
DOCTOR WEBER.
YES I I APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING
THIS FORWARD AND OBVIOUSLY
THERE'S A TREMENDOUS NEED FOR US.
TO LOOK AT HOW WE'RE GOING TO
RECRUIT AND HOW WE'RE GOING TO
SUPPORT -- TEACHERS COMING INTO
THE STATE.
WHAT I'D LIKE FOR US TO DO AS A
COMMITTEE IS LOOK AT ALL OF
THESE PROGRAMS WE KEEP PASSING?
OF CONCERNING SUPPORTING
TEACHERS IN GRANTS HAVING HEARD
THREE TODAY. TWO OR THREE AND
WE'VE HEARD SOME OTHERS IT WOULD
BE NICE TO HAVE A COMPREHENSIVE
PROGRAM RUN BY THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. TO SUPPORT TEACHERS
I MEAN IT BECAUSE IT'S AFFECT
THE WAY THAT IS NOW IT'S ONE
HERE ONE HERE ONE HERE.
AND STUDENTS MAY EVEN BE MORE
CONFUSES SO WHERE DO I GO.
RATHER THAN LOOKING AT A
COORDINATED EFFORT AND MAYBE WE
WANT TO LOOK AT THAT AS THE
HIGHER IT COMMITTEE A
COORDINATED EFFORT TO TALK ABOUT
IT BECAUSE I THINK WE'VE HEARD A
COUPLE TODAY.
NONE OF THEM WERE OPPOSED TO BUT
YOUGET SO MANY THEN IS TO PICK
AND CHOOSE AND YOU'RE NOT SURE
IF WHAT WE'RE GETTING REALLY
ADDRESSES THE ISSUES THAT WE
WANT TO DRESS OR DO CALL THE
RECRUITMENT THAT WE WANT TO A
GROUP.
WE SHOULD HAVE A STANDARD
PROGRAM IN THE STATE AT SOME
POINT THAT MEET CERTAIN KINDS OF
NEEDS BUT REALLY AS YOUNG PEOPLE
CAN GO TO KNOW THAT THIS IS WHAT
OUR STATE DOES TO SUPPORT
TEACHING SO.
THAT'S JUST MY SUGGESTION AS WE
GO FORWARD BECAUSE I KNOW THAT
SOME OTHERS THAT ARE GONNA BE
COMING ALONG.
WE'VE HEARD THESE BEFORE AND AND
IN THE AT THE END OF THE DAY I'M
NOT EVEN SURE WHICH ONES GET
SIGNED WHICH ONES DON'T GET
SIGNED WHICH WON THE GOVERNOR
SUPPORTS AND DOESN'T SUPPORT.
SOMEONE SUGGEST THAT THOSE OF US
WHO BELIEVE IN THERE SO THOSE
WHO WORK TOGETHER GET TOGETHER
AND BASICALLY GIVE US A
COORDINATED COMPREHENSIVE
PROGRAM THE HELP WAS SUPPORT.
TEACHERS COMING IN THE
PROFESSION AND AND THAT WAY WILL
KNOW WHAT WE'RE DOING AND KNOW
WHAT THE NOT WE'RE BEING
AFFECTED.
THANK YOU.
SHE NO OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE --
MISTER REAVIS IF YOU'D LIKE TO
CLOSE SURE THE I HAVE NO THE
CLOSING JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE I DO APPRECIATE
THE COMMENTS.
BY SOME THE WOMAN -- WEBER YOU
KNOW I COULD I COMPLETELY AGREE
I I I THINK THAT YOU KNOW WE'VE
WE'VE HAD CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE REGARDING --
THIS PROPOSAL THAT WE'VE
SUBMITTED THE BUDGET REQUEST BY
THING A COMPREHENSIVE -- YOU
KNOW APPROACH IS CERTAINLY WHAT
IS NEEDED AND SO THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT -- I THINK MAKES
LAW SETS BUT WITH THAT THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU -- AND I
THINK WE'VE HAD DOCTOR WEBER
JUST ONE BILL TODAY.
ON ON THE SUBJECT MATTER THIS IS
THE SECOND -- ONE BUT WITH THAT
I I VERY MUCH.
APPRECIATE THE BILL I WAS A
BILINGUAL TEACHER MYSELF -- SO I
I KNOW THE SHORTAGE OF BILINGUAL
TEACHERS THE SHORTAGE OF SPECIAL
EDUCATION TEACHERS THE THE
SHORTAGE OF A STEP TEACHERS.
SO I THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRING
IT FORWARD BUT AND ECHOING
DOCTOR WEBER'S COMMENTS -- ASK
THE AUTHOR TO ESPECIALLY LOOK AT
THE ANALYSIS WHICH I BELIEVE
WE'RE ON PAGE.
THREE OF THE ANALYSIS YEAH ON
PAGE THREE OF THE ANALYSIS
MAKING SURE THAT YOU SEE HOW IT
FITS IN WITH EXISTING PROGRAMS.
YEAH RIGHT AND YOU KNOW AND AND
SO WHAT WE'RE COMMITTED TO WORK --
YOU KNOW WITH ALL THE AGENCIES
IN THE DEPARTMENT THAT WERE
LISTED OUT AND THE ANALYSIS AND
CERTAINLY I KNOW ONE OF THEM WAS --
REFERENCE THE GOVERNOR'S
TEACHING FELLOWSHIPS -- PROGRAM --
WHICH YOU KNOW THIS BILL
PARTICULAR IT DIFFERS IN -- YOU
KNOW WITH THE THE GOALS THAT
WERE SET IN AND THAT PROGRAM IN
PARTICULAR IS THAT WAS I BELIEVE.
A SCHOLARSHIP -- EFFORT RELATED
TO YOU KNOW MAKE SURE WE GET
TEACHERS IN LOW PERFORMING
SCHOOLS WHERE THIS IS REALLY
MUCH DIFFERENT IN THE SENSE THAT
OUR PRIORITY IS -- IN THE TRYING
TO PREPARE CANDIDATES IN SUBJECT
AREAS THAT ARE NEEDED THROUGHOUT
YOU KNOW THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
ALL SCHOOL DISTRICT AND ALL
SCHOOLS -- BUT WE'RE CERTAINLY
HAPPY TO WORK WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S YOU KNOW OUR GOALS
ARE -- NOW.
THAT THE CONSISTENT [inaudible]
AND NOTE.
MOTION WAS BY MISTER LOW SECOND
BY MISTER GABRIEL.
AND SECRETARY PLEASE CALL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE.
MEDINA AYE MEDINA AYE CHOI.
CHOI I JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER I'D BLOOM.
BLOOM I GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I IRWIN -- WHEN I KILEY?
LEVINE LEVINE I LOW.
LOW I PATTERSON PATTERSON I
SANTIAGO [inaudible]
WEBER [inaudible]
WEBER I GEN ZERO THAT BILL IS
OUT WE WILL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS.
AND NEXT ITEM.
SIXTEEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER SMITH
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
WHICH ALSO ENJOYS SUPPORT
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
COLLEAGUES FOR YOUR EARLY AN
AMBITIOUS SUPPORT SO I WILL TRY.
TO GET THROUGH THIS AND AND GIVE
YOU THE FRAME AND WE WE WILL
MOVE ON AS YOU'RE APPROACHING
YOUR SEVENTH INNING STRETCH HERE.
CALIFORNIA IS POISED TO
EXPERIENCE DRAMATIC GROWTH IN
THE NEED FOR NURSES THE NATIONAL
CENTER FOR HEALTH WORKFORCE
ANALYSIS ESTIMATES THAT
CALIFORNIA COULD BE SHORT BY
FORTY FIVE THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED
REGISTERED NURSES BY.
TWENTY THIRTY THIS SHORTAGE
COULD BE POINTED TO A RANGE OF
ISSUES INCLUDING THE AGING BABY
BOOMER POPULATION THE INCREASE
OF CHRONIC HEALTH ISSUES LIKE
OBESITY AND DIABETES AND A
GROWING EMPHASIS ON PREVENTIVE
CARE.
AT THE SAME TIME SCHOOLS ARE
STRUGGLING TO ACCOMMODATE THE
NUMBERS OF STUDENTS SEEKING
SPOTS AN IMPACTED NURSING
PROGRAMS.
PART OF THE REASON FOR THIS
IMPACTION HAS BEEN THE
DIFFICULTY IN RECRUITING AND
RETAINING NURSING FACULTY.
UNLIKE OTHER PROGRAMS NURSING
REQUIRES EXTENSIVE CLINICAL
COMPONENTS ON TOP OF THE TIME IN
THE CLASSROOM.
CLINICAL EDUCATION REQUIRES THAT
STUDENTS PERFORM TWELVE HOUR
SHIFTS ONE TO TWO DAYS PER WEEK.
CLINICAL ROTATIONS MAY EXTEND
FROM SIX TO EIGHTEEN WEEKS
DEPENDING ON THE COURSE AND
AVAILABILITY OF CLINICAL SITES.
HOSPITAL CLINICAL SITES REQUIRE
FOUR TO SIX OUR ORIENTATIONS FOR
ANYONE PROVIDING PATIENT CARE
INCLUDING BOTH NORTH NURSING
STUDENTS AND THEIR FACULTY.
DUE TO THE PRACTICAL ELEMENTS OF
NURSING EDUCATION NURSING
INSTRUCTORS MUST MEET A UNIQUE
SET OF QUALIFICATIONS FROM OTHER
COMMUNITY COLLEGE FACULTY.
MANY CLINICAL NURSING
INSTRUCTORS CONTINUE TO SERVE AS
PRACTICING LICENSE NURSES WHILE
TEACHING LEADING TO A LARGE
NUMBER OF PART TIME NURSING
FACULTY.
UNDER EXISTING LAW COURSE LOADS
FOR PART TIME COMMUNITY COLLEGE
AND ADULT EDUCATION FACULTY ARE
CAPPED AT 67% OF THE HOURS PER
WEEK OF A FULL TIME COURSE LOAD.
APPROXIMATELY TWO COURSES.
THIS CAP RESULTS AN INSTRUCTOR
CHANGES IN THE MIDDLE OF
ROTATIONS INTERRUPTING THE
STUDENTS LEARNING PROCESS AND
INTERRUPTING CARE AT CLINICAL
SITES. FOR STUDENTS THE CHANGE
OF INSTRUCTORS MID ROTATION CAN
BE DISRUPTIVE TO THE LEARNING
PROCESS STUDENT EVALUATIONS MAY
ALSO NOT BE AS COMPREHENSIVE NEW
INSTRUCTORS MAY NOT BE FAMILIAR
ENOUGH WITH A STUDENT'S
PERFORMANCE TO EFFECTIVELY
DETERMINE PROGRESSION AND SKILL
DEVELOPMENT.
STUDENTS MAY BE ALLOWED MAY NOT
BE ALLOWED TO ADVANCE WHEN
THEY'RE NOT PREPARED.
THE MID ROTATION TURNOVER IS
ALSO DISRUPTIVE FOR CLINICAL
SITES.
EACH TIME A NEW INSTRUCTORS
BROUGHT INTO A HOSPITAL THE
HOSPITAL MUST PROVIDE TO THE
INSTRUCTOR THE REQUISITE FOUR TO
SIX HOUR ORIENTATION STACKING
ONTO ALREADY BUSY SCHEDULES FOR
ABOUT THE HOSPITAL AN INSTRUCTOR.
CLINICAL SITES TYPICALLY HAVE TO
HOST STUDENTS FROM SEVERAL
SCHOOLS THE CUMULATIVE EFFECT OF
INSTRUCTORS FROM EACH SCHOOL FOR
MULTIPLE COURSES TURNING OVER IN
THE MIDDLE OF EACH ROTATION CAN
SEVERELY INTERRUPT CLINICAL
OPERATIONS.
FACULTY TURNOVER CAN ALSO A ROAD
THE CLINICAL SITES CONFIDENCE IN
AN EDUCATION INSTITUTION AND
INSTRUCTORS.
THE MID ROTATION TURNOVER IS
ALSO DESTRUCTIVE FOR THE
CLINICAL SITE.
EACH TIME A NEW INSTRUCTORS
BROUGHT INTO A HOSPITAL THE
HOSPITAL MUST PROVIDE THE
INSTRUCTOR THE REQUISITE FORTY
SIX OUR ORIENTATION.
AND THEY'RE ALREADY STOCKING ON
TO THEIR BUSY HOSPITAL A
ADMINISTRATIVE DUTIES.
CLINICAL SITES TYPICALLY HAVE
HOUSE STUDENTS FROM SEVERAL
SCHOOLS.
THE CUMULATIVE EFFECT OF
INSTRUCTORS FROM EACH SCHOOL FOR
MULTIPLE COURSES TURNING OVER IN
THE MIDDLE OF EACH ROTATION CAN
SEVERELY IMPACT OPERATIONS.
AB TEN FIFTY ONE WOULD RE
ESTABLISH AN EXEMPTION INITIALLY
PUT IN STATUTE IN TWO THOUSAND
SIX FOR PART TIME COMMUNITY
COLLEGE NURSING FACULTY. TO
EXCEED THE PART TIME FACULTY
COURSE LOAD CAP ALLOWING FOR
MORE CONTINUITY IN CLINICAL
NURSING EDUCATION.
THE EXEMPTION WOULD PERMIT FULL
TIME CLINICAL NURSING FACULTY OR
PART TIME CLINICAL NURSING
FACULTY TO BE EMPLOYED BY ANY
ONE COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT
FOR UP TO FOUR SEMESTERS OR SIX
QUARTERS.
THE REESTABLISHMENT OF THE
EXEMPTION WOULD ALLOW COMMUNITY
COLLEGES ACROSS THE STATE TO
SERVE AT LEAST THREE HUNDRED
FIFTY ONE ADDITIONAL STUDENTS
PER YEAR IN NURSING PROGRAMS AND
WOULD ENCOURAGE THE HIRING
PRACTISE AND PRACTICING.
A LICENSE NURSES WHO WILL BRING
VALUABLE AND RELEVANT REAL WORLD
EXPERIENCE INTO THE EDUCATIONAL
ENVIRONMENT.
I HAVE WITH ME A FEW WITNESSES
TODAY TO TESTIFY TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF TEN FIFTY ONE AND
REMEMBER WE WERE UP. TO PASS.
JUSTIN SELLECK ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
BOARD OF GOVERNORS THE SPONSOR
OF AB.
TEN FIFTY ONE AND IN THE
INTEREST OF TIME ALL ALLOW OUR
WITNESSES TO TAKE THE A LOT OF
TIME WE HAVE -- DOCTOR SANDRA
MELTON FROM THE SCHOOL OF
NURSING AT VENTURA COLLEGE AND
SHERRIN GOLDFARB FOR THE SOVIET
DEAN OF HEALTH AT LOS MADONNA'S
COLLEGE.
THANK YOU -- GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS OF 50% OR FIVE FULL TIME
NURSING FACULTY POSITIONS ARE
CURRENTLY OPEN AT VENTURA
COLLEGE.
IN MY TEN YEARS AS THE PROGRAM
DIRECTOR THERE I'VE NEVER HAD A
FULL COMPLEMENT OF FULL TIME
FACULTY.
AND HAVE DONE A HIRING COMMITTEE
EVERY SEMESTER FOR TWENTY
SEMESTERS WITH MANY COMMITTEES
RESULTING IN A FAILED SEARCH OR
A SUCCESSFUL APPLICANT OFFERED
THE POSITION.
ONLY TO TURN IT DOWN TO TWO VERY
LOW SALARY OFFERED.
THIS SEMESTER I WAS FORCED TO
REDUCE MY ADMISSIONS BY 20%. FOR
THE GENERIC ASSOCIATE DEGREE
NURSING PROGRAM AND A 100% FOR
THE ADVANCED PLACEMENT LV AND TO
OUR AN OPTION BECAUSE OF LACK OF
FACULTY.
THE ABILITY TO UTILIZE PART TIME
FACULTY AS TEMPORARY FULL TIME
FACULTY WOULD HAVE SAVED THESE
SPOTS WITH MINIMAL COST TO THE
COLLEGE COMPARED TO HIRING AN
ADDITIONAL TENURE TRACK FACULTY.
THE COLLEGES ONLY EXPENSE WOULD
BE FULL TIME BENEFITS FOR THE
PART TIME FACULTY BUT THOSE
WOULD BE INCURRED FOR ONLY ONE
TO FOUR SEMESTERS RATHER THAN
OVER THE CAREER SPAN OF THE
TENURE TRACK FACULTY.
MOREOVER THE COLLEGE WOULD SAY
THE EXPENSIVE RECRUITMENT COST
OF ADVERTISING FOR HIRING AN
ORIENTING NEW FACULTY.
CONTINUED REDUCTIONS IN
ADMISSIONS WILL HAVE DISASTROUS
RAMIFICATIONS FOR HOSPITALS AND
CLINICAL AGENCIES THAT RELY ON
NEW NURSES FROM COMMUNITY
COLLEGE PROGRAMS.
MOREOVER IT WILL NEGATIVELY
AFFECT STUDENTS LIVES STUDENTS
WHO PARTICIPATE IN THE INTER
COLLEGE NURSING PROGRAM BURSTS
THAT BOOST THEIR EARNINGS BY AN
AMAZING FOUR HUNDRED AND 12%.
A 100% OF STUDENTS IN THIS
PROGRAM GET A JOB IN THEIR FIELD
OF STUDY AND 86% OF STUDENTS
ATTAIN.
THE REGIONAL LIVING WAGE PLEASE
SUPPORT THIS BILL SO THAT WE MAY
CONTINUE TO ADMIT AND EDUCATE
NURSES TO MEET.
THE HEALTH WORKFORCE NEEDS OF
INTER COUNTY AND THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
HI MY NAME IS SHARON GOLDFARB
ASSOCIATE DEAN OF NURSING AT
LESS MADONNA'S COLLEGE I'M
PRESIDENT ELECT OF CALIFORNIA
ORGANIZATION OF ASSOCIATE DEGREE
NURSES.
AND ON THE REGIONAL BOARD OF THE
NATIONAL ORGANIZATION OF A SEIZE
ASSOCIATE DEGREE NURSES I COULD
NOT SAY IT BETTER THAN MY MY
COLLEAGUES CENTER MOUNTAINS SO
I'M NOT GOING TO GO INTO THE
DETAILS IT'S THE SAME THING FOR
US.
BUT IF YOU WOULD JUST IMAGINE IF
YOU WERE HAVING A DINNER PARTY
AND YOU HAVE TO GET UP WHEN YOU
WERE 67% OF THE WAY.
FULL OF YOUR DINNER AND ALL OF A
SUDDEN YOU HAD TO SET THE TABLE
AGAIN FOR SOMEONE TO IT'S THAT
DESTRUCTIVE TO US TO OUR
STUDENTS TO OUR HOSPITAL
PARTNERS TO THE FACULTY HAVE TO
GOING ON POOR PEOPLE SO I
STRONGLY ENCOURAGE YOU. TO
SUPPORT THIS.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
IT SAY YOUR NAME IN THE
ORGANIZATION YOU REPRESENT.
HELLO SORRY I AM WENDY PEARL ONE
TOO BUT I'M HERE IN SUPPORT I AM
THE LEDGE CHAIR OF THE FACULTY
ASSOCIATION OF THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ANY TWO WINNERS.
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE OF MISS BETTY READ
LIKE TO CLOSE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND COLLEAGUES AND MY OWN
MOM WAS A REGISTERED NURSE
TRAINED AT A CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE -- AND SHE
LOVED AND ENJOYED HER CAREER AND
EVEN SHE AT THE END OF OF HER
TIME AND IN HER RETIREMENT COULD
FORESEE THIS SHORTAGE LOOMING
I'M AS A TRIBUTE TO HER I'D
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT TODAY
BUT REALLY THIS IS THE RIGHT
THING FOR US TO DO. TO ALLOW OUR
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO
CONTINUE TO THRIVE -- AS
TRAINERS OF OUR REST REGISTERED
NURSING LICENSE VOCATIONAL
NURSES SO I WOULD APPRECIATE AND
I ABOUT.
THANK YOU.
WELL WE HAVE A MOTION.
THE MOTION BY MISTER LOWE SECOND
BY MISTER LEVINE -- MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE CHILE.
CHOI I JONES SAWYER [inaudible]
BLOOM.
BLOOM I GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I IRWIN -- WHEN I KILEY
LEVINE?
LEVINE I LOW.
LOW I PATTERSON PATTERSON I
SANTIAGO WEBER [inaudible]
WEBER I'D. NINE ZERO THE BILL IS
OUT WE WILL LEAVE IT OPEN FRANK
PAYMENT OF THEM.
THANK YOU.
A NEXT FILE ITEM FOURTEEN MR
TROOP.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
COLLEAGUES PROJECT YOUR
CONSIDERATION OF AB NINE FORTY
THREE THIS IS A COMMITTEE THAT
IS VERY FAMILIAR WITH THE
AFFORDABILITY CRISIS THAT IS
FACING OUR HIGHER EDUCATION
STUDENTS.
CRITICALLY OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS WHO ARE STRUGGLING TO
PAY NOT JUST THE COST OF TUITION
BUT THE COST OF HOUSING.
BOOKS TRANSPORTATION AND OTHERS
JUST LAST MONTH THERE'S A SURVEY.
THANK YOU I WILL KEEP IT VERY
BRIEF -- THIS IS A BILL THAT'S
FOCUSED ON EMERGENCY AID SHORT
TERM HELP TO HELP STUDENTS
ENROLLED IN SCHOOL A RECENT
REVIEW OF ONE EMERGENCY AID
PROGRAM FOUND THAT 90% OF
STUDENTS RECEIVED.
EIGHT FINISH THEIR TERM 88% AND
ROLLED IN THE NEXT SEMESTER THIS
BILL WOULD ALLOW CAMPUS IS TO
USE UP TO TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS OF EXISTING FUNDING. TO
FUND SMALL EMERGENCY GRANTS TO
STUDENTS AND FINANCIAL BURDEN
SEES RED RISK OF OTHERWISE
DROPPING OUT.
WITH A NUMBER OF WITNESSES TODAY
AND I WILL TURN OVER TO THEM.
REMINDER TWO MINUTES EACH FOUR
MINUTES TOTAL.
THIS CHAIR MEMBERS BRIAN HOW THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS WERE PROUD SPONSORS OF
THIS VERY IMPORTANT LEGISLATION
OF MONEY YOU OF MY TIME TO THE
AMERICANA WHO'S MY PRESIDENT
SAID LOS RIOS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I CHAMBER
MEDINA AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
MY NAME IS DEAN WERE COMING A
PROFESSOR AT AMERICAN RIVER
COLLEGE AND PRESIDENT OF THE
FACT THE UNION THE LOS RIOS
COLLEGE FEDERATION OF TEACHERS.
I'M HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
NINE FORTY THREE THAT WILL HELP
SINCE WITH EMERGENCY AID.
AND FUNDING FOR HOME SIT IN
SECURITY AND FOOD INSECURITY.
A RECENT SURVEY THAT HAS BEEN
TALKED ABOUT SHOW THAT 50% OF
OUR STUDENTS.
HAVE FACE EITHER FOOD INSECURITY
OUR HOUSING AND SECURITY
PROBLEMS.
THAT'S THAT INCLUDES CHRIS THAT
REPRESENTS FORTY THOUSAND
STUDENTS. FORTY THOUSAND SINCE
IN THE SYSTEM AS A WHOLE TWO
POINT ONE MILLION STUDENTS THAT
MEANS OVER ONE MILLION STUDENTS
ARE FACING.
HOME IN SECURITY AND FOOD
INSECURITY ISSUES.
THIS IS AN ENORMOUS PROBLEM AND
THE STATE WE'RE WE'RE SUPPOSED
TO BE THE FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY
IN THE WORLD.
THIS IS UNACCEPTABLE IT JUST
ISN'T RIGHT.
THE PROBLEM IS ENORMOUS HOME
INCLUDING SECURITY BERRIES ARE
MAJOR REASONS WHY SO MANY
PERSONS DROP OUT OF COLLEGE
UNABLE TO REACH THEIR FULL
POTENTIAL STUDENTS.
AND IN MANY CASES LOSE ONE OF
THEIR MAJOR PATHWAYS TO MOVE OUT
OF POVERTY.
LET ME JUST TELL YOU ABOUT IRWIN
ROBINSON ONE OF OUR STUDENTS AND
AMERICAN COLLEGE SHE ATTENDED
AMERICAN RECALLS FROM.
NINETEEN EIGHTY TO NINETEEN
NINETY FOUR IT TOOK HER FOURTEEN
YEARS TOGETHER A A DEGREE.
BUT SHE WENT ON TO SACRAMENTO
STATE UNIVERSITY.
GARTER BATCHES DEGREE IN CHILD
DEVELOPMENT.
AND ALSO HER MASTER'S DEGREE IN
SCHOOL COUNSELING.
AND I HAVE TO TELL YOU WHEN I
WHEN I WHEN I MET HER SHE
EXPRESSED TO ME.
THAT SHE IS SO GRATEFUL THAT
AMERICAN RIVER COLLEGE GAVE HER
THE OPPORTUNITY AND TIME TO BE
SUCCESSFUL IN HER EDUCATION AND
HER LIFE.
IS BROUGHT A BRIGHTER FUTURE
PURCELL.
BUT ALL SER CHILDREN AND NOW HER
GRANDCHILDREN.
IT BROUGHT A NEW PERSPECTIVE NEW
HORIZONS AND A LIFE SHE NEVER
THOUGHT WAS POSSIBLE NOT ONLY
FOR SELF.
BUT FOR GENERATIONS TO COME IN
HER FAMILY.
THAT'S WHAT WE DO IN COMMUNITY
COLLEGES THAT'S WHAT WE'RE ALL
ABOUT.
EARLY WAS FORTUNATE THAT SHE
PERSEVERED BUT TOO MANY OF OUR
STUDENTS DO NOT.
THE FINANCIAL HOUSING AND FOOD
VERY BURDENS ARE JUST TOO GREAT.
PLEASE HELP US SUPPORT OUR
STUDENTS SO WE CAN HAVE MORE
SUCCESS STORIES LIKE IRWIN
ROBINSON PLEASE SUPPORT AB NINE
FORTY THREE THANK YOU.
IF THE NEXT WITNESS WOULD PLEASE
GIVE GIVEN THE ONE WITH.
HELLO MY NAME'S KAREN CAMP WITH
AND THE VICE PRESIDENT OF
LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS FOR THE
SINCE SENATE FOR CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
I'M HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF EIGHTY SEVEN EIGHTY NINE
FORTY THREE WHICH ALLOW
COMMITTEE COLLEGES STREET TO
SUPPORT SINCE FACING UNEXPECTED
FINANCIAL EMERGENCIES.
SMALL GRANTS TO HELP INSTANCE
SCHOOL THE LEGISLATURE'S MADE A
LOT OF PROGRESS.
RECENT YEARS TO REDUCE OR
ELIMINATE THE COST OF TUITION AT
CAN YOU COLLEGES ARE FOR THE
MOST EXPENSIVE PART OF ATTENDING
COMMITTEE COLLEGES NON TUITION
COSTS.
FOOD HOUSING BOOKS
TRANSPORTATION OTHER EXPENSES.
FOR TOO MANY COMMITTEE COLLAGENS
AND CRACKS IN OUR UNEXPECTED
ILLNESS CAN DERAIL THEIR
EDUCATION COMPLETELY.
THE NATIONAL FINANCIAL AID FOR
MARK IS NOT A DOUBLE SYSTEM.
MANY OF THE STUDENTS THERE IS NO
QUICK RESPONSE AND RAPID RAPID
ASSISTANCE AVAILABLE.
SHOULD YOU.
SHOULD YOU SHOULD NOT BE FORCED
TO TURN TO FAMILY FRIENDS CREDIT
CARDS OR EVEN PAYDAY LENDERS IN
ORDER TO COVER THOSE COSTS STAY
IN SCHOOL ALLOWING CAMPUSES TO
FIND.
ITS OWN VERSION SEE GRANT
PROGRAMS ADMISSION EQUITY IN
ACHIEVING PROGRAM FUNDING WILL
HELP STUDENTS CONTINUE THEIR
EDUCATION BILLS FOR COLLEGES
RETENTION.
GRADUATION RATES THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
STEPHANIE GOLDMAN OF THE FACULTY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE PROUD SPONSORS
IN SUPPORT [inaudible]
CO SPONSORS.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS BEING A
CHRISTOPOULOS EMERSON OF
SCHOLARSHIP AMERICA ALSO A CO
SPONSOR IN PRIVATE SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
ANGELA WILLIAMS CALIFORNIA
BLACKOUTS NETWORK IN SUPPORT.
JUSTIN TELECOM BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE WE DON'T
HAVE AN OFFICIAL POSITION BUT
SUPPORT OF OF THE INTENT AND
WILL BE TAKING IT TO OUR NEXT
BOARD MEETING IN MAY FOR SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
ANY TWO WINNERS.
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE.
OF MISTER TRUTH WOULD LIKE TO
CLOSE I REALIZE I DON'T THINK I
ACCEPTED THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
WHICH I'M HAPPY TO DO AND VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE THE
CONSIDERATION THE COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU FOR REMINDING ME ABOUT
THE AMENDMENTS AND THANK YOU FOR
ACCEPTING THOSE ABOUT.
SO WE HAD A MOTION BY MISTER LOW
THE SECOND BY MISS IRWIN.
MADAM SECRETARY IF YOU'D PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED
TO THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEDINA ALL RIGHT MEDINA I CHOI.
CHOI I JONES SAWYER -- JONES
SAWYER I'D BLOOM.
BLOOM I GABRIEL -- WHEN I --
WHEN I KILEY?
LEVINE.
LEVINE I LOW.
LOW I PATTERSON.
PATTERSON AYE SANTIAGO WEBER
[inaudible]
WEBER I NINE ZERO THE BILL IS
OUT THANK YOU COLLEAGUES WE'LL
KEEP IT OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
AND SEEING NO OTHER AUTHORS.
IN FRONT OF ME.
DOCTOR WEBER LIKE TO PRESENT
[inaudible]
OKAY.
AND DOCTOR WEBER THAT IS FILE
ITEM [inaudible] FIVE YOU'RE NOT
GETTING ENOUGH ATTENTION.
CASES
.
THE BOOKS ARE OUTSIDE OF ANY
SORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR OF TO OUR MEDINA
AND MEMBERS THIS AFTERNOON I'M
HERE TO PRESENT TO YOU AB.
THREE SIX NINE A BILL RELATING
TO THE STRUCTURE OF SALARIES FOR
C. ISSUE EMPLOYEES.
I LIKE TO SAY THAT WE'VE BEEN
WORKING ON ADDRESSING THE
CONCERNS IN ANALYSIS ABOUT
REDUCING PROGRAM FOR STUDENTS
AND WILL CONTINUE TO WORK ON
THAT.
FOLLOWING IN NINETEEN NINETY SIX
THE IMPASSE IN CONTRACT
NEGOTIATIONS THE CSU BOARD OF
TRUSTEES UNILATERALLY ELIMINATED
EXISTING EMPLOYEES STEP SALLY
STEPS.
INCREASING TIES TO JOB
PERFORMANCE AND LONGEVITY.
THIS HAS RESULTED IN NEW HIRES
EARNING HIGHER SALARIES THAN
EXISTING EMPLOYEES WHO WORKED IN
THE SAME CLASSIFICATION FOR MANY
YEARS.
THIS IN EQUITY HAS CREATED A
NINETY FIVE POINT FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS IN VIRGIN GAP BETWEEN
THE SALARIES OF NEWLY HIRED AND
LONG EMPLOYED SEE ISSUE STAFF.
FOR TWO DECADES THE C. ISSUE HAS
BEEN UNWILLING TO REINSTATE
SALARY STEPS DESPITE THE FAILURE
OF THE EXISTING SAU STRUCTURE
AND THE INABILITY OF EMPLOYEES
TO OUR IN A FAIR AND EQUITABLE
WAY.
AB TWELVE THIRTY ONE WILL
REINSTATE 5% SALLY STEPS FOR
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
SUPPORT STAFF.
THE INCREASE WILL BE MADE
ANNUALLY WHEN EMPLOYEES MEET THE
STANDARDS OF SATISFACTORY
PERFORMANCE AS DETERMINED BY THE
EMPLOYEES ADMINISTRATORS.
HERE WITH ME TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF AB THREE SIX NIGHT IS TERRY
WILSON WHO WORKS AT FRESNO STATE
UNIVERSITY.
AND CAL MASON WHO IS A MEMBER OF
THE TEAMSTERS LOCAL TWENTY TEN
AT SAN DIEGO STATE UNIVERSITY.
AND DAVID BELL HAWKINS FROM THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
EMPLOYEES UNION -- WE'LL HAVE
BEEN PRESENT NOW OKAY.
WE HAVE FOUR MINUTES SO I'LL TRY
OKAY.
NOT PER PERSON OKAY YEAH OKAY.
ALL MEANS THE END STAND YEAH.
OKAY GOT IT -- MY NAME IS TERRY
WILSON I'M AN ELEVEN YEAR
EMPLOYEE AT FRESNO STATE.
SALAR STEPS ARE NOT RAISES
RAISES SUCH AS GENERAL SALARY
INCREASES IN COLAS ARE
NEGOTIATED AND HAVE NOTHING TO
DO WITH EMPLOYEES PERFORMANCE.
ALL WE ARE ASKING FOR IS PARITY
WITH THE OTHER AGENCIES IN OVER
TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND OTHER STATE
EMPLOYEES.
I WAS FIRST HIRED IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN AS AN
ADMINISTRATIVE ANALYST OVERSAW
THE BUDGET IN THE ENGINEERING
DEPARTMENT.
GIVEN IT WORKING IS.
THAT -- ASSISTED WITH WORKING
WITH THE VICE PRESIDENT FOR
STUDENT AFFAIRS WHICH REQUIRED
INCREASE STAFF OVERSIGHT AND
BUDGET RESPONSIBILITIES.
I NOW RUN THE BULLDOG ID CARD
OFFICE IN IN THE IMAGING
DEPARTMENT THIRTEEN EMPLOYEES
WORKING DIRECTLY UNDER ME I
PRIDE PROVIDE ASSISTANCE TO THE
MINISTRY OF SERVICES DEPARTMENT
AND UNIVERSITY CONTROLLER.
I HAVE AN UNDERGRADUATE DEGREE
WITH AN EMPHASIS IN MATHEMATICS
SCIENCE AND BIOLOGY I HAVE TWO
MASTERS DEGREES.
DESPITE MY EDUCATION.
CHANGES IN MY JOB RESPONSIBILITY
WORKLOADS.
I CONSISTENT RECEIVING
OUTSTANDING EVALUATIONS.
I HAVE NOT RECEIVED ANY MERIT
SALARY INCREASE AT FRESNO STATE
ELEVEN YEARS.
HAVING FURTHER INSULT NEW
EMPLOYEES ARE BEING HIRED IN THE
SAME JOB CLASSIFICATION AS ME
AND EARNING A HIGHER SALARY.
NOT WITHSTANDING MY EXPERIENCE
THAT IS SHARED BY THOUSANDS OF
OTHER EMPLOYEES CSU MANAGERS AND
SUPERVISORS DO RECEIVE AN ANNUAL.
MERIT SALARY INCREASE DESPITE
CRITICISM OF A STATE AUDIT
RELEASED IN.
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN THE STATE
AUDIT ALSO FOUND THAT SEEKS TO
MANAGEMENT POSITIONS GREAT TWICE
THE RATE OF SUPPORT STAFF.
WITH HALF A BILLION.
DOLLARS PER YEAR IN TOTAL
COMPENSATION FAR OUTPACING THE
SALARY OF STUFF.
AGAIN WE ARE ASKING FOR IS
PARITY WITH OTHER STATE
EMPLOYEES.
I SHOULDN'T BE FINANCIALLY
PENALIZED FOR WORKING AT THE CSU.
NOR SHOULD DO EMPLOYEES BE HIRED
FOR THE SAME JOB SOUTH
CLASSIFICATION THAT I'VE WORKED
THAT FOR YEARS.
AND BE GIVEN A HIGHER SALARY.
I'M ASKING TO BE FAIRLY
COMPENSATED AND TREATED WITH
RESPECT.
AFTER OVER TWENTY YEARS OF
INEQUITY I'M ASKING THE CSU
SUPPORT STAFF BE MADE WHOLE
AGAIN I URGE YOU TO SUPPORT A.
B. THREE SIX NINE THANK YOU.
MEDINA MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE --
DAVID BALLOT HAWK INTERPRETING
THE CSU EMPLOYEES UNION -- YOU
HAVE SOME HANDOUTS -- THE
SERGEANT IS -- PASSING OUT RIGHT
NOW ONE OF THEM IS A CHART.
SHOWING THE INVERSION THAT HAS
BEEN CREATED FROM A LACK OF
SALARY STEPS.
SO ON AVERAGE NEW HIRES FOR THE
SAME POSITION ON THE SAME CAMPUS.
ARE EARNING OVER SEVEN HUNDRED
DOLLARS MORE A MONTH.
THE EMPLOYEES WHO HAVE BEEN
THERE FOR LONG TERM PERIOD.
IT'S ABOUT AN 18% DIFFERENTIAL
BETWEEN NEW HIRES AND THOSE WHO
HAVE BEEN THERE FOR TEN FIFTEEN
YEARS.
TERRY MENTIONED THE ART AT THE
DOCTOR WEBER AUTHORED -- STATE
AUDIT THAT WAS DONE IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN I JUST WANTED A RE
EMPHASIZE A COUPLE OF POINTS.
SO THE AUDITOR FOUND THAT MID
MANAGEMENT LEVEL POSITIONS THE
MANAGERS SUPERVISORS GREW AT
TWICE THE RATE MORE THAN DOUBLE
THE RATE OF OF SEE IF YOU
SUPPORT STAFF.
IN THAT THEIR COMPENSATION HAS
NOW REACHED A HALF A BILLION
DOLLARS.
THE AUDITOR CONCLUDED THAT THE
SEE IF YOU COULD NOT JUSTIFY.
THIS SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN
PERSONNEL.
AND IN THE COMPENSATION.
THE AUDITOR ALSO CONCLUDED THAT
THE C. ISSUES THAT WERE LOOKED
AT QUOTE DO NOT ADEQUATELY
OVERSEE THEIR BUDGETS.
WHICH QUOTE REDUCE ASSURANCES
THAT STATE FENDER BEING SPENT
EFFICIENTLY AND APPROPRIATELY.
SO WE BECAME CURIOUS ABOUT
WHAT'S WHAT'S HAPPENING TO
COMPENSATION FUND SO WE FOUND
THIS AUDIT WHICH YOU HAVE A COPY
OF THIS IS FROM OCTOBER TO A
TWENTY THIRTEEN THIS WAS NOT AT
THAT THE ELAINE HOW DID OF
AGENCIES THAT HAVE OUTSIDE THE
CAMP WE DIDN'T KNOW THAT THE SEE.
IF YOU HAD NAY OUTSIDE ACCOUNT
SO THE USER ACCOUNTS ARE NOT
UNDER THE OVERSIGHT.
OR ACCOUNTABILITY OF THE STATE
TREASURY.
YOU'LL SEE IN TWO THOUSAND NINE
TEN THE HIGHLIGHTED SECTION.
DURING A TIME WHEN WE WERE DOING
EMPLOYEE LAYOFFS AND FURLOUGHS.
IN STUDENT TUITION WITH
SKYROCKETING.
THE CSU BANG. SIX HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY TWO MILLION DOLLARS.
INTO AN OUTSIDE ACCOUNT THAT WAS
OUTSIDE THE STATE TREASURY.
WE REPEAT THAT.
WE ARE LAYING OFF AND FOR
ALLOWING EMPLOYEES.
STUDENT TUITION IS GOING UP.
IN THE CSU PROFIT SIX HUNDRED
EIGHTY TWO MILLION DOLLARS SO WE
WORK WITH THE SENATE.
AND WITH MISTER SANTIAGO. TO DO
A REQUEST TO THE CSU THAT YOUR
OTHER DOCUMENT ABOUT THE OUTSIDE
ACCOUNTS ON PAGE TWO OF THAT
DOCUMENT WHICH IS SIGNED BY
CHANCE FOR WHITE.
AND YOUR YOUR YOUR TIME IS
ACTUALLY EXPIRED SO IF YOU COULD
WRAP IT UP PLEASE.
I WILL SIR.
IN JUNE TWO THOUSAND EIGHT
YOU'LL SEE A BALANCE IN THESE
OUTSIDE ACCOUNT TO ONE POINT
EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS THAT'S
WITH THE BE.
IT GREW TO THREE POINT SEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS TEN YEARS LATER.
OF THAT MONEY NEARLY TWO BILLION
DOLLARS IS DISCRETIONARY ONGOING
FUNDING.
SO FOR THE CSU TO CLAIM THAT
THEY DON'T HAVE MONEY TO DO THIS.
WHEN HAVE CLEARLY PROFITED FROM
THE ABUSE OF THESE EMPLOYEES?
WE THINK IS A RATHER
HYPOCRITICAL WHEN WE ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
IF OTHER WITNESSES YOUR TIME IS
UP FOR MINUTES IS THE TIME
ALLOTTED.
CAN DIVIDE IT ANYWAY YOU WANT
BUT IT'S FOUR MINUTES SO NEXT
WITNESSES OF PLEASE JUST YOUR
NAME AND THE ORGANIZATION YOU
REPRESENT OKAY.
SURE.
ALL RIGHT -- GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE
MET GOOD AFTERNOON.
MISTER CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE
MEMBERS NAMES CAL MASON -- I'M
ELECTRICITY SAN DIEGO STATE
MEMBER OF THE TEAMSTERS LOCAL.
TWENTY TEN SKILLED TRADES
DIVISION.
I AM IN SUPPORT OF AB THREE
SIXTY NINE THANK YOU OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
HI MATT MASON -- EMPLOYEE A C.
ISSUE FOR SIXTEEN YEARS WITH THE
BOTTOM MY SCALE I'M IN SUPPORT
OF A BEASTLY.
SIXTY NINE CAN REALLY RESURRECT
WITH SERVICE EMPLOYEES
INTERNATIONAL UNION HOW TO CO
SPONSOR.
ANGELA WILLIAMS CALIFORNIA BLACK
HEALTH NETWORK IN SUPPORT.
MATT BROUGHT ON BEHALF THE
TEAMSTERS ARE CO SPONSORS ON THE
BILL WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
MICHAEL YOUNG WITH CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION SUPPORT.
MARIO GUERRERO ON THE BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
THE WORD OR WHETHER VICE
OF CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
ROBERT OLSON SAN JOSE STATE
UNIVERSITY IN SUPPORT.
LOOK MULLIN OTHER EMPLOYEE OF
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
FRESNO FOR TWENTY FIVE YEARS AND
CHIEF STEWARD FOR THE ACADEMIC
PROFESSIONALS OF CALIFORNIA
STRONGLY SUPPORT AB THREE SIXTY
NINE THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING CHAIRMAN MEDINA AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ALL THE TWENTY
POLITICAL DIRECTOR TEAM SAYS
LOCAL.
TWENTY TEN AND TEN FIFTEEN
THOUSAND STRONG MEMBERS IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL WE ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE.
AND SUPPORT IN THE BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON SANDRA BARRERA ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
BRIAN HOW IT CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS WERE A
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
HELLO.
GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU
MARTINEZ CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY -- WE MUST REALLY BEWE MUST RESPECT WILL BE OPPOSED
AS MEASURE AS OPPOSED TO THE
PREVIOUS BIRD VERSION OF THE
BILL BUT TWELVE THIRTY ONE FROM
LAST YEAR.
UP I WOULD LIKE TO KIND OF JUST
HIGHLIGHT THE THREE REASONS WHY
WERE OPPOSED THE MEASURE AND
THEN ALSO TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THE THE ACCOUNTS THAT.
A MISTER BALL HAWKINS REYES AND
I'LL HEAD OVER THAT TO TRANSFORM
BACK.
ARE SUCH A VICE CHANCELLOR FOR
LABOR RELATIONS TO TALK ABOUT IN
QUESTION YOU HAVE ABOUT THE
SCOPE OF THE BILL.
FIRST OF ALL WE ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT THIS BILL BECAUSE WE
BELIEVE IT TAKES AWAY FROM THE
CSU STABILITY OF THE MORE
JUSTICE TO MATCHES IN PLACE IT
TAKES AWAY FROM OUR COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING PROCESS.
AND IT PUTS INTO A BILL INTO
LEGISLATION.
AND GIVE THE BY PRESENTS
ARGUMENT -- FOR ALMOST ALL OF
OUR PULLED BOYS CALLED SUPPORT
STAFF FOR THE NEXT TEN YEARS
THAT'S A SIGNIFICANT COST THE
SYSTEM.
THOSE COSTS ARE ARE GONNA BE
QUICKLY COMING OUT OF OTHER POTS
OF FROM THE CAMPS OPERATIONS WE
ARE.
WE GOT THROUGH TO BILLING
DOLLARS FROM THE LEGISLATURE THE
GOVERNOR EX I'M SORRY.
IT'S PROPOSED IN THE BUDGET.
THOSE ARE THE REAL DOLLARS
THAT'S GONNA SUPPORT THE
COMPETITION AGREES INCREASES
THAT WE CAME TO AGREEMENT WITH
OUR LABOR GROUPS -- THAT'S GOING
TO BE THIRTY FIVE DOLLARS OR SO
THAT'S PART OF THOSE WHICH WERE
GRADUATION INITIATIVE ALL THOSE
DOLLARS OF YOUR DOLLARS THAT WE
HAVEN'T GOT HAVEN'T SPOKEN.
FOR HOW TO PAY FOR A 5% FONG
GOING IS BEYOND ME.
BRING THAT DON'T WE ALSO ARE
OPPOSE HIS MAGIC AS WE DON'T
BELIEVE THIS BILL ADDRESSES IN
VERSION BECAUSE IF THIS BILL
WERE GONNA PULL INTO PLACE.
ALL EMPLOYEES WITHIN THE SCHOOL
WOULD RAISE BY PERCENT.
YOU DO NEED A SATISFACTORY --
EVALUATION WE JUST BE 95290% OF
EMPLOYEES WILL RECEIVE SUSPECT
ROOMS -- VALUATION BECAUSE IT'S
ON A SCALE FIVE IMMEDIATELY SO.
THREE IT COMES TO THE ACCOUNTS
THEY ALSO COUNTS THIS WAS AN
AUDIT ITEM.
I WANNA BE VERY CLEAR WITH YOU.
THE LEGISLATURE.
GAVE THE AUTHORITY TO WORK JUST
TO STUDENTS TO OUT RUN THESE
COUNTS OUTSIDE THE STATE
CONTROLLER'S AUTHORITY.
THOSE COUNTS ARE TIGHT
SPECIFICALLY TO A SPECIFIC
OBLIGATIONS SO HEALTH FACILITIES
PARKING -- HOUSING ALL THE HAVE
A VERY SPECIFIC PURPOSE THE CSU
IS NOT IN THE BUSINESS OF A
SUSPECT AS A MATTER OF FACT
COUPLE YEARS AGO MR BLOCK.
X. INCREASE THE ABILITY OF THE
BOARD JUST TO USE TO INVEST
MONEY AGGRESSIVELY MORE
AGGRESSIVELY THAN THE CURRENTLY
PREVIOUSLY HAD. THOUSAND FORTY
BROUGHT TO GIVEN TO US BY THE
LEGISLATURE.
SO I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE YOU
ALL UNDERSTAND HERE IS NO SLUSH
FUNDS ALL THE MONIES THAT ARE AT
THE OUTSIDE THE CONTROLS OFFICE
ARE SPOKEN FOR AND THAT ARE
GRANTED OVER JOHN SORT.
A GOOD AFTERNOON.
SO I APPRECIATE THIS IS A POLICY
COMMITTEE SO I LIMIT MY
OBJECTIONS TO POLICY.
UNDER HERO.
AND THE DEFINITION OF SCOPE OF
REPRESENTATION WE HAVE WAGES
HOURS AND OTHER TIMES AND
CONDITIONS OF EMPLOYMENT.
WHAT THIS BILL WOULD DO IS
ESSENTIALLY REMOVE WAGES FROM
THE SCOPE OF COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING?
HI AND IF THAT WERE TO BE THE
CASE.
THEN THAT WOULD HAVE A VERY
SERIOUS NEGATIVE IMPACT ON THE
ABILITY OF MANAGEMENT AND LABOR
TO COME TOGETHER NEGOTIATE
COLLECTIVELY.
THIS BILL AS DRAFTED AS AND
EXPLAIN WOULD ACTUALLY CATCH
PROBABLY HI 90% OF OUR STAFF
EMPLOYEES ARE NOT FACULTY
EMPLOYEES -- WOULD DO ABSOLUTELY
NOTHING TO ADDRESS THE ISSUES
WHICH WERE RAISED WE KNOW WE
HAVE SALARY STRUCTURE ISSUES --
WITH.
OUR STAFF EMPLOYEES WE HAVE
WORKING GROUPS ESTABLISHED IN
ORDER TO DISCUSS THOUGHT OUTSIDE
THE BARGAINING CYCLE.
BUT SIMPLY A BROUGHT ACROSS THE
BOARD STROKES OF GIVING 5% FOR
SATISFACTORY EVALUATION REPEATED
OF TEN YEARS IRRESPECTIVE OF THE
PHYSICAL ENVIRONMENT IN WHICH
THE CSU WILL HAVE TO OPERATE
DURING THOSE TEN YEARS.
AT A SOMETHING WHICH THE
ADMINISTRATION JUST CAN'T
POSSIBLY SUPPORT.
AND THEN FINALLY JUST ON THE
POLICY SIDE.
THESE ISSUES HAVING VERSION
COMPRESSION THE COMPLEX AND THE
COMPLICATED THEY DIFFER BY
REGION THAT DIFFER BY CAMPUS.
AND THE COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
PROCESS IS BY FAR AND AWAY THE
BEST MEANS OF RESOLVING THAT --
IMPOSING THIS IS A UNFUNDED
MANDATES WOULD ONLY BE
DESTRUCTIVE OF THE COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING.
ENVIRONMENTS AND DESCRIPTIVE OF
THE RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE
PARTIES.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION [inaudible]
ANY TWEENER.
STEPHANIE GOLDMAN OF THE FACULTY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES OUR BOARD HAS
NOT TAKEN AN OFFICIAL POSITION
ON THIS BUT WE SUPPORT THE
SPIRIT OF THE BILL AND STAND IN
SOLIDARITY.
ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE MISTER PATTERSON.
AB.
MEMBERS AND MISTER CHAIRMAN
THANK YOU I VOTED FOR THIS BILL
LAST TIME I'M GONNA VOTE FOR IT
AGAIN.
I APPRECIATE -- YOU BRING THIS
FORWARD AGAIN -- THIS HAS A LOT
TO DO WITH.
MY ALMA MATER AND FRESNO STATE.
AND FRIENDS THAT I HAVE KNOWN
FOR A LONG LONG TIME IN THESE
KINDS OF POSITIONS.
AND WHAT I FIND OUT THAT PEOPLE
WHO ARE.
MAKING SURE THAT BULLDOG STADIUM
IS FIRST RATE WHEN WE BEAT UCLA
[inaudible]
OUR AND OTHERS WHO ARE IN THESE
SUPPORT STAFF POSITIONS.
UP FINDING THEMSELVES
[inaudible]
HAVING.
TO STACK SHELVES AND SEVEN
ELEVEN WITH A SECOND JOB.
WHILE WE SIT IN THE RED
[inaudible]
SECTION.
AND ENJOY A WONDERFUL EXPERIENCE.
AND WHEN I DISCOVERED THAT THIS
WAS THE CIRCUMSTANCE OF PEOPLE
THAT I REALLY CARE ABOUT AND
HAVEN'T GOTTEN TO KNOW FOR A
LONG LONG TIME.
THE I AM IN SUPPORT.
AND I'M ALSO ON A A PURELY WAGE
AND REWARD [inaudible]
DECISION [inaudible]
YOU KNOW [inaudible]
MANAGEMENT [inaudible]
FACULTY.
EXECUTIVES SEEM.
TO DO PRETTY WELL.
THIS GROUP OF EMPLOYEES I THINK
HAVE BEEN [inaudible]
LEFT BEHIND.
AND SO I'M GOING TO WEAR OUT.
VOTE IN SUPPORT ON THIS.
AND I SURE HOPE IT.
YES BEYOND THIS COMMITTEE AND
GETS TO A GOVERNOR WHO WILL SIGN
IT.
SO WHEN I GO TO MY NEXT FRESNO
STATE FOOTBALL GAME.
I DON'T HAVE THE PANGS OF GUILT
THE SERIOUSLY.
OF AN OF AN ALARM.
OF A GREAT UNIVERSITY.
THAT WOULD HAVE SUPPORT STAFF
LIVING THE WAY THEY DO.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
MR LEVINE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
OCTOBER THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL BACK LAST YEAR I HAD
VOTED NO IN COMMITTEE AND I
VOTED AYE.
ON THE FLOOR I'M GONNA PROBABLY
AT LEAST KEEP TO THE FIRST
PATTERN OF VOTING KNOWING
COMMITTEE AT THIS POINT -- I
APPRECIATE WHAT YOU'RE DOING AND
I WOULD LOVE TO HAND OUT RAISES
THAT WOULD BE A FUN DAY EVERY
DAY IN THIS JOB -- BUT THAT IS
NOT WHAT WE DO YOU GUYS ENGAGE
IN COLLECTIVE BARGAINING I WOULD
NEVER.
TAKE SOMETHING AWAY THAT YOU
GAIN IN COLLECTIVE BARGAINING --
OR TAKE SOMETHING AWAY FROM THE
CSU THAT THEY HAD.
DIED HAD RECEIVED IN COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING SO IT'S IT'S AN
AWKWARD SITUATION FOR US TO BE
IN. TO T. PLACE IN THIS.
SHOULD THERE BE.
ECONOMIC MOBILITY FOR EMPLOYEES
AND I I FUNDAMENTALLY BELIEVE
THAT THERE SHOULD BE JUST AS WE
HOPE THAT THERE IS ECONOMIC
MOBILITY FOR STUDENTS IN THIS
ISSUE I THINK FOR THE WORK FORCE
THERE SHOULD BE AS WELL.
SO I THINK WHAT I WOULD JUST ASK
OF THE CSU IS TO MAKE SURE THAT
I HAVE A LITTLE BIT MORE
INFORMATION AS THIS BILL MOVES
FORWARD IF IT MOVES FORWARD --
TO UNDERSTAND WHAT HAS BEEN
GAINED AND LOST IN THE
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING PROCESS SO
YOU KNOW WE CAN MAKE SURE THAT
THIS IS HAPPENING WELL IF WE'RE
GONNA BE ASKED TO REFEREE THIS.
I JUST WANT TO HAVE A LITTLE BIT
MORE INFORMATION BEFORE THIS
THING GOES TO THE FLOOR -- BUT
AGAIN I I APPRECIATE WHAT YOU'RE
DOING AND AND YOU KNOW WE WANT
TO LIFT EVERYONE UP --
ESPECIALLY THE POOREST PEOPLE
WORKING FOR AN AMAZING
INSTITUTION LIKE THIS YES YOU
SHOULD HAVE PEOPLE THAT ARE PAID
WITH DIGNITY.
AND AND SO I APPRECIATE THE THE
EFFORT THAT YOU'RE PUTTING
[inaudible]
FOR DR JOY.
I THOUGHT I'D GIVE THEM A CHANCE
TO ANSWER.
I THINK IT WAS JUST ARE GONNA
FOR EIGHT RIGHT [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
USE ME [inaudible]
THE OUT.
PAY INEQUITY I HEAR THE PROBLEM
AND THE HOW WE CAN ADDRESS OF
INTO US WHAT YOUR BILL IS ARE
TRYING -- TO MAKE UP BUT TWO
QUESTIONS THAT I HAVE IS THAT --
HOW YOU GONNA MAKE UP BUT THE
CURRENT -- INEQUITY SITUATION.
FOR THE PEOPLE WHO ARE -- BUT
LESS PAID THE WITH THE LONGER OR
LONGEVITY.
OF WHEN YOUR EMPLOYEES SAW.
WITH THERE BE A CATCH UP A
SPECIAL FUND.
AND HOW MUCH OF THAT WOULD BE
OUR FOR THE TWENTY THREE
CAMPUSES SO CH CSU SYSTEM.
NUMBER. TWO QUESTION IS THAT THE
WHY IT IS SO OFTEN I MEAN I HAS
HAPPENED IF THIS WAS THAT
THROUGH THE OF COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING -- NEGOTIATIONS.
I'M I'M SURE THE I UNION GIVEN
CERTAIN PERCENTAGE IF THERE'S A
5% THE HOW THAT WOULD BE.
ACTIVELY DISTRIBUTED.
OUR AND THEN.
THAT THE PEOPLE WHO.
I HAVE BEEN WORKING THERE LONGER
PERIOD.
I SHOULD BEEN TAKEN CARE OF HOW
WOULD.
JUST A DISTRICT IN EQUITY HAS
HAPPENED -- LET ME LET ME SAY
FIRST OF ALL OF THEM.
THE INVERSION ISSUE IS AN ISSUE
THAT'S BEING ADDRESSED ANOTHER
WAY IN PEOPLE'S MENTION HERE BUT
THIS BILL IS NOT THE SOLUTION TO
THE INVERSION FIRST OF ALL THAT
WAS JUST MENTIONED SHOW YOU HOW
BAD THINGS GOT.
THIS BILL IS ABOUT RESTORING THE
MERIT INCREASES OF THAT CAN
HAPPEN FOR AN INDIVIDUAL -- AND
IT'S IMPORTANT TO UNDERSTAND
THAT WHILE WE GIVE PAY HOMMAGE
TO COLLECTIVE BARGAINING.
AND I WAS ONE OF THE PEOPLE WAY
BACK IN THE DAY WITH YOU P. C.
AND THEN CFA THAT ACTUALLY GOT
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING IF THIS IF
THIS ISSUE SYSTEM THAT WAS ONE
OF THE THINGS I DID IN THE
SEVENTIES -- BUT THIS WAS DONE
OUTSIDE OF COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
AND THAT'S WHY IT'S SO IMPORTANT
UNDERSTAND IT WOULD BE DIFFERENT
IF THIS WAS SOMETHING THAT HAVE
BEEN COLLECTIVELY BARGAIN.
NOW THE SYSTEM PAYS HOMMAGE TO
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING WHEN IT'S
TO THEIR ADVANTAGE.
BUT WHEN IS NOT TO THEIR
ADVANTAGE THEY DO WHAT THEY WANT
TO DO.
AND THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED IN THE
SITUATION AND IT NOT ONLY
HAPPENED TO THESE FOLKS BUT IT
HAPPENED AB ALMOST EVERYBODY IN
SYSTEM.
AND SO WHAT HAPPENED WAS THEY
DECIDED TO ELIMINATE STEP
INCREASES THE MERIT STEP
INCREASES.
NOT SINCE THEN THE OTHERS HAVE
GONE BACK AND GOTTEN MERIT STEP
INCREASES THE VARIOUS FORMS THEY
HAVE REFUSED TO BARK TO GET TO
GET THIS THIS PARTICULAR GROUP
THE STEP INCREASES SO THEY'RE
THE ONLY ONES NOW.
WITHOUT THE 5% MERIT INCREASE
POSSIBILITY THAT THAT DOESN'T
MEAN YOU GET EVERY YEAR.
AND IT'S NOT LIKE GETTING A
RAISE WHEN YOU GET A RAISE AT
THE SYSTEM WE GIVE THREE POINT
FOUR TWO POINT WHATEVER RAISES.
EVERYBODY GETS A RAISE OKAY WE
UNDERSTAND THAT APPEAR BECAUSE
THAT HAPPENS OCCASIONALLY WHERE
EVERYBODY GETS A RAISE.
BUT THEN WHEN YOU CAN DO
ASSESSMENT AND EVALUATE YOUR
FACULTY OR YOUR STAFF YOU CAN
YOU CAN INCREASE THOSE WAYS THAT
YOU CAN DO.
THERE'S MERIT KINDS OF RACES
THAT ARE THERE THIS IS A SYSTEM
OF MAD WHEN I CAME INTO THIS
ISSUE EVERYBODY HAD THE
POSSIBILITY 5%.
INCREASES.
THEN THEY TOOK IT AWAY WITHOUT
BARGAINING AND IT SHOULD HAVE
BEEN BARGAIN BUT IT WAS NOT.
SO WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS
CORRECT SOMETHING THAT WAS DONE
OUTSIDE OF THE BARGAINING THAT
WAS REALLY UNFAIR AND UNJUST.
AND EVERYBODY'S COAST TALK ABOUT
BARGAINING WHEN THIS WAS TAKEN
AWAY WITHOUT BARGAINING WHAT WAS
SIMPLY TRYING TO DO IS PUT THIS
PARTICULAR GROUP OF INDIVIDUALS
BACK INTO THE SAME STRUCTURE AS
EVERYONE ELSE AT THE UNIVERSITY.
THAT ALLOWS THEM TO BASICALLY
GET MERIT INCREASES THAT OF THE
YEAR NOW THE INVERSION PIECE HAS
OCCURRED BECAUSE OF ALL THE
STUFF THAT HAPPENS AT THE
UNIVERSITY.
AND I CAN TESTIFY TO THE HOW
HORRIBLE AND HOW DEMORALIZING
INVERSION ME IS BECAUSE AS I
WORK AT THE UNIVERSAL FORTY
YEARS AFTER ABOUT TWENTY FIVE
YEARS I HAD PEOPLE I WAS HIRING
MAKING MORE MONEY THAN I WAS.
AND IT TOOK A MAJOR ACT BY THE
PRESIDENT OF THE CAMPUS TO
INCREASE MY SALARY BECAUSE I HAD
BEEN SUPERVISING PEOPLE MAKING
MORE THAN I WAS BECAUSE OF THAT
NEGOTIATIONS.
AND ALL THE INVERSION STUFF THAT
HAPPENED IT WAS STOLEN JUST.
AND IS STILL A LOT OF THIS IN
THE SYSTEM THAT NEEDS TO BE
CLEANED OUT AND CLARIFIED AND
IT'S ME.
IN ITS EVEN MORE DEMORALIZING
WHEN YOU CONSIDER THAT -- YOU
KNOW WE WE GIVE AS WHAT WAS
HAPPENING MINISTERS ARE GETTING
MAJOR INCREASES.
SUPPOSEDLY MERIT INCREASES
WITHOUT ANY PERFORMANCE.
NOW AS A A CHAIR OF A DEPARTMENT
I HAD TO EVALUATE MY FACULTY
EVERY YEAR.
I HAD TO GIVE THEM GOALS AND
OBJECTIVES AND SO FORTH AND SO
ON BUT I HAD NO ABILITY AT ALL
AT THAT POINT. TO SAY AND AS A
RESULT THIS PROB GOING TO
RECOMMEND THIS PERSON FOR ME ARE
THE CHESTNUT.
BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T HAVE IT.
AS THEY HAD IN OTHER AREAS.
AND SO WHAT WE'RE LOOKING AT IS
AN INJUSTICE THAT OCCURRED.
WHEN THEY DECIDED THE
ADMINISTRATION TOOK THE MERIT
OUT OF THE MERIT STEPPED OUT OF
OUT OF THE ABILITY OF THESE
FOLKS WHO WORK THERE?
AND THEY HAVE BEEN STRUGGLING
EVER SINCE TO BRING BACK BUT IT
WAS NOT TAKEN IN THE NORMAL
PROCESS WHICH WOULD BEEN TO
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING.
MAY I DON'T WANT PEOPLE CAN
UNDERSTAND THE STRUCTURE THAT
HAS HAPPENED AND WHY THIS IS
BEING BROUGHT HERE I WOULD NOT
HAVE BROUGHT IT IF IT HAD BEEN
NEGOTIATED NAY LOST THE GHOST
ASIANS OF THIS DATA THAT.
THEY TOOK IT WITHOUT
NEGOTIATIONS.
BEFORE I GO TO VOTE BOTH OF THE
LIKE WHATEVER'S BUT I I HAVE
MEMBERS WHO SURE -- I THINK
STILL HAVE QUESTIONS SO WHAT ARE
THE MEMBERS FIRST.
MY QUESTION GOES TO THE YES.
GO AHEAD MR ROOM ON THE UHHUH.
FIRST I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE --
ARE A A FRIEND FROM FRESNO IN
THIS FLIGHT OF FANCY ABOUT WHAT
MIGHT.
WHEN YOU SEE LA SHOWS UP -- BUT
BUT I WANT TO HEAR YOUR RESPONSE
TO THE OF THE ISSUE THAT --
DOCTOR WEBER I JUST REYES BUT I
AM I HAVE TO SAY I'M A BIT
CONFUSED NOW WHETHER.
THE THE ISSUE IS THE MERIT
INCREASE OR THE INVERSION OR
WHETHER OR AND THAT'S THE INTER
CONNECTED TO THE OF THE TWO BUT
MAYBE ALL OF THIS IS WHY THIS IS
A SUBJECT THAT'S FRANKLY I THINK
BETTER.
BETTER DEALT WITH OUTSIDE OF
AREA.
A HEARING LIKE THIS BUT WE'RE
HERE I VOTED FOR THIS LAST TIME --
I'M NOT SURE WHERE I WANT TO GO
BUT I DO WANT TO HEAR FROM BOTH
SIDES.
ON WHAT ACTUALLY HAPPENED
BECAUSE WE HEARD THAT CSU --
ELIMINATED -- THIS BENEFIT
OUTSIDE OF BARGAINING -- AND NOW
EVERYBODY ELSE HAS IT.
ON SO IF THAT'S ALL THE CASE
THEN THE QUESTION IS IT SEEMS TO
ME THAT THERE'S IF IFIT'S
ACCURATE THERE'S AN AND JUSTICE
THAT'S HAPPENING AND YOU'VE HAD
A YEAR NOW. TO THINK ABOUT THIS
ISSUE -- I THINK IT'S BEEN A
YEAR SINCE WE HEARD IT LAST AND
I WOULD JUST THINK YOU WOULD
HAVE SPENT SOME TIME ON IT SO
YOU COULD LIKE.
A JOKE ADDRESS -- COLLECTIVELY
ALL THOSE ISSUES ARE.
I'D VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DO SO -- WITH THE
GREATEST OF RESPECT -- THERE WAS
NOTHING WHICH WAS JUST TOLD TO
THIS COMMITTEE WHICH JACKIE'S
AYE THE STOCK HISTORICALLY
ACCURATE OR IS CURRENTLY
REFLECTS THE SITUATION IN THE C.
ISSUE.
I'VE MAIN BARGAINING THESE
CONTRACTS SINCE TWO THOUSAND SIX
I'VE BEEN THE CHIEF NEGOTIATOR
OF MULTIPLE CYCLES OF BARGAINING.
HISTORICALLY WHAT HAPPENED WAS
THAT.
IN THE MID NINETEEN NINETY IS.
THE STATE DECIDED TO CHANGE THE
WAY THAT FUNDS WERE APPROPRIATED
TO THE CSU.
PREVIOUSLY THE STATE PROVIDED
MONEY.
FOR ARTS STEPPING INCREASES AND
THAT WAS PART OF THE C. ISSUES
BUDGET.
THE STATE MOVED AWAY AND GAVE US
A BLOCK AMOUNTS OF MONEY AND
SAID YOU CSU NOW DECIDE HOW YOU
SPEND THAT MONEY.
SO WE NEGOTIATED WITH ALL UNIONS
TO MOVE AWAY FROM.
WHAT GENERALLY COULD BE COLD
STEP SYSTEM EVEN THOUGH IT WILL
HE DIDN'T LOOK ANYTHING LIKE
STATE CIVIL SERVICE?
TOWARDS A SYSTEM OF OPEN RANGES.
NOW.
THERE WAS ONE UNION CSU A YOU.
WHO DIDN'T NEGOTIATE?
OPEN RANGES AND WE WENT THROUGH
THE STATURE TREAT IMPASSE
PROCEDURE UNDER HERE.
AND UNDER HERE AT THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS THE ABILITY
TO IMPOSE ITS LAST OFFER.
FOR THE LAST OFFER WITHIN
REASONABLE CONTEMPLATION OF THE
PARTS SO TO SAY THAT IT WAS DONE
OUTSIDE OF COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
IS TO COMPLETELY IGNORE HERO.
AND THE TERMS WHICH UNDER WHICH
WE OPERATE AS COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING.
SO SINCE THE AND ONE OF THE
REASONS WHY THE HASN'T BEEN
RANGE MOVEMENT WHICH IS WHAT
THIS REALLY AMOUNTS.
TO IS THE EVERY TIME WE HAVE
GIVEN.
SALARY INCREASES BY WAY OF
GENERAL SALARY INCREASES.
THE UNIONS HAVE PASSED.
AND DEMANDED THAT THE MINIMUM
AND A MAXIMUM OF THE RANGE IS
INCREASED BY THE SAME PERCENTAGE
OF THE G. SI.
SO WE CAN PUT HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF WE HAVE HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS IN TWENTY PLAY SALARIES.
AND THE POSITIONING RANGE HASN'T
NECESSARILY CHANGED BECAUSE THE
MINIMUM AND A MAXIMUM THROUGH
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING TO BE
INCREASED BY THE SAME PERCENTAGE.
HE WAS A A SEPARATE MECHANISM
CALLED IN RANGE PROGRESSION TO
DO INDIVIDUAL INCREASES.
AND THAT'S SOMETHING WHICH THE
CAMPUS IS DIRECTLY FUND.
SO THE SECOND PART OF THIS IS
EVERYBODY ELSE GETS MERIT SALARY
INCREASES THAT'S NOT A TIME
WHICH WE USE INCIDENT IN THE CSU.
AS FAR AS YOU THE STAFF UNITS
ARE CONCERNED THEY ALSO USE THE
IN RANGE PROGRESSION MECHANISM
IN ORDER TO DO EQUITY
ADJUSTMENTS DEAL WITH LONGEVITY.
AND DEAL WITH -- ISSUES AROUND
INVASION AND COMPRESSION -- THE
ONLY.
SALARY INCREASE WHICH IS LINKED
TO ME AND MERITS IS ACTUALLY FOR
THE M. P. P.'S WHERE THERE IS A
REQUIREMENT OF SATISFACTORY
SERVICE TO GET ANY TYPE OF
INCREASE A TOLL.
IN A YEAR BUT FOR THE OTHER
BARGAINING UNITS -- SALARIES ARE
GIVEN SO SALARY INCREASES ARE
GIVEN TO EVERYBODY WHO'S IN PAY
STATUS AT THE DATE THAT THE
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING AGREEMENT
IS RATIFIED WAR RETROACTIVELY
FAST NEGOTIATED AT THE TABLE.
SO ALL OF THIS IS SUBJECT TO
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING ALL OF
THIS IS BEING DEALT WITH.
MANY MANY TIMES OVER MULTIPLE
DAYS OVER MULTIPLE YEARS.
I'M NOT STILL REMAINS THE BEST
AND ONLY MECHANISM TO MAKE ANY
MEANINGFUL PROGRESS.
IN RELATION TO THESE SERIOUS
ISSUES WHICH WE ARE BOTH TRIED
TO FACE -- UNION AND MANAGEMENT
TO LIGHT.
THE OTHER ISSUE IS OF SOME
UNIONS HAVE NEGOTIATED A THERE'S
A USUALLY A POOL OF MONEY THAT
WE PUT INTO COMPENSATION.
AND THE UNION.
OF SOME UNIONS HAVE CHOSEN TO
SPLIT THAT UP SO THAT LOWER PAID
EMPLOYEES LECTURERS ARE A FACTOR
OF FACULTY.
CAN'T GET COMPETITION.
THIS IS QUESTION ABOUT
DISTRIBUTION WE KNOW TO GET WE
WE BARGAINED ESSENTIALLY THE
SIZE OF THE POOL IN DOLLAR TERMS
OR IN PERCENTAGE TERMS.
AND THEN HOW IT'S DISTRIBUTED
AMONGST THE THE DIFFERENT
EMPLOYEE GROUPS.
SOME OF OUR UNIONS PARTICULARLY
THE CFA THE FACULTY HAVE BEING.
HAVE WILLING TO WORK WITH THOSE
AND COME UP WITH DIFFERENTIAL
DISTRIBUTION MECHANISMS.
AS FAR AS I STAFF UNITS IN
PARTICULAR THE CSU YOU.
EVEN THOUGH WE'VE PRESENTED THEM
WITH PROPOSALS WHICH WOULD
ADDRESS EQUITY ISSUES WHICH
WOULD AGGRESSIVE RECRUITMENT AND
RETENTION ON EACH AND EVERY
OCCASION THE UNION HAS DEMANDED
THAT THE MONEY BE DISTRIBUTED BY
WAY OF GENERAL SALARY INCREASE.
SO WE DO BARGAIN THESE THINGS
BUT ULTIMATELY IT'S BEEN THE
UNION THAT DEMANDED THE
EVERYBODY GETS THE SAME
PERCENTAGE BECAUSE THAT'S
POLITICALLY.
WHAT THEY CAN GET RATIFIED SO TO
HEAR THAT THE CSU IS NOT BEEN
SEEKING TO DO THIS IS AN
ABSOLUTE -- FAILURE TO RECOGNIZE
WHAT WE HAVE DONE ON THE
PROPOSALS WHICH WE HAVE MADE IN
WHICH WE CONTINUE TO MAKE.
BOTH OUTSIDE OF BARGAINING WHICH
WILL MAKE IN THE NEXT BARGAINING
CYCLE.
I MAY I THINK HE DID HIGHLIGHTED
A POINT WHICH IS HERE UP HERE A
IS GEARED TOWARDS THE EMPLOYER
IT PUTS US US THE EMPLOYEES AT A
DISADVANTAGE BECAUSE WE ARE
REQUIRED TO TAKE.
THE LAST BEST AND FINAL AND IN
THIS CASE IT UNILATERALLY WE SAY
IT UNILATERALLY BECAUSE WE DID
NOT AGREE TO IT WAS A LAST BEST
AND FINAL WHEN WE WERE STUCK
WITH THE STEPS REMOVED.
FROM OUR MEMBERS NOW SINCE THEN
THEY'VE NEGOTIATED VARIOUS OTHER
FORMS THAT HAVE NOT BEEN
SUCCESSFUL IN ARE NOT TO THE
SAME CALIBER AND THAT'S
PROBLEMATIC IN PART WHEN THE
SALARY STEPS ARE.
INCREASING REFLECTING COLA BUT
WE HAVE A MEMBER THAT'S WORK FOR
FIFTY THREE YEARS IS ONLY
HALFWAY THROUGH THE SALARY RANGE
I DON'T KNOW IF WORKING MORE
THAN HALF A CENTURY.
SHOULDN'T YOU TOWARDS THE MAX
RANGE BUT I THINK THAT'S HIGHLY
PROBLEMATIC TO REFLECT ON
ACTUALLY SIX SIX OF OUR SIXTEEN
THOUSAND MEMBERS ARE IN THE HIGH
END OF THE RANGE.
THERE'S NO CONVERSATION THAT
HAPPENS AT THE NEGOTIATING TABLE
I ACTUALLY HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF
MEETING YOU WHEN I WAS AN INTERN
DURING NEGOTIATED AND HE IS VERY
TOUGH.
BUT HE WAS NOT NEGOTIATED ON
THIS SO I JUST WANT TO HIGHLIGHT
THAT WE ARE TALKING ABOUT HERE
UP WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT
TRADITIONAL COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING IT IS A LITTLE BIT OF
A BIASED -- ARGUMENT THAT WE
HAVE TO TALK ABOUT CLICK THE
BARGAINING WERE UNDER A
DIFFERENT SYSTEM.
I JUST WANT BY FINAL PARTS OF
STEP TO THE CHAIR NOT MAKE
MISTER CHAIR OF TWENTY SECOND.
I'M GOING TO CONTINUE TO LOOK
TOWARDS THE MEMBERS OF THE
MEMBERS HAVE QUESTIONS YEAH I I
DO HAVE SOME QUESTIONS IN THE
COMMENT BUT IF I GO THIS IS
HELPFUL FOR ME OKAY.
QUESTION YEAH BUT IF YOU IF YOU
WANNA RESPOND GO AHEAD CERTAINLY
AND AND THIS THIS GOES. TO
REMEMBER THIS -- POINTS ABOUT
THE THE TYPES OF EMPLOYEES HERE
IF YOU EXCLUDE MP PAYS THE
MANAGERS AND THE FACULTY.
I WAS JUST CHECKING WE'RE
LOOKING AT A RANGE OF EMPLOYEES
WHO AT A MINIMUM -- THE MINIMUM
THE SALARY RANGE WILL BE TWO
THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED DOLLARS PER
MONTH.
AND THEN THE MAXIMUM OF THE
HIGHEST RANGE WILL BE TWENTY ONE
THOUSAND EIGHT HUNDRED DOLLARS
PER MONTH.
SO WE'RE NOT JUST LOOKING AT
PEOPLE AT THE BOTTOM AND WE HAVE
A LOT OF INDIVIDUALS PARTICULAR
IN THE I. T. AND YOU KNOW THE
BARKING UNITS HAVE BEEN PAID
VERY GOOD SIX FIGURE SALARIES.
AND THIS BILL WOULD GIVE THEM
50% INCREASE FOR TEN YEARS JUST
THE SAME AS THE GROUNDS KEEPERS
IN THE CUSTODIANS IN THE FOOD
SERVICE WORKERS.
IT'S A BLUNT INSTRUMENT IT
DOESN'T DEAL WITH THE PROBLEM IT
JUST MAKES IT WORSE.
IF THANK YOU MISTER TURN ALL OF
YOUR CHANCE RESPOND BECAUSE THIS
IS HELPFUL FOR ME AND I I I WILL
CONFESS I'M -- I'M STRUGGLING A
LOT WITH THIS I FIND MYSELF IN A
VERY SIMILAR POSITION TO MISTER
BLOOM -- AND AND AND TRYING TO
SORT THROUGH SOME OF THIS I
GUEST -- HAVE A A NUMBER OF
COMMENTS FOR JUST A FEW
QUESTIONS FOR THE AUTHORED
WANTED -- TO THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING FOR THIS BILL AND FOR
FOR ALL OF YOUR SERVICE AND MY
MY GRANDFATHER WAS -- IN A PLAY
THE CSU SYSTEM FOR SEVERAL
DECADES AND SO JUST WANTED TO
THANK THE IN PLACER HERE TODAY I
KNOW YOU GUYS DO --
EXTRAORDINARY WORKING A LOT HE
PUT YOUR HEART AND YOUR SOUL
INTO SERVING OUR STUDENTS AND
AND CREATING A BETTER FUTURE FOR
OUR STATE SO I DID WANT.
TO START WITH THAT -- I GUESS MY
QUESTIONS ARE WHY -- AND I'M
JUST -- LOOKING AT THE THE
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
I'M JUST TRYING TO UNDERSTAND MY
THINKING ABOUT THE MANDATE THAT
CSU MUCH USE EXISTING RESOURCES
TO PAY FOR THE ON GOING 5% OF
WHAT THE THINKING IS BEHIND THAT.
SURE SO -- MR GABRIEL GREAT
QUESTION -- WE SOLVE THIS FUND
OF MONEY -- AS MUCH AS A MISSED
MARTINEZ WANTS TO CLAIM THAT IT
IS EARMARKED MONEY -- AND
ACTUALLY THAT HAS TRANSITIONED
OVER TIME TO LAST YEAR IT
STARTED OUT HIS EARMARKED MONEY.
AND ABOUT LESS THAN 45% IS THERE
MARKED BASED ON USER FEES THEY
STAY WITHIN THE FUND THE
REQUIRED USE FOR THOSE PROGRAMS
WE'LL SEE WHAT THE ART IT SAYS
MAY ABOUT THE PARKING PROGRAM
BUT THAT'S THE INTENT.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE DOCUMENT
SIGNED BY CHANCELLOR WHITE.
YOU'LL SEE AN ENDING ITEM CALLED
CSU OPERATIONS THAT IS COMPRISED
MAINLY OF STUDENT TUITION.
AS WELL AS SALARY SAVINGS THE
STATE COMPTROLLER TELLS US I
DON'T KNOW WHO INTRODUCED
TALKING TO IN THE STATE
COMPTROLLER THEY'RE TELLING US.
THIS IS THE ONGOING
DISCRETIONARY MONEY.
ONGOING DISCRETIONARY MONEY SO
WE SAW THAT WE SAID WELL.
WE DON'T WANT TO PUT ANY
PRESSURE FOR FEE INCREASES OR
ANYTHING WE JUST WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THIS MONEY.
WHICH SHOULD HAVE BEEN USED FOR
THIS PURPOSE IS USED FOR THIS
PURPOSE AND THAT'S WHY WE PUT
THE LANGUAGE IN ABOUT THE A
USING USING THE EXISTING BUDGET.
MISTER SCHWARTZ BRECK.
THE SALARY WISE -- TWO THOUSAND
THIRTEEN THIS MAN WAS MAKING TWO
HUNDRED AND TWENTY THREE
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR. FIVE
YEARS LATER HE'S MAKING TWO
HUNDRED AND SIXTY NINE THOUSAND
DOLLARS YEAR I'VE GOT JANITORS
THAT WOULD LOVE TO TAKE THAT
INCREASE AS AN ANNUAL INCOME.
AND THEN FINALLY JUST TO CLARIFY
SOME HISTORY BECAUSE I THINK
THAT'S REALLY BEEN
MISREPRESENTED BY MR.
CHORE BRICKS COMMENTS. NINETEEN
NINETY TO LOBBY BE IN THE
DOCUMENTS WE HAVE PILES OF THEM.
NINETY NINETEEN DO YOU NINETEEN
NINETY TO THE CSU SAID WE'RE NOT
GOING TO PAY YOUR STEP THAT WAS
IN THE CONTRACT.
WE TOOK A THE PURPOSE AN
APPELLATE COURT RULED FOUR YEARS
LATER THAT THE CSU VIOLATED THE
CONTRACT ORDER THE CSU TO
COMPENSATE FOR THOUSAND
EMPLOYEES AT THE TIME IT WAS ONE
OF THE LARGEST PAY OUTS THAT
PERMIT EVER.
HAD EVER DEALT WITH.
WHAT DID SEE IF YOU DO THAT YEAR?
NINETEEN NINETY SIX THEY KNEW
THAT THERE WAS A COURT CASE
COMING OUT IN MARCH OF NINETEEN
NINETY SIX THE UNILATERALLY
IMPOSED AND TOOK OUT STEPS.
SO WHEN THE COURT.
CAME OUT WITH THIS DECISION IN
DECEMBER OF NINETEEN NINETY SIX
WE COULDN'T APPLY IT TO THE
ACTION.
OF REMOVING STEP BECAUSE IT ONLY
APPLIED TO THE PRIOR ACTION OF
NOT PAYING FOR STEPS.
AND COMPENSATING OUR EMPLOYEES
THROUGH.
NINETEEN NINETY SIX SO THEY'VE
BEEN PLAYING GAMES WITH THIS.
WITH THESE EMPLOYEES -- I DON'T
KNOW ANY STATE AGENCY THAT HAS A
MULTI BILLION DOLLAR FUND.
AGAIN THEY START OUT BY SAYING
IF YOU'RE MARKED LESS THAN HALF
OF THAT MONEY THEN THEY SAID IT
WAS ONE TIME MONEY MR GABRIEL.
SO WE WENT TO THE BOARD OF
TRUSTEES WITH THIS DOCUMENT.
AND SAID LET'S TALK TO THE BOARD
OF TRUSTEES WE PRESENTED TO THE
BOARD OF TRUSTEES CHANCELLOR
WHITE ON FILM IS SHAKING HIS
HEAD LIKE THIS.
BECAUSE THEY'RE ALL LOOKING AT
HIM GOING DO WE HAVE A SLUSH
FUND HE'S.
SO THEY COME BACK AND TELL ME I
SAID WELL THAT'S RIDICULOUS WE
HAVE A DOCTOR WITH HIS SIGNATURE
ON IT LET'S MAIL THIS TO THE
BOARD OF TRUSTEE MEMBERS.
SO WE DID. FOUR DAYS LATER MR
GABRIEL FOUR DAYS LATER.
CHANCE FOR WHITE COMES OUT IN
THE PRESENCE AS WE ARE NOT GOING
TO PURSUE A STUDENT TUITION
INCREASE THIS YEAR.
WHY BECAUSE WE HAVE A MULTI
BILLION DOLLAR SURPLUS?
HE'S NOT GOING TO SEE THAT
THAT'S ONE TIME ON YOUR YOUR
MARK MONEY THAT IS MONEY AS
DISCRETIONARY ONGOING FIND AT
THE STATE COMPTROLLER HAS THAT
EXIST.
THE MONEY TO PAY FOR STEP FOR
ONE YEAR. 4% OF THAT FUND.
OF THE DISCRETIONARY MONEY.
SO WE THINK WHAT THEY WERE DOING
RIGHT NOW IS IS IS CLEARLY IN
AND JUSTICE. TO THESE EMPLOYEES.
TO THE POINT OF THE STRING PEAS
I KNOW I'M SORRY FOR SPEAKING
OUT OF TURN I JUST WANNA MAKE
SURE YOU UNDERSTAND THAT THAT
WAS STATUTORILY GIVEN TO US THAT
AUTHORITY WAS STATUTORILY GIVEN
TO US TO COLLECTORS FEES.
TYPICALLY WE DO IS WE SPENT.
THE OF THESE GENERAL FUND
DOLLARS FIRST NAME KEEPS FROM
THE STUDENT FEES SECOND.
I WANT TO POINT OUT TO YOU IN
THE DEPTHS OF THE DEEPEST
DARKEST HOURS OF THE LOWER THE
BUDGET NOT THAT LONG AGO ABOUT
FOUR FIVE YEARS AGO.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ASKED US
THE ASKED US TO LEND THEM MONEY
TO KEEP THE STATE A FLOAT SO
THIS IS NOT TOP SECRET MONEY
THIS IS MONEY THAT THE
LEGISLATURE AND GET THE GOVERNOR
AND FINANCE ARE AWARE OF SO I
JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THAT YOUR
STAMINA.
AND IF I MASON ARE REALISTIC
COUNTIES CLEARANCE TRANSPARENT
AS WELL AS THE THIS THE REASONS
WHY IT'S KEPT IN THE SOURCES OF
MONEY FROM WHERE IT COMES IN THE
REASONS WHY WE NEED THOSE MONIES
IN VISITS.
THANK YOU FOR THAT NIGHT JUST
ONE OTHER QUESTION FOR THE
AUTHOR WHICH IS -- JUST AT THE
ABOUT THE 5% NUMBER HOW YOU
ARRIVED AT THAT.
THAT'S BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT THE
NORMAL STEP WAS I MEAN THERE WAS
A 5% STEP INCREASE BETWEEN THE
VARIOUS LEVELS OF EMPLOYMENT IF
YOU CAME IN A CERTAIN LEVEL THE
NEXT STEP WAS 5% 5% DEPENDING
UPON YOUR EVALUATIONS NOT DONE
EVERY YEAR.
AND DEPENDING UPON WHAT THE
MONIES AVAILABLE AND ALSO WITH
THE NOT TO GET A RECOMMENDATION.
SO IT'S NOT AN AUTOMATIC THING
THAT HAPPENS IS ONE OF THE FEW
THINGS THAT REALLY IS AMERICA
JUST WENT WITH IT HAS TO BE
ASSESSMENT AND EVALUATION OF THE
INDIVIDUAL.
BUT THAT WAS STANDARD AT THE
UNIVERSITY AND STILL IS YEAH.
YOU HAVE TO THE JUST TO SAY
MISTER GABER WE WOULD LOVE TO
NEGOTIATE THIS VAST FOR OVER
TWENTY YEARS TO PUT THIS ON THE
TABLE.
I'VE GOT A QUOTE I'M HAPPY TO
REVIEW THAT WAS FROM NOTES FROM
ONE OF THE SESSIONS -- THE
BASICALLY SAID YOUR EMPLOYEES
CAN ROT IN HELL BEFORE WE DO
STEPS AGAIN.
THAT'S NOT RESPECTFUL AT ALL --
IN.
IN THOSE NEGOTIATIONS -- WE
WOULD LOVE TO SIT AND TALK ABOUT
IT UNFORTUNATELY WE CAN'T DO IT
UNTIL WERE MADE WHOLE AND THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE ASKING 45% WERE
SAYING LISTEN YOU YOU'VE ACCRUED
ALL THIS MONEY FOR ALL THIS TIME
IT.
OKAY BUT FROM THIS POINT ON WE
WANT TO BE MADE WHOLE.
GET US TO WHERE WE WERE AND THEY
WERE HAPPY TO SIT DOWN AND DO
NEGOTIATIONS COLLECTIVE BARGAIN
THE WAY IT WAS INTENDED TO BE.
THIS WAS NOT DONE THROUGH
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING IT WAS
SUBVERTED.
AND WE WERE IN THIS POSITION
THAT WE WOULD NOT BE COMING TO
YOU IF THIS WAS SOMETHING THAT
WE HAD NEGOTIATED OR JUST MADE A
BAD DECISION.
MR SANTIAGO START TONIGHT I
MISSED MR CHECK I MAKE A FEW
COMMENTS IS THAT OKAY.
WITH YOUR WITH YOUR PERMISSION
I'LL BE VERY BRIEF -- SO SIR
THANK YOU FOR THAT I I AM A THAT
THE REASON I'M STRUGGLING THIS
IS I'M.
HAVE A A PRINCIPLE OUT THERE
THAT I THINK -- YOU THINK THE
THE THE AUTHORS ACKNOWLEDGED
WHICH IS THAT I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THINGS THAT OUGHT TO
BE PART OF THE COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING PROCESS ARE PART OF
THE COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
PROCESS I THINK IT'S REALLY
REALLY IMPORTANT WE DON'T CREATE
A PRECEDENT.
THAT WOULD FOLKS DON'T GET WHAT
THEY WANT IN THE PROCESS EITHER
ON EITHER SIDE THAT THEY COME TO
LEGISLATURE BECAUSE WE ARE NOT
SUITED TO REFEREE THOSE
DISCUSSIONS.
THOSE ARE BEST LEFT TO THE
BARGAINING UNITS TO THE
UNIVERSITY TO HAVE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS AND I I'M GLAD TO
HEAR YOU ACKNOWLEDGE THAT DOCTOR
EVER I THINK THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT.
HAVE YOU THAT I SURE I THINK I
HEARD MY COLLEAGUE FROM SANTA
MONICA SAY THAT AS WELL SO I
THINK THAT'S AN IMPORTANT POINT.
THE FLIP SIDE OF THAT IS IT
SEEMS TO ME FROM WHAT I CAN
GATHER HERE THERE DOESN'T EVEN
SEEM TO BE.
A BASIC AGREEMENT ON THE FACTS
BUT FROM WHAT I GATHER THERE'S A
REAL AND SIGNIFICANT INJUSTICE
YEAR IT SEEMS TOUGH PERSISTED
FOR TWO DECADES IT SEEMS THAT
THERE'S A GROUP OF EMPLOYEES
THAT ARE BEING TREATED.
DIFFERENTLY FROM ANY OTHER CLASS
OF EMPLOYEES ACROSS THE
UNIVERSITY AND REALLY IT'S BEEN
REPRESENTED TO ME ACROSS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND SO -- AND AND EVERYTHING THE
DOCTOR WEBER SAID ABOUT THIS
BEING TAKEN AWAY FROM FOLKS
OUTSIDE OF THE COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING PROCESS -- IS VERY
CONCERNING TO ME SO WHAT I'M
STRUGGLING WITH IS THIS GENERAL
PRINCIPLE THAT I HAVE THAT'S A
VERY IMPORTANT ONE TO ME -- AND
ALSO THIS DISCRETE SET OF FACTS
WHICH ALSO APPEARS TO BE VERY
VERY TROUBLING TO ME -- SO
WANTED TO TO TO THANK DR WEBER
FRONT FOR FOR FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL I WANT TO THANK THE THE
FOLKS ARE COMING UP IN
TESTIFYING ABOUT IT FOR BRING IT
TO OUR ATTENTION.
I WILL SAY TO THE THE FOLKS IN
THE CSU I CONSIDER MYSELF ONE OF
THE FOREMOST PROPONENTS OF
HIGHER EDUCATION THE STATE I
THINK THAT WE ARE DRAMATICALLY
UNDER FUNDING HIGHER EDUCATION.
I WANT TO DO EVERYTHING I CAN TO
INCREASE FUNDING FOR HER
EDUCATION BUT ALSO SEEMS TO ME
THAT YOU ARE MISS PERCEIVING
WHERE THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
GOVERNOR ARE ARE A PRIOR
GOVERNOR ON THIS ISSUE I WENT
BACK AND READ.
GOVERNOR BROWN TO VETO MESSAGE
ON A PRIOR VERSION OF THIS BILL
YOU SAW THE OVERWHELMING VOTE
FOR THIS A PRIVATIZATION IN THIS
LEGISLATURE SO CLEARLY FOLKS ARE --
UPSET ABOUT THE CURRENT STATUS
CIRCUMSTANCES -- THE AND AND AND
I WOULD YOU KNOW ENCOURAGE YOU
TO GO BACK AND READ THAT
LANGUAGE AND UNDERSTAND WHERE
FOLKS ARE IN THE LATEST TRYING
THIS MEAN CLEARLY IT'S A
BIPARTISAN ISSUE THAT FOLKS ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT HOW YOUR
COMPENSATING THESE EMPLOYEES.
AND I WOULD REALLY ENCOURAGE YOU
TO THINK ABOUT THAT TRYING TO GO
SHEET THAT ISSUE BECAUSE THAT'S
HOW IT NEEDSTO BE DONE WHEN
THERE'S A REFUSAL TO NEGOTIATE
WE END UP IN THESE.
THESE TYPE OF SITUATIONS SO
THOSE ARE MY COMMENTS AND
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY SHARE
THEM THANK YOU MISTER SANTIAGO.
YES THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MISTER CHAIR THIS IS ONE OF
THOSE BILLS WERE THAT YOU WISH A
ONE AWAY BECAUSE THERE'S NO NEED
FOR IT BECAUSE IT WAS ALL TAKEN
CARE OF THE CONTRACT.
NEGOTIATION TABLES AND I WAS
MENTIONING THE AUTHOR EARLIER
YOU KNOW.
THAT THAT THAT YOU KNOW I I KIND
OF FEEL CONFLICTED COMPLETED IN
THE SENSE THAT.
DOING CONTRACT NEGOTIATIONS HERE
IT IS IS A BIT OF A CHALLENGE
HOWEVER HOWEVER WHEN CONTRACT
NEGOTIATIONS BREAKS DOWN THIS IS
THE POINT WHERE WE TRY TO
ENCOURAGE AND PUSH IT.
THE END WE HOPE THAT SOMETHING
FAIR WOULD COME I DON'T THINK
IT'S A IT'S A GOOD PRESENCE
BECAUSE YOU CAN GIVE A THING YOU
CAN TAKE IT.
AND THAT THAT IS ALSO A
CHALLENGING SITUATION I'M TO GET
A BETTER UNDERSTANDING.
OF WHAT ACTUALLY IS THE ISSUE
NOW AND AND I SAY THAT BECAUSE I
HAVEN'T BEEN ON A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE FOR THE PAST WE WENT
THROUGH SOME OF THE SIMILAR
CONVERSATIONS RIGHT WHERE YOU
HAVE AN EMPLOYEE WHO HAS BEEN
THERE TWENTY FIVE YEARS --
BECAUSE RACES WERE HELD BACK OR
OR NOT HAPPENING IN A CERTAIN
PERIOD IN TIME INSURGENTS MAY BE
A LITTLE BIT A LITTLE BIT LONGER
THAN THEN YOU'D WHICH FOR BUT
YOU GIVE ME FULLER DATA.
GO BACK AND FORTH THAT I
APPRECIATE THAT BUT SO YOU MAY
HAVE EMPLOYEES BUT TWENTY FIVE
YEARS TEN YEARS -- WAGED AN
INCREASE FOR A CERTAIN PERIOD OF
TIME -- DOING MARKET THE OR
SALARY SURVEYS APPOINT TIME WAIT
JUST COME UP ON THE USUALLY MADE
OF WITH SOME COMPARABLE SORT OF
WORK FORCE AND EXPERIENCE AND
AND TIME RIGHT.
AND SO YOU GET EMPLOYEES TO COME
IN AND MAKE A HIGHER WAGE -- IN
MY MY QUESTION IS ASSEMBLY IN
TIME.
WHAT PREVENTS IT WHAT WHAT'S
PREVENTING YOUR SIDE FROM
ACTUALLY GETTING TO ACE A
STELLAR THE SALARY STEP -- A
PROPOSAL THAT ADDRESSES SOME OF
THOSE ISSUES COULD.
THAT DOES BECOME A PROBLEM NOW
VERY DIFFERENT THIS YES YOU
COULD DON'T HAVE A CSU NEXT DOOR
THAT COMPETES TO YOU.
UP IT'S PROBABLY THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES PREVALENT THAN A AND
ANY PUBLIC AGENCY WILL BE LAW
ENFORCEMENT OR WHAT HAVE YOU BUT
THIS SEEMS TO BE A AN
OVERWHELMING PROBLEM.
AND CURES LIKE WHAT IS REALLY AT
THE CRUX OF THE U. PREVENTING
FROM DOING SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
SATCHER I'LL TRY AND BE SIMPLE --
THIS IS ONE OF THOSE THINGS
WHICH YOU CAN ONLY MAKE SO
SIMPLE.
BUT ESSENTIALLY IT'S LIKE TRYING
TO BOLT ON A PIECE FROM THE FORD
ON TWO CHEVY AND EXPECTING IT TO
WORK.
WE HAVE AN OPEN RANGE SYSTEM.
WE WOULD HAVE TO COMPLETELY RE
ENGINEER ALL THE CLASSIFICATIONS
AND THEN PLACE EVERY SINGLE
EMPLOYEE.
IN A NEWS AGNEW RANGE FOR THAT
CLASSIFICATION TO GET SOMETHING
SIMILAR. TO WHAT HAPPENS IN
STATE CIVIL SERVICE.
THEY HAVE SOME VERY NARROW
RANGES WE HAVE RANGES WHICH GO I
DIDN'T 50% OF THE MINIMUM.
EMPLOYEES OBVIOUSLY WOULD WANT
NOT TO BE.
PUT DOWN TO BE PLACED ON A STEP
THEY DON'T WANT TO PLACE THE
FASTEST THE NATURAL RESPONSE.
THE INITIAL COST TO DOING THAT
WOULD BE EXTREMELY EXPENSIVE.
THIS ISSUE IS IS RANGE MOVEMENT
AND AND NO AND I UNDERSTAND YOU
WOULD IF YOU HIRED SOMEBODY
LET'S SAY TEN BUT I'M GONNA USE
NUMBERS THAT DON'T REALLY EXIST
RIGHT BUT AT TEN BUCKS A YEAR.
THAT ARE COMING IN AND PEOPLE
WHO HAVE BEEN WORKING THERE FOR
THIRTY YEARS AT AT TWO BOOKS
YEARS CERTAINLY WOULD EXPECT
THOSE AT TEN YEAR AND INSTEAD OF
SAYING AT TEN YEARS.
WHEN YOU DO A SATELLITE I'D
RESURFACE A SUPPLE THE SAUDIS GO
YOU WOULD EXPECT THE NEW HIRES
TO COME BACK DOWN THEY HAVE TO
STAY WHERE THEY'RE AT?
BUT BUT I THINK THERE IS A THERE
IS A WAY TO CONTACT NEGOTIATIONS
TO BEGIN.
THAT PROCESS WHEN WE DID IT WE
CALL THE BUDGET ALLOCATION MODEL
AND IT WAS GIVEN OVER A CERTAIN
AMOUNT OF YEARS WHERE WE ALIGNED --
A PRESIDENT TO A CAMPUS TO A
CERTAIN AMOUNT OF DEAN'S TO
POPULATION AND START
STANDARDIZING THAT FORMAT ALONG
THE ROAD WHEN WE WERE DOING THAT
WE WERE ALSO TAKE A LOOK AT
SALARY SURVEYS -- WITHIN THE
REGION TO TAKE TO TO ACCOUNT NO
YOU CAN'T DO THIS OVERNIGHT I
GET THAT AND AND EVEN IF WE
WANTED TO TAKE CARE OF ALL THOSE
THINGS THAT THE CONTRACT
NEGOTIATION TABLE.
IT WOULD ALMOST BE IMPOSSIBLE TO
TAKE CARE OF THAT ONE PARTICULAR
ISSUE AT ONE TIME.
BUT BUT THERE CAN BE EVEN IF
EVEN IF YOU WERE TO SAY LOOK WE
CAN'T DO IT NOW.
IS THERE STEPS OVER A CERTAIN
AMOUNT OF YEARS THEY GET YOU TO
A POINT SO YOU'RE NOT FACING
THIS THIRTY YEARS TONIGHT I FACE
IN THIS TEN YEARS FROM NOW.
THAT WOULD BE A REASONABLE STEP
FORWARD IN THIS CONVERSATION TO
AT LEAST THE LINE -- THOSE
SALARIES -- WITH EXPERIENCE --
EXPERIENCE -- THAT WOULD MATCH
UP TO A NEW SALARY SCALE.
SIR I AM PLEASED TO TELL YOU
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT WE'VE BEEN
DOING OVER THE PAST SEVERAL
YEARS.
HAVE MANY OF OUR CAMPUSES CAMPUS
PRESIDENTS OF ALLOCATED SPECIFIC
POTS OF MONEY.
IN ORDER TO DO ACROSS THE BOARD
CAMPUS EQUITY PROGRAMS SOME OF
THOSE HAVE BEEN TAKING PEOPLE UP
TO COURT HOUSE BASED ON
LONGEVITY OF SERVICE.
OTHERS OF LOOKED ACROSS TO MAKE
SURE THAT THERE'S NO INVASION
COMPRESSION.
CAMPUSES OF SPEND VERY VERY
HEAVILY TO DO THIS FROM CAMPUS
FUNDS TO TO TRYING TO ADDRESS
THESE ISSUES -- WILL WE HAVE
BEEN TRYING IN COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING TO USE THE IN RANGE
PROGRESSION.
ALSO TO MEET THOSE SAME.
GOALS AND OBJECTIVES AND OVER
THE LAST THREE TO FOUR YEARS
WE'VE SAME AND BOTH THE NUMBER
AND AMOUNTS OF THOSE IN RANGE
PROGRESSIONS SUBSTANTIALLY
INCREASE IT IS THAT WE HAVE BEEN
ADDRESSING IT.
MISTER CHAIR.
IS THERE AN ESTIMATED TIME IN
YOUR IN YOUR WORLD YOUR POINT OF
VIEW IS AN ESTIMATED TIME WHERE
THIS WOULD BE ADDRESSED RIGHT BE
TEN YEARS LIKE WHAT WE DID IT WE
KNEW THAT THERE WAS THREE PHASE.
THREE PHASES WHAT HAPPENED OVER
FIVE YEARS IN IN IF NOT THAT
WOULD BE GIVEN AN EXTRA YEAR TO
WRITE.
SO IT IF IT THE I ASSUME YOU
WANT TO DO IT AT THE CSU LEVEL
NOT AFFECT NOT AT THE CAMPUS
LEVEL BUT IT BUT HAVING SAID
THAT -- WHAT RANGY YEARS?
IN YOUR WORLD VIEW DO YOU THINK
THAT THOSE.
THAT THAT THOSE EQUITY ISSUES
WOULD BE BECOME ADDRESSED AND
THEN I WANT TO ASK YOU THE OTHER
SIDE TOO BUT I'M CURIOUS AS TO
WHAT YOU THINK ABOUT THAT.
IF SIR I MENTIONED WE'VE HAD
WE'VE GOT A MEETING OF A THE
UNION AND ADMINISTRATION TO TALK
ABOUT SALARY STRUCTURE.
THE PROPOSAL IS OVER THE COURSE
OF THE NEXT YEAR WE'LL COME UP
WITH SOME JOINT RECOMMENDATIONS
AND TAKE THOSE RECOMMENDATIONS
INTO BARGAINING.
SO THE IDEA THAT WE'RE NOT.
ONLY WILLING TO TALK ABOUT THIS
IN COLLECTIVE BARGAINING BUT
ALSO THE FACT THAT WE'RE TALKING
THIS OFF CYCLE BECAUSE WE
RECOGNIZE THIS IS A NOW ISSUE.
RATHER THAN PUTTING OFF I THINK
YOU SHOULD GIVE THIS COMMITTEE
SOME REASSURANCE OF THE SEA
ISSUE IS TRYING TO ADDRESS THIS.
IT WILL TAKE MULTIPLE YEARS.
IF THE OBJECTIVE IS TO GET
EVERYBODY EQUAL OR DIFFERENTIAL
BUT AS YOU POINTED OUT WE WE ARE
DRIVEN BY MARKET FORCES.
WHEN WE HIRE PEOPLE SAN DIEGO
SAN JOSE SAN FRANCISCO IN A
BOOMING ECONOMY WE HAVE TO PAY
MARKET SALARIES?
AND THEN WHAT WE ENCOURAGE ALL
OUR CAMPUSES TO DO ALL THEIR
HATE SHODDY POINT MINUTES IS
LOOK AT THE SORRY OF THAT NEW
HIRE LOOK AT THE CLASSIFICATION.
AND USE THE IN RANGE PROGRESSION
MECHANISM TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE ARE NO IT.
OR THE INEQUITIES A MITIGATED OR
READY KATE.
SO ALL OF THESE.
PROCESSES IN RANGE PROGRESSION
CAMPUS EQUITY PROGRAMS I WILL BE
AN EMPLOYEE NOW. TO ADDRESS
THESE ISSUES.
IN THE FUTURE OF A NIGHT.
WRAP IT UP YES.
BUT IT ON ON BEING ON YOUR SIDE
OF AT ONE POINT IN TIME WE ALSO
KNEW THAT OVER A CERTAIN AMOUNT
OF YEARS.
BY DEFAULT THE AGE AND LONGEVITY
THROUGH THE DISTRICT THERE'D BE
A CERTAIN AMOUNT OF PEOPLE THAT
WOULD NO LONGER BE THERE BY THE
TIME WE GOT THE LAST PHASE SO WE
ALWAYS KNEW THAT THERE BE A
CERTAIN SAVINGS A DOLLARS.
IF WE PUT A SALARY.
A SKILL TOGETHER BECAUSE THE BY
THE TIME WE GOT THERE ARE SOME
OF THOSE PEOPLE WOULD NEVER MAKE
IT TO TO A CERTAIN SCALE.
BUT BECAUSE RETIREMENT ISSUES.
SO SO THOSE NUMBERS AREN'T
REALLY APPLE THE APPLE NUMBERS
RIGHT BECAUSE AT THE END OF THE
DAY THERE'S SOME POPULATION THAT
YOU KNOW OVER.
TIME IS GONNA MAKE IT TO THE HOW
TO THE HEIGHTS OURS SCALE ANYHOW.
THE END ON TALK ABOUT THOSE
EMPLOYEES HAVE BEEN THERE FOR A
LONG PERIOD OF TIME.
NO ONE ASKED IF I WANT ONE MORE
QUESTION I KNOW ONE DUDE.
THE OTHER SIDE.
WHY ARE THEY NOT SEEING THE SAME
WHAT WOULD THEY DO NOT SEE THE
SAME THING?
HI I AGREE WITH SOME OF THE
COMMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN MADE
HERE THAT THIS IS NOT THE BEST
PLACE FOR NEGOTIATION.
AND THIS IS SHOULDN'T BE
NEGOTIATION -- SO. FOR THE LIMIT
OF FOR FOR THE FOR TIMES SAY.
BECAUSE I THINK WE COULD SIT
HERE AND AND BE HERE ALL NIGHT
DISCUSSING THESE THINGS.
I I THINK THERE'S BEEN VERY GOOD
DISCUSSION POINTS WELL TAKEN
FROM BOTH SIDES OF POINTS TO BE
NOTED BY BOTH SIDES.
AND AND I WOULD IF PERMISSION
WITH THE COMMITTEE -- FOR FOR
TIME'S SAKE WE STILL HAVE A
BELIEVE TEN MORE BILLS TO HEAR --
I DIDN'T REALIZE THAT SO I
APOLOGIZE MISTER JONES GOING TO
ASK.
I WAS GONNA ASK THE PROPONENTS
OF THE BILL IS HERE'S A QUESTION
SO I APOLOGIZE AGAIN.
SO WHAT WITH THAT IF IF THE
COMMITTEE PERMITS I'M GOING TO
ASK THE AUTHOR TO CLUBS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH -- LET ME GO BACK
TO WHERE WE STARTED.
IS WHERE WE WANT IT WHERE THEY
WERE GOING TO GO THERE A LOT OF
ISSUES THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED
THAT ARE NOT WITHIN THE PURVIEW
OF THIS BILL FIRST OF ALL.
I MEAN THE WHOLE ISSUE OF TRYING
TO RE DESIGN THE ENTIRE SYSTEM
TO DEAL WITH IT.
EQUITY IN SALARIES AND PEOPLE
BEING HIRED AND ADMINISTRATORS
AND ALL THIS KIND OF THING
THAT'S NOT WHAT THIS BILL IS
ABOUT WE KNOW THAT -- THIS BILL
IS ABOUT EIGHT EIGHT A GROUP OF
OF EMPLOYEES AT THE CSU SYSTEM.
WHO HAD A A 5% OF STEP PROGRAM
TAKEN AWAY NOT BECAUSE THEY
BARGAINED FOR BUT WAS TAKEN AWAY?
AND NOW THE QUESTION BECOMES DO
WE GO BACK AND BARGAIN TO GET IT
BACK WHEN IT WAS GIVEN TO BEEN
WAS THERE'S IN THE FIRST PLACE.
IT IS NICE TO HEAR ALL OF THE
CONVERSATION ABOUT EVERYBODY
AROUND BUT THIS IS REALLY ABOUT
A SPECIFIC GROUP OF PEOPLE.
WHO WANT TO TALK ABOUT HAVING A
MERIT SALARY SYSTEM PLACE BACK
IN THE OTHER SYSTEMS OTHER
EMPLOYEES HAVE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND OTHER EMPLOYEES
HAVE A TO SEE ISSUE SYSTEM?
THAT WAS IN PLACE AND BOB EVEN
WITH THE COMMENTS MADE BY THE
GOVERNOR LAST YEAR THERE'S BEEN
NO EFFORT TO GO BACK AND HAVE
THIS CONVERSATION.
AND THE GOVERNOR WAS HESITANT
BECAUSE HE SAID THIS SHOULD BE
DONE WITHIN COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING AND MOST OF US FEEL
THAT WAY.
BUT THEY HAVE TRIED AND TRIED
AND TRIED AND SO WHEN THE
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING SYSTEM
DOESN'T COME BACK TO NEGOTIATE
THIS WHAT DO YOU DO YOU JUST SAY
WHATEVER AT SOME OF THE PEOPLE
HAVE SAID IT RETIRED AND MOVED
ON AND JUST SAY THE SYSTEM.
IS NOT GONNA WORK FOR ME OR DO
YOU BASICALLY COME TO THE FOLKS
WHO ARE SUPPOSEDLY IN CHARGE OF
THE SYSTEM WHICH IS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE AND SAY.
LOOK THIS WAS TAKEN AWAY WE
TRIED OUR BEST EVERYONE HERE
PROBABLY REALIZES THAT MOST
EMPLOYEE ORGANIZATIONS IS
SPECIAL INSTEAD OF CALIFORNIA
HAVE A MERIT.
SYSTEM BUILT INTO IT SO THAT YOU
CAN DO ASSESSMENT IN YOU CAN
EVALUATE PEOPLE AND THEY CAN GET
MARRIED JUST ONCE WE DO THAT ALL
THE TIME UP YOUR WITH OUR
EMPLOYEES.
THAT DOESN'T EXIST IN THE C.
ISSUE FOR THIS PARTICULAR GROUP
NOT FOR THE OTHERS BUT FOR THIS
PARTICULAR GROUP WHICH IS THE
LOWEST PAID LOWEST WAGE
INDIVIDUALS IN THE SYSTEM.
SO WHAT I'M ASKING IS THAT WE
BASICALLY RESTORE THAT STRUCTURE
BACK TO THEM NOW THE ISSUES OF
ALL THE VERY SALARIES AND HOW
YOU'RE GOING TO EQUITY IN HIGH
GOING TO HAVE A SYSTEM AND YOU
WILL TAKE FIVE YEARS TO BAG WITH
THIS THIS THIS THIS.
THAT IS NOT WHAT THIS BILL IS
ABOUT I WANT TO MAKE THAT VERY
VERY CLEAR WE UNDERSTOOD IT LAST
YEAR WE BASICALLY RECOGNIZE THIS
WAS A GOOD THING ON BOTH SIDES
OF THE HOUSE.
GUIDED TO THE GOVERNOR AND HE
WROTE A STATEMENT -- BECAUSE HE
WAS IN FAVOR BUT WROTE A
STATEMENT BECAUSE HE FELT
DIFFICULT MOVING INTO THAT THAT
SYSTEM HOPING THAT THEY WOULD BE
A FURTHER ALONG IN A
CONVERSATION RIGHT NOW ABOUT HOW
YOU RESTORE THE STEP INCREASES.
OF THIS MERIT STEP THIS THERE
THAT HAS NOT HAPPENED AND IT MAY
NOT HAPPEN AND PROBABLY WON'T
AND I UNDERSTAND THAT THIS.
ISSUE WAS BROUGHT THEIR TOUGHEST
NEGOTIATOR HERE BUT I WOULD
REMIND HIM HE ENTERED THE SYSTEM
IN.
TWO THOUSAND SIX THIS HAPPENED
IN NINETEEN NINETY SIX SO
WHATEVER YOU THINK ABOUT OF THE
HISTORY THAT HE READ ABOUT I OF
THE SYSTEM IN.
NINETEEN SEVENTY TWO SO I KNOW
WHAT THEY DID.
ALL THE EMPLOYEES AT ONE
PARTICULAR TIME AND I'LL HARD IT
WAS TO FIGHT TO GET BACK THE
DIGNITY OF STOP MERIT STEP
INCREASES OKAY AND AND EVERYONE
HAS BEEN ABLE TO TAKE SOME OUT
OF THE FIGURE IT OUT TO GET IT.
BUT THEY HAVE BEEN RESISTANT TO
GIVING IT TO OUR LOWEST PAID
EMPLOYEES WILL OFTEN OUR MOST
DEDICATED AND MORE COMMITTED
INDIVIDUALS WHO MAKE THE SYSTEM
WORK.
SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK BUT I BOTH
AB [inaudible]
THREE SIX NINE OUR MOTION
[inaudible]
SECOND [inaudible]
STORY -- I REMEMBER VERY WELL
LAST YEAR AS WELL.
RUSSIAN AND WE HAD A SUPPORT TO
DO YOUR H
HI I AGREE WITH THE AUTHOR.
IT IS -- UNFAIR THAT HAVE --
EMPLOYEES WHO ARE NOT BENEFITING
FROM THE SAME.
KIND OF SALARIES STATUS LIVE
UNDER.
SO I SUPPORT THE BILL I ALSO
AGREE -- ONE OF THE POINTS THAT
MR GABRIEL MADE.
THAT PERHAPS THE OTHER THINK
ABOUT REMOVING THAT ONE OF THE
PART IN THE BILL THAT IT MUST BE
FROM.
EXISTING.
RIGHT AND WE LOOK AT THAT OKAY
WE WILL DEFINITELY CONSIDER THAT
THE QUESTION WE HAVE A MOTION BY
MISTER PATTERSON.
SEC ABOUT AS WE GO TOWARD.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE MEDINA.
MEDINA I CHOI.
CHOI I JONES SAWYER HI JONES
SAWYER I'D BLOOM LEVINE.
LEVINE NOW LOW [inaudible]
PATTERSON.
PATTERSON I SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I'D WEBER HI WEBER HI
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MEMBERS A ONE THE BILL
IS OUT WE'LL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS.
THE NEXT OF I DON'T SEE MISTER
LOW HERE [inaudible]
JUDGES ME.
IS THE DO YOU THE BILL TO
PRESENT [inaudible]
OKAY.
MR BLOOM ITEM.
NINE ENJOY SUPPORT SUPPORT.
GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS ALL TRY TO MAKE QUICK
WORK OF THIS.
THIS IS A UP A BACK IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN I AUTHORED AB EIGHT A
ONE THE SUCCESS FOR HOMELESS
YOUTH AND HIGHER EDUCATION ACT
AND THAT REQUIRED ACADEMIC AND
FINANCIAL SUPPORT -- FOR
IDENTIFIED HOMELESS STUDENTS
ATTENDING A PUBLIC STATE
INSTITUTION.
THE STATUTE PROVIDED HOMELESS
YOUTH WITH PRIORITY ENROLLMENT
AND IS DESIGNATED LIAISON TO
HELP NAVIGATE THE FINANCIAL AID
PROCESS.
AND OTHER AVAILABLE SUPPORT
SERVICES FOR STUDENTS HOWEVER.
AS FREQUENTLY HAPPENS DUE TO AN
OVERSIGHT THE DEFINITION OF
HOMELESS YOUTH DID NOT CAPTURE
YOUTH ARE CURRENTLY WHO ARE
CURRENTLY ENROLLED.
AND VERIFIED IS BEING HOMELESS
FOR THESE SERVICES SO AB EIGHT
OF SEX ALIGNS THE DEFINITION OF
HOMELESS YOUTH WITH A. B..
TWELVE TWENTY EIGHT A BY MR
GIPSON IN TWENTY FIFTEEN TO
INCLUDE YOUTH WHO ARE CURRENTLY
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS.
THE BILL ALSO ELIMINATES THE
SUNSET THAT WAS IN AB EIGHT ONE
SUCH THE CURRENT AND FORMER
HOMELESS YOUTH WILL RECEIVE
PRIORITY ENROLLMENT INDEFINITELY.
LASTLY AB EIGHT OH SIX WILL.
QUALIFY CURRENTLY HOMELESS YOUTH
FOR THE PROMISE GRANT FEE WAIVER.
ADD TO IT.
MEMBERS AB EIGHT OF SIX WHAT
SURE THE LEGISLATURE IN STATE
UNIVERSITIES CONTINUE MAKING
STRIDES IN PROVIDING THE
NECESSARY SUPPORT FOR HOMELESS
YOUTH.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE.
AT ALL -- LEFT -- THEY
SUPPORTERS OF THE BILL
INTRODUCED THEMSELVES TO SAVE A
COUPLE SECONDS.
HEY ONCE AGAIN GOOD AFTERNOON
SHOW HER HIGH WITH THE
CALIFORNIA HOMELESS YOUTH
PROJECT I'LL BE VERY QUICK -- IN
LARGE PART THIS LEGISLATION
WOULD ADD CURRENTLY HOMELESS
YOUNG ADULTS TO THE PROTECTIONS
GIVEN TO FORMALLY HOMELESS
COLLEGE STUDENTS IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN AB EIGHT OH ONE
INCLUDING ACCESS TO PRIORITY
ENROLLMENT TUITION FEE WAIVERS
FINANCIALLY IT OUT REACH -- AND
ACCESS TO COLLEGE HONESTLY IS ON
ON THEIR CAMPUS.
BASED ON A REPORT RELEASED TODAY
CALIFORNIA'S COMMUNITY COLLEGE
HOMELESS LIAISONS HAVE SAID THAT
HOUSING IS THE GREATEST NEED OF
STUDENTS THEY SERVE.
FOLLOWED BY ASSISTANCE WITH CAL
FRESH HELP WITH STAFF THE
APPLICATION MENTAL HEALTH
SUPPORT AND REFERRALS TO FOR
SUPPORT OF SERVICES OFF CAMPUS.
MORE STUDENTS TO BE ABLE TO BE
ASSISTED BY THIS MEASURE AND WE
KNOW THERE'S A GREAT NEED FOR
LEGISLATION THAT WOULD
POSITIVELY IMPACT THE STUDENT
COMMUNITY.
AS WE'VE HEARD NEARLY ONE IN
FIVE COMMITTEE CAUTIONS
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS AT
SOME POINT THE PAST YEAR AND IN
DESPERATE NEED OF GREATER
SUPPORT FOR HIGHER EDUCATION
INSTITUTIONS.
HOMELESSNESS IS CYCLICAL AND
SYSTEMIC SOLUTIONS REQUIRE
PREVENTION INTERVENTION AND
AFTER CARE IN ORDER TO BE
SUCCESSFUL.
INCLUDING FORMALLY HOMELESS
YOUTH IN THESE PROVISIONS HELPS
TO RECOGNIZE AND RESPOND TO THE
TRUE NATURE OF HOUSING
INSTABILITY FOR THIS COMMUNITY.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND HAVE
IT ANSWERED QUESTIONS.
CAN LOW'S REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR YOUTH
PROUD TO BE ONE OF THE CO
SPONSORS ON THIS BILL IN AB NO
ONE FROM TWO THOUSAND AND
SIXTEEN AND IS CAMPAIGNING ELSE
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME
TODAY.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
JUSTIN SILICON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNICABLE CHANCES
OFFICE IN SUPPORT.
BRIAN ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS MY
SUPPORT.
I YOU SHE ON GOING ON BEHALF OF
THE STUDENTS IN A FOR CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES WE SUPPORT.
HI U. MENDOZA ON THE BEHALF OF
DOUBLE VALLEY COLLEGE IN SUPPORT.
DANNY THEIR FULL LEGISLATOR
FIRST RECORD REGION TWO OF THE
STINSON OF COMPANY COMMUNITY
COLLEGE IN SUPPORT.
ANGELA WILLIAMS CALIFORNIA
BLACKOUT MY WORK IN SUPPORT.
RESIDENTS ALSO BE HALF THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS IN SUPPORT.
FIRST DIRECTOR FOR REGION THREE
OF THE STUDENTS IN FOR
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
AND SUPPORT. SEVEN GOLDMAN WITH
THE FACULTY ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES IN
SUPPORT.
HEATHER JOHNSON SYSTEM AFFAIRS
DIRECTOR OF OF REGION EIGHT FOUR
SENATE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES.
SKEWS THE SENATE.
STUDENTS SENATE CALIFORNIA.
SKEWS ME THE STUDENT SENATE FOR
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
AND SUPPORT.
CAN I CAP WITH RESISTED STUDENTS
SUMMERSIDE COLLAGEN SUPPORT.
PRIME MACLAINE INTO COMMUNITY
COLLEGE LIKE A CALIFORNIA AND
SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
ANY TWEENER.
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE [inaudible]
CENA.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
AT A MOTION BY MISTER IRWIN
SECOND BY MISTER LEVINE THANK
YOU TO THE AUTHOR FOR CONTINUING
TO BE A CHAMPION OF HOMELESS
STUDENTS.
OF MADAM SECRETARY IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEDINA.
MEDINA I CHOI.
CHOI I JONES SAWYER.
BLOOM HI BLOOM AYE GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I IRWIN -- WHEN I KILEY
LEVINE?
LEVINE I LOW LOW I PATTERSON
SANTIAGO WEBER [inaudible]
WEBER I JONES SAWYER HI.
AB PERMISSIBLE. NINE NINE ZERO
THAT BILL IS OUT.
LEAVE IT OPEN FOR ABSENT --
MEMBERS AND THEN TURNING TO
MISTER LOW.
FILE ITEM [inaudible]
EIGHT OH HOUSING SERVICE.
ALWAYS GET FILE ITEM.
TO YOU YOU ALSO HAVE FILE ITEM.
TO WHICH ONE WOULD YOU LIKE TO
PRESENT FIRST.
REALLY -- LET'S SEE.
AB.
ONE THIRTY HIGHER ED.
MISSION FILE ITEM.
TO ALL RIGHT.
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- MISTER
MEMBERS YOU SEEN THIS BEFORE
WITH RESPECT TO THE ABSENCES HE
BECKONING.
ESTABLISHING A COORDINATING
ENTITY I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A
VOTE AND HAVE WITNESSES TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS VS AND UP TO BAHT AND
I'M INTERIM EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
FOR CALIFORNIA COMPETES HIGHER
EDUCATION. FOR A STRONG ECONOMY --
IN THE INTERESTS OF TIME I'M
SUBMITTING WRITTEN TESTIMONY --
BUT THANK YOU -- PLEASE KNOW
THAT THAT RED HAT'S MONEY IS
THERE AS WELL AS AN ADDITIONAL
SUPPORTING DOCUMENT THAT WAS
REFERENCED IN THE BILL AND NOW
SIS AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU.
THE GOLF COURSE.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
BRIAN HOW WITH CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS WERE A
SUPPORT.
HANNAH RAKKESTAD BUT THE CAL
STATE STUDENT ASSOCIATION OUR
BOARD DOESN'T HAVE AN OFFICIAL
POSITION ON THE BILL -- BUT WE
SUPPORT AND CONCEPT THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON WHEN I THOUGHT OF
THIS MAGALI KINCAID WITH PUBLIC
ADVOCATES AND ALTHOUGH WE
HAVEN'T TAKEN A POSITION WE
APPLAUD THE EFFORTS FOR THE BILL
AND HAVE MADE.
SOME COMMENTS REGARDING PARTS OF
THE BILL AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE COMMITTEE AND
THE AUTHOR IN MAKING THESE
IMPROVEMENTS.
THANK YOU.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
AND I THINK WE'VE HEARD FROM
TWEETERS BUT ARE THERE ANY MORE
TWEETERS [inaudible]
SEEING NONE.
THE WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE A
STRICTLY AS PRIVATE.
SO WE HAD A MOTION BY MS IRWIN
SECOND BY MISTER JONES SAWYER.
I THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRING IT
FORWARD I THINK IN.
OUR OF MY LAST. SIX YEARS HERE
AS A MEMBER AND CHAIR OF THIS
COMMITTEE I SEE THE NEED SO
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS BILL.
FOR IT'S A MATTER SURGERY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEDINA AYE MEDINA AYE CHOI.
CHOICE I JONES SAWYER HI JONES
SAWYER I'D BLOOM.
BLOOM I GABRIEL -- WHEN I KILEY?
LEVINE LEVINE I LOW HIGH LOW AYE
PATTERSON SANTIAGO WEBER.
WEBER II. EIGHT ZERO THAT BILL
IS OUT WE WILL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS AND OUR MOVING TO
ITEM.
EIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
RESEARCH AND I UNDERSTAND THAT
THIS ALSO ENJOYS SAID DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION ON BOTH SIDES OF
THIS BILL WOULD ASSIST.
WITH THE TRANSFER OF SICK LEAVE
AND WITH AN IMPORTANT ASPECT TO
CONTINUE TO ENSURE THAT WE HAVE.
EDUCATORS WHO CAN TRANSFER
BETWEEN DISTRICTS AND A SEVEN AS
A FOR A FACULTY MEMBER I THINK
THIS IS.
A BE BENEFICIAL TO THE STATE AND
WITH ME HAVE OTHER WITNESSES TO
TESTIFY VERY BRIEFLY IN SUPPORT.
LEFT GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEDINA
AND REST OF THE COMMITTEE --
YEAH YES THE INFORMATION I SAW
THAT YOU ALREADY HAVE REALLY
EXPLAINS THE ISSUES QUITE
CLEARLY SO I DON'T NEED TO
EXPLAIN THEM ANY FURTHER BUT
I'LL JUST RELAY A LITTLE BIT OF
MY OWN EXPERIENCE -- THE RIDLEY
BILL IT'S EXPLAINED -- IN YOUR
INFORMATION -- WAS TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY FOURTEEN BUT I CAME OUT
OF MY LOCAL FERTILITY ANSWER
EXPERIENCE WE HAD TROUBLE WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION ACCEPTING
SICKLY FROM A PART TIME FACULTY
MEMBER.
WHO WAS CONSIDERING RETIREMENT
BUT WAS ALSO HOPING TO TRANSFER
HER SICK LEAVE SO?
THE PROBLEM IS BACK THEN IT WAS
ONE YEAR.
OF AND THAT WAS BASED ON K.
TWELVE WHERE BUT MOST K. TWELVE
DOT JOBS ARE FULL TIME AND YOU
CAN ONLY GO FROM ONE JOB TO
ANOTHER IN ITS NATURAL THING TO
TRANSFER YOUR SICK LEAVE.
WHEN YOU DO THAT BUT FOR A PART
TIME FACULTY AS YOU CAN READ --
THAT'S NOT THE CASE THEY NEVER
QUITE KNOW WHEN THEY'RE DONE
WITH ONE EMPLOYER AND ARE
STARTING WITH ANOTHER.
SO WE DID GET THAT BILL PASSED
WE GOT A THREE YEAR WE'RE HOPING
FOR A FIVE YEAR BUT A THREE YEAR
PERIOD.
THINK WE ONE OF THE FIVE BECAUSE
WE THOUGHT THAN ANY REEMPLOYMENT
RIGHTS THEY MIGHT HAVE A PART
TIME FACULTY MEMBER THOSE WOULD
HAVE EXPIRED AND THAT WOULD HAVE
BEEN OKAY.
BUT THE REALITY IS THAT PEOPLE
DON'T THINK ABOUT THIS ISSUE
UNTIL THEY GET TO RETIREMENT.
AND A LOT OF TIME MAY HAVE
PASSED BETWEEN ASSIGNMENTS AND
OTHER DISTRICTS.
IT'S DIFFICULT EVEN FOR FULL
TIMERS BUT IT'S JUST.
IMPOSSIBLE FOR PART TIMERS TO
KNOW THAT THEY SHOULD TRANSFER
THEIR SICK LEAVE.
SO ONE OF THE ARGUMENTS BACK
THEN WHEN WE WERE DOING THAT
OTHER BILL WAS THE DISTRICTS
SAID -- WE DON'T KEEP THOSE
RECORDS WELL THEY DO KEEP THOSE
RECORDS AND I'VE JUST RETIRED A
LITTLE OVER A YEAR AGO.
I GOT INFORMATION BACK FROM
LAUSD WHERE I STARTED AT
CRENSHAW HIGH SCHOOL TAUGHT FOR
FOUR YEARS.
NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR TO EIGHTY
EIGHT THEY HAD TO GO TO MICRO
FISH.
BUT THEY FOUND MY UNUSED SICK
LEAVE THAT I COULD TRANSFER NEWS
FOR RETIREMENT.
SO THIS IS THIS CAN BE DONE IT
SHOULD BE DONE -- WHEN I WORKED
WITH CAL STIRS ON THIS THEY WILL
SAY -- THIS IS AND EARNED A
BENEFIT AND THAT SHOULDN'T BE
TAKEN AWAY BY SOME ARBITRARY
TIME LIMIT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SEVEN A GOLDEN OF THE FACULTY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES WERE PROUD TO
SPONSOR THIS BILL AND I'M HERE
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU
MIGHT HAVE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS JENNIFER BAKER
WITH CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION ALSO IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL THIS IS BEEN AN ISSUE --
WE BONE ALSO WORKING ON FOR A
NUMBER OF YEARS WITH CAL STIRS
AND WE'RE VERY APPRECIATIVE OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW'S EFFORTS TO
TRY TO REMEDY THIS ISSUE I DO
WANT TO PLANT A SEED THAT THIS
IS.
NOT GOING TO BE THE END OF THIS
OVERALL DISCUSSION BECAUSE MR
HANSEN WAS VERY LUCKY IN THE
FACT THAT HIS DISTRICT.
HAS KEPT RECORDS AND ON BUT WE
ALSO KNOW THAT THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF DISTRICTS THEY MAY NOT
HAVE KEPT RECORDS OVER A NUMBER
OF YEARS WE HAVE HAD SOME
INCIDENTS WITH MEMBERS THAT HAVE
ACTUALLY TRIED TO GOING TO
RECIEVE.
RETRIEVE INFORMATION THE
DISTRICTS HAVEN'T HAD --
INFORMATION WHEN YOU. FOR SOME
DISTRICTS AND YOU GO BACK TEN
TWENTY YEARS IT CAN BE MORE
COMPLICATED AND WHEN YOU'RE PART
TIME FACULTY MEMBER YOU DON'T
NECESSARILY THINK THAT YOU HAVE
TO KEEP PAY STUB. FOR TEN TWENTY
OR EVEN THIRTY YEARS AND MANY
PART TIMEFACULTY MEMBERS HAVE
NOT REALLY UNDERSTOOD THE AS YOU
GO FROM DISTRICT TO DISTRICT --
THAT YOU HAVE TO TRANSFER THAT
SICK LEAVE AND SO NOW THAT MANY
FULL TIME FACULTY IN ADDITION.
OUR WHO USED TO BE PART TIME
FACULTY MEMBERS ARE STARTING TO
COME IN TO RETIREMENT THERE IS A
REALIZATION OF ALL I HAVE
SOMETHING THAT CAN BE USED TO
PURCHASE QUALIFIED SERVICE AND
CAL STIRS THE I DIDN'T EVEN
REALIZE SO.
IT IS GOING TO TAKE SOME TIME TO
TRY TO GO BACK TO REMEDY THE
SITUATION IN THE LONG RUN BUT
WERE EXTREMELY APPRECIATIVE OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW'S EFFORTS
AND APPRECIATE.
YOUR SUPPORT ON THIS BILL MOVING
FORWARD.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT JERRY
DEAN -- MEMBERS DAVID BELL
HAWKINS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
COLLEGE INDEPENDENCE -- ASK IF
YOU'RE AYE VOTE THANK YOU MISTER
LOWE.
DAVE ALL RATS REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA RETIRED TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT.
BRIAN HOW WITH CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS WERE
SUPPORT.
CAN REALLY RESONATE WITH SERVICE
EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL UNION IN
SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ANY TWO WINNERS.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE [inaudible]
MR CHOI.
THIS IS GOOD NEWS TO ME I DIDN'T
REALIZE I HAD THE SICK LEAVE AS
A PART TIME FACULTY MEMBER FOR
TWENTY YEARS I TAUGHT THAT I
NEED TO CALL BACK.
TO THIS YOU CAN **** NO MY
BENEFITS.
WELL MY GOD IS.
IN A NEW A I I I LOST A LOT OF
BENEFITS I I GUESS I NEED.
TO CALL BACK IN THE ****.
IS IT POSSIBLE.
MR LOW IF YOU SEE NO OTHER
QUESTIONS WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE I GET AND JUST LIKE THAT
THANK THIS ANSWER FOR DRIVING
ALL THE WAY UP -- TO HELP
TESTIFY ON THIS VERY POINT AS
SOON AS YOU CAN SEE THAT THIS
WOULD TRANSCEND THE NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT ISSUES AND GENERATION
SO WITH RESPECT TO ASK FOR I
FELT.
I DO HAVE A MOTION.
WE HAD A MOTION BY MISTER WHEN.
SECOND BY.
WELL DOCTOR CHOI ALL RIGHT.
AS A PART TIME FACULTY.
AND AS A TEACHER OF THIRTY FOUR
YEARS.
DOCTOR CHOI -- IT JUST A MATTER
OF FAIRNESS JUST A MATTER OF
FAIRNESS AND SICKLY ESPECIALLY
AS YOU MOVE TO RETIREMENT IS
LIKE BAY.
AND THERE SHOULD BE NO REASON
WHY YOU SHOULD ANYONE SHOULD
LOSE IT -- BECAUSE IT IS JUST
LIKE PAY AT THE END OF YOUR
CAREER -- IT SERVES -- FOR
LONGEVITY AND SENIORITY AND AND
RETIREMENT SO.
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THE THE BILL FORWARD AND MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEDINA AYE MEDINA AYE CHOI.
CHOI I JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER AYE BLOOM.
I GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I IRWIN.
IRWIN I KILEY LEVINE.
LEVINE I LOW HI LOW HI PATTERSON
SANTIAGO [inaudible]
WEBER [inaudible]
WEBER I NINE ZERO THE BILL IS
OUT [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
MEDINA AGAIN [inaudible] FIVE
FOR MEDINA TEMPLE IS BUILT ON
CONSENT [inaudible]
IN MOTION.
YEAH WITH.
YOUR OKAY ODDS GERMAN -- INDIAN --
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN EIGHTY SIX
NINE FIVE THE BILL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
AB SIX NINETY FIVE EXTENDS THE
CURRENT CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DESIGN BUILD STATUTE
UNTIL.
TWENTY THIRTY I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE.
YOU GOT IT.
WITNESSES ANY WRITTEN WORD IS.
WITH ME IS -- MARK MCDONALD.
THE TERM MEMBER MARK MCDONALD ON
BEHALF OF THE KERN FOOTHILL DE
ANZA PERALTA.
SAN BERNARDINO AND SAN DIEGO
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS ALL
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
REBECCA CURLY ON BEHALF OF THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE FACILITY
COALITION DESIGN BUILD
PROCUREMENT PROVIDES A GREAT
TOOL FOR COLLEGES TO DELIVER A
LARGE COMPLEX PROJECTS USING A
COLLABORATIVE PROCESS -- IT'S
THE BEST VALUE APPROACH THAT
ALLOWS US TO SELECT THE TEAM TO
DESIGN AND CONSTRUCT THE PROJECT
USING FACTORS IN ADDITION TO
COST INCLUDING QUALIFICATIONS.
EXPERIENCE AT CETERA -- WE
REALLYAPPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S
WILLINGNESS TO WORK WITH US --
THROUGH THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE SKILLED WORK FORCE
PROVISIONS THAT ARE VERY
APPRECIATIVE OF THE JULY ONE
IMPLEMENTATION STARTED ON THAT
PIECE OF THANK YOU.
AND WE ARCHER SUPPORT.
ADDITIONAL SUPPORTS PRIME
MACLAINE COMMUNITY COLLEGE TO
GET CALIFORNIA TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT.
JUSTIN SILICON THAT THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
CHANCES OFFICE IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
ANY OPPOSITION.
THERE IS A NAY HAD EARLY ON
BEHALF OF ASSOCIATED BUILDERS
AND CONTRACTORS OR IN CALIFORNIA
AND WE POSE [inaudible]
ANY OTHER.
OKAY -- BACK TO COMMITTEE
MEMBERS QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
OKAY IF NOT I HAVE A QUESTION
NOT OF IF WITH THIS IS THE BEST
RECOMMENDATION NOW WHY WAS THIS
NOT -- BEEN PRESENTED BEFORE AND
THE USED.
WOULD YOU MIND CLARIFYING THE
QUESTION THE BEST RECOMMENDATION
ON THIS IS THE DESIGN BUILD A
CONTRACT THOUGH SYSTEM.
YOU ARE SAYING THAT SOUGHT OUT.
BETTER SYSTEM -- NO WE DON'T
BELIEVE THAT IT'S A BETTER
SYSTEM BUT WE BELIEVE THAT
COLLEGES HAVE REALLY BENEFITED
FROM HAVING THE OPTION TO USE IT.
IT DOESN'T MAKE SENSE TO USE
THIS PURPOSE PROCUREMENT METHOD
FOR ALL PROJECTS BUT ESPECIALLY
FOR THOSE THAT ARE LARGE A VERY
COMPLEX AND CAN BENEFIT FROM.
A VERY COLLABORATIVE PROCESS
FROM THE BEGINNING TO DESIGN TO
BRING TOGETHER THE TEAM BUT
WE'LL BOTH DESIGN AND CONSTRUCT
THE PROJECT FROM THE OUTSET.
THERE ARE CERTAINLY BENEFITS TO
THAT APPROACH FOR SOME PROJECTS.
WE BELIEVE THAT IT SHOULD NOT BE
A MANDATE BUT IT CAN BE AN
OPTION -- FOR FOR SOME COLLEGES
THAT CHOOSE TO USE THAT APPROACH.
THIS IS A NON MANDATE JUST AN
OPTION CORRECTIVE OPTION YES I
SEE I WANT WHAT IT IS AN OPTION
THAT THEY CURRENTLY DO HAVE THE
AUTHORITY TO WHAT WAS NOT AN
OPTION BEFORE -- IN TWO THOUSAND
AND SEVEN COMMUNITY ALL
COMMUNITY COLLEGES RECEIVED THE
AUTHORITY TO USE THE THE DESIGN
BUILD PROCUREMENT.
PRIOR TO THAT THERE WERE A FEW
COLLEGES THAT HAD RECEIVED THE
AUTHORITY TO DO SO IN A PILOT
PROGRAM -- THERE ARE MANY OTHER
AND STATE AND LOCAL AGENCIES
THAT TO HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO DO
DESIGN BUILD THIS IS AN
EXTENSION OF THE AUTHORITY FOR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE PROJECTS.
IT'S A SUNSET THAT'S EXPIRING IN.
TWENTY TWENTY OKAY.
IF NOT THEN NANA WITHOUT CLOTHES.
AS FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
OKAY CLOAK OF THE STATE THE
MOTION.
THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED
TO THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEDINA.
HI MEDINA AYE CHOI AYE CHOI AYE
JONES SAWYER JONES SAWYER ANI
BLOOM.
BLOOM I GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I IRWIN -- WHEN I KILEY
[inaudible]
LEVINE.
LEVINE I LOW.
LOW I PATTERSON [inaudible]
SANTIAGO [inaudible]
WEBER [inaudible]
WEBER I DID TO PASS NINE ZERO
AND THE WOULD LEAVE IT OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS
.
DOUBLE.
ZERO SEVEN THE UNIT BACK AGAIN
OKAY.
OUR GERMAN DENY YOU HAVE -- ITEM
NUMBER THIRTEEN AB [inaudible]
EIGHT NINE SEVEN THANK YOU.
AB EIGHT NINE SEVEN WOULD CHANGE
THE PERCENTAGE OF HOURS THAT
PART TIME TEMPORARY EMPLOYEES
MAY TEACH. TO UP 285%.
THE HOURS PER WEEK A FULL TIME
EMPLOYEE HAS -- WE GO FULL TIME
EMPLOYEE.
WOULD HAVE.
UNDER THE 67% THRESHOLD MANY
FACULTY MEMBERS TEACH IN
MULTIPLE CLICK CAT CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT.
AT THE SAME TIME TO PIECE
TOGETHER FULL TIME SCHEDULE
LIMITING THEIR ABILITY TO
PARTICIPATE AND CAP ISN'T
COMMUNITY.
AND THE RESOURCES TO THEIR
STUDENTS -- TO TESTIFY WITH ME
AND FAVOR THE BILL IS JIM MAILER
PRESIDENT OF THE CFTC COMMUNITY
COLLEGE.
AND WENDY GROW. ONE COULD POINT.
TO POINT.
OKAY THIS.
ONE TO TESTIFY WITH ME.
GOING TO GO FIRST.
SURE FIRST MEMBER YESTERDAY.
I DON'T NEED.
TO HI GOOD AFTERNOON -- CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS OF THE ASSEMBLY
HIGHER ED COMMITTEE -- I AM WITH
YOU PER ONE TOO BUT I'M HERE
TODAY IN SUPPORT OF AB -- EIGHT
NINETY SEVEN I'M THE CURRENT
DEPARTMENT YOUR PHOTOGRAPHY A
COLLEGE OF THE CANYONS.
I AM THE ONLY FULL TIME FACULTY
MEMBER MY DEPARTMENT AS THE
MAJORITY OF THE COURSES THAT ARE
COLLEGE ARE TAUGHT BY PART TIME
FACULTY -- THIS IS TRUE.
BUT MOST OF THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICTS BEFORE
OBTAINING MY FULL TIME POSITION
ECOLOGY CANYONS IN ONE SINGLE
SEMESTER I TAUGHT A CLASS AT UC
IRVINE.
WHEN IT PEPPERED?
COLLEGE IN MALIBU AND ONE AT
CHIEF YOU COLLEGE IN ONTARIO.
THOSE OF YOU FROM THE NORTH
PROBABLY DON'T KNOW HOW FAR
THOSE ARE PART BUT THEY'RE FAR
APART -- I SPENT MORE TIME ON
THE FREEWAY PER WEEK THAN I DID
IN CLASS WITH MY STUDENTS BUT I
WAS LUCKY I WAS ABLE TO LAND A
FULL TIME JOB -- TEACHING
POSITION I'M HERE TODAY TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT
NINETY SEVEN BECAUSE MOST OF OUR
FACULTY ARE NOT SO LUCKY.
WHAT'S THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
PART TIME AND FULL TIME FACULTY
AT THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES PART TIME FACULTY CAN
TEACH UP 267%.
OF WHAT IS CONSIDERED A FULL
TIME LOW.
AT COLLEGE OF THE CANYONS LIKE
MOST COLLEGES A FULL TIME LOTUS
FIFTEEN TEACHING HOURS PER WEEK.
FOR PART TIME FACULTY THIS WOULD
BE UP TO TEN HOURS PER WEEK PER
SEMESTER.
MANY OF THE PART TIME FACULTY I
HIRED A COLLEGE THE CANYONS HAVE
BEEN WITH US FOR MORE THAN A
DECADE.
AND MANY ALSO TEACH AT
NEIGHBORING DISTRICTS OF INTER
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT AND
LOS ANGELES COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT WE AFFECTIONATELY
REFERRED TO THEM AS FREEWAY
FLYERS.
BUT THE REALITY IS THAT THEY
DON'T HAVE A CHOICE.
AND FOR A PROFESSIONAL POSITION
REQUIRING A MASTER'S DEGREE OR
HIGHER THIS LIMIT OF 67%
TRANSLATES INTO APPROXIMATELY
TWELVE THOUSAND DOLLARS PER
SEMESTER AT COLLEGE OF THE
CANYONS.
HARDLY ENOUGH TO COVER RENT IT'S
NOT JUST OUR STUDENTS THAT LIVE
IN THEIR CARS AND RELY ON PUBLIC
ASSISTANCE.
IT'S ALSO OUR PROFESSORS.
SOME OF MY FELLOW FACULTY HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT THIS BILL AND I'D
LIKE TO ADDRESS SOME OF THE
MISCONCEPTIONS.
BY COMPARISON THE UC'S AND CSU
SYSTEMS DO NOT HAVE A CAP.
IN PART TIME FACULTY HOURS THIS
BILL WOULD ALIGN THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES WITH OTHER --
INSTITUTIONS OF HIGHER EDUCATION
THE BILL DOES NOT AFFECT THE
GRANT GRANTING OF TENURE TENURE
IS A PRINCIPLE OF ACADEMIC
FREEDOM.
AND ACCORDING TO THE AMERICAN
ASSOCIATION OF UNIVERSITY
PROFESSIONALS IT SHOULD BE
AFFORDED TO ALL PROFESSORS
REGARDLESS OF THE NUMBER OF
HOURS THEY TEACH PER WEEK.
IT ALSO DOESN'T CHANGE THE
NUMBER OF CLASSES TAUGHT BY FULL
TIME AT THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
THE 7525% LAW ENACTED NINETEEN
EIGHTY EIGHT TO INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF SECTIONS TAUGHT BY
FULL TIME FACULTY 275%.
HAS CREATED AN ARTIFICIAL
CEILING WITH THE WITH THE
MANDATE OF DISTRICTS FULL TIME
OBLIGATION NUMBER OR FINE.
THE FINE WAS MEANT TO BE THE
FLOOR A BARE MINIMUM NUMBER FULL
TIME FACULTY AT EACH DISTRICT
HOWEVER DISTRICTS HAVE NO
INCENTIVE CENTER OF TO HIGHER
ABOVE THE FINE.
ON THIS BILL WILL NOT INCREASE
COSTS TO CAL STIRS OR HEALTH
CARE.
EXCUSE ME AB. EIGHT EIGHT NINETY
SEVEN WOULD ALLOW EACH LOCAL
DISTRICT TO COLLECTIVELY BARGAIN
FOR PART TIME FACULTY TO TEACH
UP 285% OF FULL TIME FACULTY AT
LOAD.
THE BILL WOULD ALLOW PART TIME
FACULTY TO DECIDE TO DEDICATE
MORE TIME TO TEACHING AT A
SINGLE CAMPUS AND LAST TIME
COMMUTING BETWEEN CAMPUSES.
PART TIME FACULTY WOULD HAVE
MORE TIME TO DEVOTE TO MEETING
WITH STUDENTS AND PARTICIPATING
IN THE GOVERNANCE THE COLLEGE.
RATHER THAN RUNNING OUT THE DOOR
TO DRIVE TO AN ADJACENT DISTRICT
PIECING TOGETHER A LIVING AND
ROLL DISTRICTS WHERE IT IS
DIFFICULT TO HIRE ENOUGH FACULTY.
AB EIGHT NINETY SEVEN WOULD
ALLOW COLLEGES TO OFFER CLASS
SECTIONS MORE CLASS SECTIONS TO
A SINGLE PART TIME FACULTY
MEMBER.
ALTHOUGH AB EIGHT NINETY SEVEN
DOES NOT ADDRESS THE NEED FOR
MORE FULL TIME FACULTY IT DOES
PROVIDE THE OPPORTUNITY FOR PART
TIME FACULTY TO HAVE A GREATER
IMPACT ON THE LIFE OF OUR
STUDENTS AND THEIR SUCCESS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
OKAY.
AS THE SECOND [inaudible]
WITNESS.
YEAH JIM MILLER -- PRESIDENT
COMMUNITY COLLEGE COUNCIL
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS -- TO ADD ON TO WHAT MY
COLLEAGUE JUST SAID.
AND THIS WILL ALSO BE A COST
SAVINGS TO DISTRICTS BECAUSE WE
WOULD HAVE.
FEWER HEADS TO YOU KNOW EMPLOYEE
BECAUSE OF EACH PERSON COULD
TEACH A HIGHER LOAD WE WOULDN'T
HAVE TO HIRE AS MANY PEOPLE.
IN EACH DISTRICT IT TAKE TEACH
THE SAME NUMBER OF CLASSES SO
THERE'D BE LESS OVERHEAD LESS
BUREAUCRACY FOR THE DISTRICTS --
TO DEAL WITH AND IT WOULD CREATE
A LITTLE BIT OF A BETTER
LIFESTYLE FOR ADJUNCT FACULTY
WHO ARE ALREADY.
NO PART OF A TWO TIER SYSTEM BUT
IT WOULD GIVE THEM A LITTLE BIT
MORE STABILITY.
LITTLE BIT MORE DEDICATION TO
THE INSTITUTION WHERE THEY COULD
DO A HIGHER LOAD AND NOT HAVE TO
TRAVEL THE FREEWAY AS MUCH.
SO I HOPE THAT YOU CAN ALL VOTE
IN FAVOUR THANK YOU.
BRIAN HOW THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS WERE ONE
OF THE CO SPONSORS OF THIS BILL.
OKAY ANY EDITION ARTIST SUPPORT
MEMBERS SO IN THE AUDIENCE.
ANY HIND SHANK LEGISLATIVE AND
POLITICAL DIRECTOR FOR THE
UNIVERSITY PROFESSIONAL AND
TECHNICAL EMPLOYEES
COMMUNICATIONWORKERS OF AMERICA
LOCAL NINETY ONE NINETEEN IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HI GENE ARE COMING PRESIDENT LOW
STRESS CALLS FEDERATION TEACHERS
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
STEPHANIE GOLDMAN OF THE FACULTY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES PROUD TO
SPONSORS [inaudible]
OKAY ANY [inaudible]
OPPOSITION WITNESSES.
OKAY IF NON AND NOT ALL MEMBER
QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
OKAY IF NOT ON WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE -- I THINK.
THE COMMITTEE HAS HEARD ME SAY
THAT COMMUNITY COLLEGES WOULD
NOT EXIST IF IT WAS NOT FROM THE
PART TIME FACULTY.
I THINK IN OUR LAST MEETING.
HERE WE HEARD FROM PART TIME
FACULTY BUT THE DIFFICULTY OF OF
MAKING ENDS MEET THE WHEN WHEN
THEY WERE TALKING ABOUT.
LOANS -- THIS COMMITTEE IS ALSO
MANY TIMES EXPRESS THE DESIRE
AND THE INTENTION OF THE
LEGISLATURE THAT WE INCREASE.
THE PERCENTAGE OF FULL TIME
FACULTY -- I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR I BOOKED [inaudible]
OKAY.
ON A STATE THE MOTION PLEASE.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
CALDERON.
MEDINA AYE MEDINA AYE CHOI AYE
CHOI AYE JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER I'D BLOOM.
BLOOM I GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I IRWIN -- WHEN I KILEY
LEVINE LEVINE I LOW?
LOW I PATTERSON SANTIAGO.
WEBER [inaudible]
WEBER I BILL PASSES TO IN NINE
NINE ZERO IN ONLY BE TO OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS [inaudible]
WHAT'S NEXT [inaudible]
SEVENTEEN CHAIRMAN YOU ARE VERY
BUSY YOU BEEN THE WORKING HARD
TO YOU HAVE ANOTHER ONE ITEM
NUMBER SEVENTEEN AB -- TEN
NINETY THE PRESENTATION
[inaudible]
OKAY.
THANK YOU AB TEN NINETY WOULD
AMEND THE ALLEN.
PADDY.
BUT T. SCHOLARSHIP ACT OF
NINETEEN SEVENTY WHICH WAS
CREATED TO ASSIST SURVIVING
FAMILY MEMBERS OF FIREFIGHTERS
AND LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS WHO
DIED IN THE LINE OF DUTY.
THE ACT WAVES ALL MANDATORY
TUITION AND SYSTEM WIDE FEES.
AT THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
HASTINGS COLLEGE OF LAW
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY AND
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
FOR THESE SURVIVORS.
AB TEN NINETY WILL EXPAND THE
EXISTING EXEMPTION.
FROM MANDATORY SYSTEM MY TUITION
AND FEES.
ALSO CAMPUS FEES BAYS ARE PROVED
AT THE CAMPUS LEVEL AND VERY
AMONG CAMPUSES.
AB EIGHT TEN NINETY WILL HAVE
THE FREE COSTS OF CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC COLLEGE OR UNIVERSITY
ELIMINATING ANY COST BURGERS FOR
SURVIVING FAMILY MEMBERS OF
FIREFIGHTERS.
AND LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS WHO
DIED IN THE LINE OF DUTY.
WITH ME TODAY IN SUPPORT IS YOU
VIA MENDOZA.
OF STUDENT SENATE OF CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND CHRISTY
BALMA REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS.
OKAY WITNESSES.
THE CAN GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS EVEN MENDOZA
AND I AM.
THE REGION.
THE LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS DIRECTOR
FOR REGION THREE FOR THE US
CALIFORNIA'S STUDENT SENATE.
AND I'M HERE TODAY TO ASK YOU
FOR YOUR SUPPORT -- FOR AB
[inaudible]
TEN NINETY SO -- JUST TO
REITERATE THE BILL RIGHT NOW IS.
BECAUSE THERE IS A LOOPHOLE IN
THE SYSTEM RIGHT NOW LEGISLATURE
CURRENT LEGISLATION.
IS.
BASICALLY WAVES TUITION FOR
STUDENTS WHO HAVE HAD PARENTS
WHO -- WHO LOST THEIR PARENTS IN
THE LINE OF DUTY AND?
THEIR TUITION IS WAIVED BUT NOT
THE MANDATORY FEES THAT WE HAVE
TO PAY A STUDENTS LIKE THE
CAMPUS SPACE FEES SO THESE FEES
CAN RANGE FROM.
I KNOW IT'S SOME COLLEGES THERE
LIKE ONE HUNDRED AND FORTY
DOLLARS BUT THEY CAN BE UP TO
TWO HUNDRED THREE HUNDRED
DOLLARS.
AND ON TOP OF ALSO PAYING FOR
BOOKS AND ANY OTHER THINGS MAYBE
TUTORING AND OTHER THINGS THAT
YOU MIGHT NEED TO GET IN.
A SUFFICIENT EDUCATION.
THINGS LIKE THIS CAN ADD UP AND
FOR AS WE KNOW STUDENTS WITH
SINGLE PARENTS.
HAVE OF LOWER GRADUATION RATE
FROM -- HIGHER EDUCATION IN POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION SO THIS IS
WHY WE'RE HERE TO ASK YOU FOR
YOUR SUPPORT ON THIS AND I HOPE
THAT YOU.
YES IN WITNESS.
THANK YOU MISTER MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE CHRISTY
BOMB ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS.
OF WE'RE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE THANK YOU MISTER MEDINA
FOR BRINGING IT FORWARD.
A AND WE TO SHARE THE CONCERN.
OF THE SPEAKER PREVIOUS SPEAKER
THAT THESE -- FEES AND IT WAS
WEBER STILL HOW TO WORK ON THE
TRANSLATION OF TUITION INTO
STUDENT FEES STUDENT SUCCESS
FEES FACILITY FEES.
STUDENT CENTER FEES A JUST A WAY
OF MAYBE BALANCING OUT MORE
INCOME FOR THE COLLEGES WHICH IS.
POTENTIALLY UNDERSTANDABLE BUT
MAKES REALLY DOMITIAN DIMINISHES
THE BENEFIT THAT IS AFFORDED TO
SURVIVING FAMILY MEMBERS WHEN
THEY SEEK THE TUITION WAIVERS
THAT HAVE BEEN PROVED BY THIS
LEGISLATURE PREVIOUSLY SO. FOR
THOSE REASONS WERE PROUD TO
SUPPORT THE BILL.
OKAY.
MOVED AND SECONDED ANY
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT.
FROM THE AUDIENCE BRIAN HOW THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS WERE IN SUPPORT.
STEPHANIE GOLDEN OF THE FACULTY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES IN SUPPORT.
KIM CALPERS FATE VOIGTS PRISON
LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS FOR THIS
INCIDENT FOR CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES IN SUPPORT.
MONTEL FLY FROM HERE BECAUSE I'M
PROUD TO DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
YANNIS JOHNSON IN THE PROTOCOL.
THE PROUD TO COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
HEATHER JOHNSON FROM SERENA'S
COLLEGE WITH CALIFORNIA'S
STUDENTS SENATE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND SUPPORT
[inaudible]
ANY OPPOSITION.
OKAY IF NON.
AND TO THE MEMBERS OF QUESTIONS
SO WAS STATEMENTS.
OKAY IF NON BAND -- MOTION HAS
BEEN MADE BY MEN BOOK I SEE --
AND SECONDED BY BLOOM.
YEAH MR BLOOM.
THE STATE THE MOTION PLEASE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
ALL THE ROLE.
MEDINA AYE MEDINA AYE CHOI AYE
CHOI AYE JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER I'D BLOOM.
BLOOM I GABRIEL.
APRIL I IRWIN.
IRWIN I HIGHLY.
I LEVINE LEVINE I LOW.
LOW I PATTERSON [inaudible]
SANTIAGO [inaudible]
WEBER [inaudible]
WEBER I IT PASSES THE TIME TO
ZERO AND LEAVE IT OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS [inaudible]
CONGRATULATIONS.
NEAR THE BILL BY THE CHAIRPERSON
[inaudible]
WHICH ONE OKAY.
CHAIRMAN YOU'VE BEEN WORKING SO
HARD TO HAVE ONE MORE A SINGLE
EXIT IS A LAST ONE OR OKAY -- IN
FRONT OF ITEM NUMBER NINETEEN
EIGHTY UP FIFTEEN ZERO FOUR A.
B..
FIFTEEN OH FOUR AB.
FIFTEEN OH FOUR WOULD GIVE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS THE
SAME KIND OF STUDENT
REPRESENTATION.
THAT WE SEE THAT CSU STUDENTS
AND YOU SEE STUDENTS HAVE.
YOU SEE STUDENTS AND CSU
STUDENTS HAVE THE ABILITY. TO
COLLECT [inaudible]
A FEE [inaudible]
HE FOR STUDENT ACTIVISM FOR
STUDENT -- LOBBYING ON THE
ISSUES THAT THE STUDENTS MOST
CARE ABOUT AND THEY USE THOSE.
AMONG OTHER THINGS TO COME HERE
AND INTERACT WITH US -- AND TO
BRING FORWARD THE THEIR CONCERNS
AND THEIR ISSUES.
AND SO I THINK IT IS A VERY
EFFECTIVE WAY THE CSU STUDENTS
AND YOU SEE STUDENTS HAVE -- TO
VOICE THEIR CONCERNS
UNFORTUNATELY COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS DON'T HAVE.
THE WAY OF COLLECTING MONEY FROM
THEIR STUDENT BODIES OF BECAUSE
IT TAKES A AN ELECTION ON THEIR
CAMPUSES.
SO RIGHT NOW ONLY ELEVEN OUT OF
THE HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CAMPUSES HAVE.
IMPLEMENTED A TWO DOLLAR FEE
WHICH IS WHAT THE STUDENTS ARE
ASKING FOR THE STUDENTS.
A VAST.
AND I'M HAPPY TO BE THE SPONSOR
OF THEIR BILL AB -- FIFTEEN FOR
THAT WOULD ALLOW COMMUNITY
COLLEGES TO IMPOSE A TWO DOLLAR
FEE SO THAT COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS COULD HAVE.
THE SAME REPRESENTATION APPEAR
AS A CSU AND YOU SEE STUDENTS SO
WITH ME TODAY.
IS [inaudible]
LEISHA.
YOUNGBLOOD.
I THINK YOU SHOULD AYE AYSHA.
EXCUSE ME.
PRESIDENT OF THE STUDENT SENATE --
FOR CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES [inaudible]
AND ALSO HERE TO TESTIFY ON
BEHALF OF THE BILL.
OKAY I WITNESS.
HI YEAH SO WE WOULD REALLY LIKE
YOUR SUPPORT IN THIS BILL SO
THAT WE CAN IN REALLY.
LEVERAGE OUR STUDENTS VOICE IS
AN ADVOCATE FOR THEM THE SAME
WAY OUR COUNTERPARTS AT THE UCSC
ISSUES DO CURRENTLY THIS
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
OPERATES AT A BUDGET OF LIKE
THIRTEEN CENTS PER STUDENT WHEN
WE REPRESENT TWO POINT ONE
MILLION STUDENTS IN THE SYSTEM.
VERSUS OUR COUNTERPART TO
OPERATE AT NEARLY THREE DOLLARS
PER STUDENT SO WITH THIS WE CAN
SPEND MORE TIME SACRAMENTO
LOBBYING FOR BILLS THAT REALLY
AFFECT US IN OUR STUDENTS -- WE
CAN DO REGIONAL.
SUPPORT AND LEADERSHIP TRAINING
WE CAN.
REALLY.
THE SKY'S THE LIMIT IF YOU HAVE
THE MONEY AND ULTIMATELY WE CAN
GET PROFESSIONAL STAFF BECAUSE
AT THIS POINT WHERE THE ONLY
STUDENT RUN ORGANIZATION THAT
LEAVES LITERALLY.
STUDENT RAN -- WE DO ALL OF OUR
MEETINGS OURSELVES LIKE
EVERYTHING SO WE WERE REALLY
LOOKING FOR YOUR SUPPORT IN THIS.
SEVEN WITH THE WITNESS
[inaudible]
SORRY.
HI -- COMMITTEE MEMBERS OF
ACTING CHAIR.
THIS IS WORKING OF MY NAME IS TO
BE FOUND AND I'M ALSO PART OF
THE STUDENT CENTER FOR
CALIFORNIA TWENTY COLLEGES.
I'M WITH REGION FOR WHICH COVERS
THE IS SO COMPELLING IT ALL
THROUGHOUT -- THE SOUTH BAY AND
SO WITH -- THE TWO SRF -- AS A
STRIP WILL SEE AS A WHOLE WOULD
HAVE SO MUCH MORE POTENTIAL TO
JUST GIVE BACK TO WHERE IT
CONSTITUENTS BASICALLY ALL TWO
POINT ONE MILLION OF THEM.
AND IT'S BASICALLY AN INJUSTICE
TO SEE AN ADVOCATE SEE WHEN YOU
COMPARE IT TO THE CSU AND YOU
SEE SYSTEM.
WHO RECEIVES A TIME FROM A TON
OF MORE MONEY THAN WE DO?
AND THEY'RE ABLE TO DO SO MUCH
MORE AND IN COMPARISON TO THAT
WE'RE JUST STRUGGLING.
TO REALLY HAVE A VOICE IS SET UP
TO THE CAPITOL IN SACRAMENTO --
OCCASIONALLY WE MIGHT BE ABLE TO
GO TO WASHINGTON DC AND SO YOU
SEE THE DISPARITY WHEN YOU
COMPARE THOSE. THREE SYSTEMS --
ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU BREAK IT
DOWN TO THE REGIONAL LEVEL --
AND SO THE BOARD OF DIRECTORS
WHICH ABOVE ME ARE MYSELF IN
ASIA SAID ON AYE AYSHA OF
OVERSEAS EVERYTHING IN BUT WHEN
IT COMES TO THE REGIONS --
MYSELF REPRESENTING VISION FOR
AS THE REGIONAL AFFAIRS DR -- WE
HAVE OUR OWN INDIVIDUAL BUDGET
AND THAT BUDGET IS VERY VERY
SMALL AND WE MAKE THE BEST WITH
WHAT WE HAVE.
BUT THAT ALSO LIMITS OUR
CAPABILITY AND HOSTING EVENTS --
GOING TO CONFERENCES --
ATTENDING DIFFERENT CONFERENCES
THAT MAY BE TOO FAR AWAY AND
REQUIRE EXTENSIVE TRAVEL AND WE
ALSO HAVE ISSUES WITH JUST.
GETTING DIFFERENT DISTRICTS TO
SUPPORT.
OUR REGION BECAUSE EACH
INDIVIDUAL COLLEGES ALSO
STRUGGLING IN SOME WAY -- DUE TO
FINANCIAL RESTRICTIONS AND SO
I'M REALLY HERE TODAY TO REALLY
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT AND AB
FIFTY NO FOUR THANK YOU.
IN ADDITION ORDER.
SUPPORT SO FROM THE AUDIENCE.
SEVEN GOLDEN AT THE FACULTY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND SUPPORT.
CAN MY CAR WITH WAVY P. OF
LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS THIS INSIDE
OF CALIFORNIA'S ME CARTER'S.
CLERK FOR THE ASSOCIATED SINCE
SUMMERSIDE COLLEGE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR SUPPORT.
MICHELLE HALL REPRESENTATIVE
FROM THE FACILITY AND THE
DISTRICT BEING TWO OF THE ELEVEN
COLLEGES THAT PAY INTO THE TO
ANSWER IF WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
OTHER JOHNSON FROM CERRITOS
COLLEGE IN SUPPORT.
HI CAN YOU HEAR ENDOZA IN A
CLUB COUNCIL CHARITABLE VALLEY
COLLEGE BEING ONE OF THE
COLLEGES THAT PAYS THIS BE WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT.
DANNY THEIR COAST INTERESTED FOR
LOS RESIDENTES STUDENT AT
SACRAMENTO CITY COLLEGE IN
SUPPORT.
MONTEL CAUGHT MONTEL FLIGHT FROM
PRAGUE TO UNIFY -- TO ME
COLLEGES SO SUPPORT.
MAGALI KINCAID WITH PUBLIC
ADVOCATES IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THE AMISH JOHNSON FOR MERRITT
COLLEGE IN STRONG SUPPORT AND
ALSO THE REGION THREE TEAR THAT
HAS THE ELBOW VALLEY COLLEGE
CONTRA COSTA.
AND ELHAM SEE THE OLD ONE OF THE
ELEVEN COLLEGES THAT ARE
SUPPORTING.
HI TWENTY ROLLING COOPER IS A
FACULTY MEMBER AT THE CAN'T
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
ONE WHO LOVES HER STUDENTS I
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY OPPOSITION THIS.
OKAY IF NOT THEN THE MEMBERS
QUESTIONS -- IF NOT THEN I HAVE
A QUESTION -- IF.
FOR THIS BILL OF PASSES SO THAT
WILL.
ELIMINATE THE REQUIREMENT OF
DESTROYING THE SENATE TO VOTE
THAT THE THROUGH THE ELECTION
NIGHT FOR ANY ASSESSMENT FEES
SAYS THAT THOUGH YOU HAVE TO GO
THROUGH THE SENATE MEMBERS.
MORE ON THAT.
NO SO WHAT THIS. TO DO SO
CURRENTLY IN ED COAT THE WAY
THAT THE FEES IMPLEMENTED ON
CAMPUS IS THAT EACH A HUNDRED
AND FOURTEEN ASSOC.
BUT STUDENT BODIES HAVE TO VOTE
ON IT IN.
IT'S IT'S LIKE STRENUOUSLY LIKE
DOESN'T WORK SO THIS WOULD
IMPLEMENT THE FEE AS I OPT OUT
SO STUDENTS STILL HAVE THE
ABILITY TO OPT OUT FROM THE FEE.
OKAY I WONDER IF INDIVIDUAL
STUDENTS.
INDIVIDUALS.
TO THIS ELECTION IS SO WHAT THE
CAMPUS BASED -- ARE SYSTEM WIDE.
THE SPACE CAMPUS BASED.
MONA STERN SENATE MEMBERS MIGHT
KNOW THE WHOLE STUDENT BODY
HOLSTER ON BODY I SEE.
SO IT HAS -- GIVEN YOU --
DIFFICULTY TO ROUTE TO CHARGE
TWO DOLLARS.
YEAH IF I MAY.
RESPOND MOST RECENTLY.
AS A ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY AND
I HAVE BEEN WORKING AND SUB ONE
ON ON TRYING TO REFORM OF THE
CAL GRANT -- PROGRAM -- WE'VE
SEEN STUDENTS COME FROM UC CSU.
IN LARGE NUMBERS.
AND I THINK THEY COME IN LARGE
NUMBERS BECAUSE THEY HAVE A
SYSTEM IN PLACE FOR STUDENT
REPRESENTATION THEIR STUDENT
ORGANIZATIONS THAT REPRESENT
THEM.
A MOBILIZE THE STUDENTS AT BOTH
OF THOSE SYSTEMS AND WHEN WE HAD
TWO DIFFERENT DAYS ONE FOR CSU
STUDENTS.
AND ONE FOR UC'S STUDENTS AND
THERE WERE HUNDREDS OF STUDENTS.
FROM EACH OF THOSE -- IT SYSTEMS
ON THOSE DAYS.
BUT WHEN IT COMES TO TRYING TO
GET COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS
HERE -- TOO ALSO LOBBY ON ON
ISSUES THAT ARE MOST AFFECTING
THEM IT IS DIFFICULT TO GET
STUDENTS TO COME HERE.
BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE THE
EQUIVALENT KIND OF ORGANIZATIONS
BECAUSE IT IS SO DIFFICULT FOR
THEM TO IMPOSE.
THIS TO DOLLAR FEES THAT WOULD
HELP THEM ORGANIZE.
SO I I I I SEE THAT AS A THE
REASON WHY THIS BILL IS IS
NEEDED.
YEAH I UNDERSTAND THE NEED FOR
THE FUND FOR THE SPIRIT.
STUDENT REPRESENTATIVES OF TOTAL
WATER LAPPING WORK.
AND WORK WITH THE CAPITAL APPEAR
A WEAVER.
I AM A LITTLE BIT CONCERNED
ABOUT THE ELIMINATING THE
DEMOCRATIC PROCESS.
AND THE GOVERNMENT IS SUCH
TRYING TO IMPOSE.
YOU YOU HAVE NO RIGHT TO VOTE
THE DETERMINE THAT YOU OR YOUR
OWN SHE SAID IN THE WE MANDATING
THEM.
JUST THE TWO CHARGES ANY STORE
IN TWO DOLLARS EVEN THOUGH
THAT'S A SMALL AMOUNT.
AND THEN A THAT'S MY FEELING AND
THE SECOND SECOND QUESTION IS
THAT THE US YES YOU AND DO YOU
SEE IT -- STUDENTS SO DO THEY
DETERMINE THE FEES SO ARE HAVE
WE DECIDED THEIR FEES I I I
DON'T KNOW FOR SURE DOCTOR CHOI
BUT I WOULD NOT BE SURPRISED IF
THE STUDENTS.
DON'T DETERMINE THE FEE
THEMSELVES BUT I I I DON'T KNOW
ABSOLUTELY -- THIS IS STUDENTS
AND THE STUDENT ORGANIZATION.
I THINK THAT SPEAK ON BEHALF OF
STUDENTS -- TRYING TO MAKE IT
EASIER -- FOR THEM TO HAVE
BETTER REPRESENTATION HE I YEAH
I HEARD THEM -- BUT THE THIS IS
SO IN THE SPIRIT OF WHAT A
DEMOCRACY.
IS A SELF GOVERNING AND THE HERE
GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS A STATE
LEGISLATURE TRIED TO TELL THEM
MICHAEL MANAGING STUDENTS --
DECISION ON FEES RIGHT AND AN
END TO THAT I I WOULD.
JUST SAY THIS THIS WAS NOT A
BILL THAT I THOUGHT UP THIS WAS
NOT A BILL.
THAT.
I THOUGHT OF THE STUDENTS CAME
TO ME.
AND ASKS ME.
I THINK FOR THE REASONS THAT
DAVE EXPRESS.
IF I WOULD.
ON THEIR BEHALF.
OF BRING THIS BILL FORWARD WHICH
I WAS HAPPY TO DO.
SO IT CAME FROM THE STUDENTS.
OKAY I UNDERSTAND DOT OUR
SUPPORT IF THE COST IS A TWO
DOLLARS.
EACH PERSON IS A SMALL AMOUNT
THE AND THAT THAT CAN GIVE THEM
THE ABILITY. TO DO THE JOB BUT
THEY ARE CURRENTLY DOING AND THE
DUST IN IMPORTANT BUT I I THINK
YOU NEED -- TO CANNOT TELL A US
TOUR AND SENATE.
WE DID NOT THE VOLUNTEER TO TO
ELIMINATE THEIR RIGHT TO
DETERMINE THEIR SELF ASSESSMENT.
IT IS A MORE OFFER YOU ARE
ADVOCATING TO US HEY YOU.
MAKERS CHARGE YOU YOU
LEGISLATORS SO YOU YOU DEMAND US
UP THE REQUIRE US TO TO PAY TWO
DOLLARS SO SO BLAME IS -- FORTY
ONE MY LAPSE.
IS TERRIBLE.
ODYSSEUS IS IT SHOULD HAVE BEEN
NOT MORE OF A SELF DETERMINATION
BY THE STATE RUN BODY.
YOU KNOW IF YOU NEEDED IT.
DâN NON THEY SHOULD BE EASY. TO
DETERMINE THE TWO DOLLARS THE
STAFF ASSESSMENT.
BUT THE WE ARE TELLING THEM HEY
YOU GUYS EVERYBODY YOU DON'T PAY
TWO DOLLARS SO SO THAT'S A
LITTLE BIT STOP BOTHERING ME AS
TO IN THE DEMOCRATS DEMOCRATIC
WHY DO THEY HAVE WESTERN SET. TO
BEGIN WITH.
I UNDERSTAND YOUR POINT
[inaudible]
OKAY.
AND THEN -- AND IS A SECOND
[inaudible]
THIS.
THIS THIS FREE SYSTEM EXIST AT
THE C. ISSUES.
AND THE UC'S -- AND THEY HAVE TO
COME TO US TO GET THIS.
THIS SELFIE THAT THAT THAT
THEY'RE ASKING FOR OUR AND SO
YOU SEE ISSUE YOU SEE A FEW
YEARS AGO I KNOW THEY WENT FROM
ONE DOLLAR TO TWO DOLLARS.
A REYES IT ONE DOLLAR THEY HAD
TO COME TO US TO DO IT BECAUSE
THERE'S SOME.
SOME ISSUES IN THE LAW THAT
PREVENTS THEM FROM DOING THESE
EXTRA THINGS LIKE THIS ON THEIR
OWN -- AND AS A RESULT COMMUNITY
COLLEGES WERE NOT INCLUDED.
THIS IS NOT IN COMMON THE
STUDENT COMMITTEE COLLEGE IT'S
COME NOW TO ASK TO BE TREATED
LIKE THIS ISSUE IN THE UC. TO
HAVE FUN SO THEY CAN RUN THEIR
STUDENT ORGANIZATION THAT ANY
STUDENT ON THE CAMPUS CAN DECIDE
THEY DON'T WANT TO PAY THE TWO
DOLLARS.
AND THEY DON'T HAVE.
TO ALSO IT'S ALMOST LIKE A FEE
THAT IS AN OPTIONAL FEE BECAUSE
WHEN YOU WHEN YOU REGISTER YOU
SAY KIND OF LIKE IF YOU FOLLOW
NEW TAXES AND YOU WANT TO GET
SOME MONEY FOR CAMPAIGNS
WHATEVER YOU CAN'T.
THAT'S AN OPTION BUT IT'S NOT A
REQUIREMENT SO NOW THEY HAVE
THIS OPTION THAT THEY CAN DO AT
THIS STUDENT SAY YEAH I'LL GIVE
TWO DOLLARS TO THE STUDENT BODY.
THEN A DOLLAR THAT HAS TO GO TO
THE ASSOCIATION -- WHAT THEY
DIDN'T HAVE THAT OPTION BEFORE
IN THE C. ISSUE HAS IT AND THE
UC HAS IT AND THAT'S WHY THEY
SAYING THAT THOSE CAMPUSES ARE
MUCH MORE ACTIVE?
MORE ENGAGE CAN GO TO WORKSHOPS
AND SEMINARS TO HELP THE
STUDENTS TO GROW AS STUDENTS
BECAUSE THEY HAVE THIS MONEY IN
THE SYSTEM THAT COMES FROM FEET
FROM FROM A STUDENT FEE OF TWO
DOLLARS.
WE GET A DOLLAR BUT FOR THEIR
ASSOCIATION BUT A STUDENT CAN
SAY I DON'T WANT TO PAY JUST
LIKE YOU DON'T HAVE TO CHECK
THAT BOX WHEN YOU FILE YOUR IS
THE TRUTH CHIP GERMAN.
THIS IS OPTIONAL BUT IF THEY
HAVE A OPT OUT I HAVE NOT TAKEN
UP YEAH.
ABOUT THINGS I'M NOT GOING I
DON'T WANT TO IT YEAH BUT IT'S
NOT AN OPT IN BUT IT'S NOT BAD
OKAY IF THIS OF THE HOUSES OUT
OF THE NOT THE OPTION IN THE AIR
YEAH THEY DO.
SO I I THINK THAT'S MORE
FLEXIBLE.
OKAY THEN NOT WE USED A
PROMOTION PLEASE.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
OKAY CALDERON.
MEDINA AYE MEDINA AYE CHOI AYE
CHOI AYE JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER I BLOOM.
BLOOM I GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I IRWIN -- WHEN I KILEY
[inaudible]
MR KILEY.
MR KILEY NOT VOTING [inaudible]
LEVINE [inaudible]
LOW [inaudible]
PATTERSON [inaudible]
SANTIAGO.
WEBER HI WEBER I BILL PASSES
SEVEN ZERO AND ONLY BEEN OPEN
FOR SOME MEMBERS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER MISTER MEDINA.
ARE YOU ALL DONE.
THE THING
.
WE'RE GONNA BEGIN -- ADD ON
STARTING WITH THE CONSENT.
CONSENT CALENDAR KILEY
[inaudible]
KILEY AYE. TWELVE ZERO THE
CONSENT.
CALENDAR IS OUT.
ITEM ONE A. B..
FIFTEEN KILEY [inaudible]
KILEY I AB FIFTEEN TWELVE ZERO
THAT BILL IS OUT.
I AM TOO AB ONE THREE ZERO
GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I KILEY.
KILEY AYE PATTERSON SANTIAGO.
AB ONE THIRTY TEN ZERO THAT BILL
IS OUT.
ITEM FOUR AB.
THREE ZERO TWO JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER I AB THREE OH TWO
TEN ZERO THE BILL IS OUT.
ITEM FIVE AB THREE SIX NINE
KILEY.
KILEY NO LOW.
AB THREE SIXTY NINE EIGHT TWO
THE BILL IS OUT [inaudible]
ITEM.
SEVEN AB.
SIX NINE FIVE KILEY [inaudible]
HIGHLY NO [inaudible]
PATTERSON SANTIAGO [inaudible]
SANTIAGO I AB SIX NINETY FIVE
TEN ONE THE BILL IS OUT.
ITEM EIGHT AB SEVEN ZERO SIX
KILEY.
KILEY I PATTERSON SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO II.
AB SEVEN OH SIX ELEVEN ZERO THE
BILL IS OUT.
ITEM NINE AB EIGHT ZERO SIX
KILEY.
KILEY I PATTERSON SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I AB EIGHT OH SIX
ELEVEN ZERO THAT BILL IS OUT.
ITEM ELEVEN AB EIGHT FOUR THREE
BLOOM.
BLOOM I KILEY.
KILEY I AB EIGHT FORTY THREE
TWELVE ZERO BILL IS OUT.
ITEM THIRTEEN AB.
EIGHT NINE SEVEN KILEY.
KILEY I PATTERSON SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I'D.
AB EIGHT NINETY SEVEN ELEVEN
ZERO THAT BILL IS OUT.
ITEM [inaudible]
FOURTEEN EIGHTY NINE FOUR THREE
APRIL.
GABRIEL I KILEY.
KILEY NOT VOTING [inaudible]
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO HI.
AB NINE FOUR THREE ELEVEN ZERO
ILL IS OUT.
ITEM SIXTEEN AB.
TEN FIFTY ONE JONES SAWYER HI
JONES SAWYER AYE KILEY.
KILEY I SANTIAGO [inaudible]
SANTIAGO AYE.
AB TEN FIFTY ONE TWELVE ZERO
BILL IS OUT.
ITEM SEVENTEEN AB [inaudible]
TEN NINETY PATTERSON
[inaudible]
SANTIAGO [inaudible]
SANTIAGO HI.
AB EIGHT TEN NINETY ELEVEN ZERO
BILL IS OUT.
ITEM EIGHTEEN AB ELEVEN FIFTY
JONES SAWYER HI JONES SAWYER I'D
HIGHLY.
KILEY NOT VOTING [inaudible]
PATTERSON SANTIAGO [inaudible]
SANTIAGO I AB ELEVEN FIFTY TEN
ZERO BILL IS OUT.
ITEM NINETEEN AB [inaudible]
FIFTEEN OH FOUR LEVINE
[inaudible]
LOW [inaudible]
PATTERSON [inaudible]
SANTIAGO [inaudible]
SANTIAGO I'D.
AB FIFTY NO FOUR EIGHT ZERO BILL
IS OUT.
I AM TWENTY AB SIXTEEN OH SIX
GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I IRWIN -- WHEN I KILEY
[inaudible]
KILEY NO [inaudible]
PATTERSON SANTIAGO [inaudible]
SANTIAGO I
AB SIXTEEN OH SIX TEN
TO ONE BILL IS OUT.
ITEM TWENTY ONE AB.
SIXTEEN TWENTY THREE KILEY.
KILEY I SANTIAGO [inaudible]
SANTIAGO I'D.
A. B. SIXTEEN TWENTY THREE
TWELVE ZERO BILL IS OUT.
ITEM TWENTY TWO AB SIXTEEN FORTY
FIVE KILEY.
HIGHLY NO PATTERSON SANTIAGO
[inaudible]
SANTIAGO I I DON'T KNOW
RIGHT.
AB SIXTEEN FORTY FIVE NINE ONE
THE BILL IS OUT [inaudible]
ITEM.
I AM TWENTY THREE AB SEVENTEEN
FORTY GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I IRWIN -- WHEN I KILEY?
KILEY I PATTERSON SANTIAGO
[inaudible]
SANTIAGO I'D.
AB SEVENTEEN FORTY ELEVEN ZERO
BILL IS OUT.
I'D [inaudible]
THE FACT [inaudible]
THURMOND [inaudible]
YES.
YOU KNOW YOU CAN.
YOU GOT.
THAT.
ARE YOU BOTH LOOKING.
THE CARD MORE [inaudible] FOR
MORE
[inaudible]
ROGER